hey everyone dear volume here and in
today's video i've decided to cover the
majority of the unanimated arcs from
throughout the entire kamitsu-nayova
story to do this we will be covering the
entire entertainment district arc
swordsmith village arc kashira training
arc infinity castle arc and finally the
sunrise countdown arc the series here is
truly packed with a continuous feed of
just breathtaking action and an in-depth
floor which spans over a thousand years
and finally comes to an end in such an
extremely satisfying way that it just
hits everyone in the right spots so just
before we do get into the video if you
are new around here and want to keep up
to date with the latest anime series
explained videos just like this then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with
pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
let's get into the beautiful world that
is demon slayer so four months after the
mugen train incident and the passing of
rengoku all three boys had been
relentlessly training at the butterfly
mansion and occasionally going on
missions so that they could improve
their strength tanjuro says that they're
able to endure all of their training
since the boys are together later after
completing one of his solo missions
tanjuro approaches the butterfly mansion
to hear the screams of the young girls
inside inside the property aoe and naho
screamed to be let go after the sound
hashira tengan uzoi picked them up and
started to take them away while the
other girls and their plea for their
freedom aoi calls out to kano to try and
help save them initially hesitant on
what to do kanel makes the decision to
chase after uzoi and she grabs a hold of
the girls tengan looks at kano and tells
her to obey her orders but when she
doesn't respond to him he becomes
aggravated and starts to call her a
stuck-up pig the other girls get scared
by his screaming but they all manage to
muster up their courage to swarm him and
stop him from kidnapping aoe and naho at
this point tanjuro enters the property
and although he initially gets confused
as to what's going on he decides to head
butt tengen in order to free the girls
however as he goes to make contact
tengen escapes the head bar flying above
them and revealing that he previously
used to be a ninja tanjiro angrily
demands that uzui returns the girls
wakiyo and sumi continuously assault him
with names because of this tengen
becomes even more riled up at their
disrespect and he demands that they obey
him as their superior officer
however tangero stubbornly refuses to
acknowledge tengen as his superior
causing him to explode with anger while
seething with anger tengan explains that
he needs female corpse members in order
to carry out his mission he then states
that since they aren't sukuko he doesn't
need to ask shinobu for permission to
take the girls keo cries out that naho
isn't a corpse member so tengen just
tosses her off the roof and decides to
only take aoi still not pleased with the
outcome tangero demands that he gives up
aoi and instead he will go in her place
and with almost perfect timing senetsu
and inosuke arrive to help protect the
girls also offering to go on the mission
in place of them uzui ends up giving in
and whacks aoe on the back as he returns
it to the girls as the boys set off on
the mission they ask tengan where
exactly they are going to which he says
the flashiest place in japan steeped in
lust and ever ice ultimately revealing
that they are heading towards the one
and only entertainment district
before arriving outside the
entertainment district tengen begins
instructing the trio and establishes
himself as the leader of the three young
demon slayers he then specifically
states his status as a god and demands
that they all bow scrape and evert their
eyes being genuinely intrigued tanjoro
falls for the tengan's flamboyance and
asks what it is that uzuwi rules over as
a so-called god sensing the complete
absurdity of the scenario zenitsu
concludes that uzui is a bad sign and is
left speechless by just how gullible
tangero truly is tengen explains that he
is the god of festivals and upon hearing
this inosuki loudly introduces himself
as the god of the mountain trying to
imply that they are both on equal ground
but this disgusts uzui he then instructs
the group to follow him to a wisteria
house there they will discuss their
plans then in almost an instant he
sprints off and vanishes leaving the
group to chase after him in a complete
panic once they arrive at the wisteria
house tengan asks the group to be on a
lookout for a young lady he could marry
which infuriates zenitsu he angrily
tells tengen to stop screwing around and
stop using members of the corpse to be
his matchmakers tengan blows up and
yells that he doesn't need a matchmaker
since he's already married and that
they're searching for his wives who have
failed to respond to his letters zenitsu
who doesn't believe it tells tenkan to
stop spreading his fantasies causing
tenkin to angrily whack him in the face
with a pile of letters tanjuro begins to
sift through all of the letters noticing
the large quantity he comments that she
must have been a fast writer to which
tengan clarifies that the large quantity
is due to the fact that he has three
wives after hearing this zenitsu's head
erupts and fills with rage thinking that
the tenkan is lying he demands to know
how he could possibly have three wives
tenkin gets angry at his remarks and
punches zenitsu in his stomach with such
force that it renders him completely
unconscious tangible begins to ask how
they plan on sneaking into the district
leaving their tengan to explain that
they will be disguised his wives which
okunowichi were originally stationed
there after he himself failed to find
any leads as a customer but after they
narrowed down a few possible locations
of where the demon might be they lost
all communication overhearing the
situation anoski bruntly asks what if
his wives are already dead to which
tengen also punches him in the stomach
knocking him unconscious as well within
the entertainment district a majority of
the workers are individuals who were
sold into the business due to poverty
and deaths as a courtesan their job is
to appeal and entertain customers so
they can eventually find a wealthy man
who is willing to buy their freedom the
highest classification of a courtesan is
an orien who is considered to be the
most artistic beautiful and educated and
is thus only ever reserved for the
wealthiest of customers as the group
finally arrives tengan uses his charming
looks to give away the boys who were
disguised as girls and is initially
successfully able to give tanjiru away
to their tokito house tengen then
proceeds down the street with the other
two boys following behind anosuke and
uzoi notice a courtesan procession
coming towards them on this tree and
learned that the aurian named konowatsu
is on her way to greet asuto zenitsu
notices the orion and angrily yells
tengan demanding to know if that's his
wife as well which ends up earning him
another punch in the face a woman
approaches tengen and asks him if he is
looking for a house and offers to take
inosuke into the ogimoto house to which
tengen accepts standing there alone
zinetsu fearfully starts to realize that
he is the only one left with the hashira
skipping over to the ogimoto house where
two women are clapping for joy at just
how beautiful enosuke is after removing
her makeup due to this they become
motivated to educate him and transform
him to become the most popular orion
within the district
meanwhile in the kyogoku house zenitsu
is in the middle of putting on an
emotional performance with a shamasian
after being abandoned by tengen uzui and
at the tokito house tangido is assisting
in doing household chores the staff asks
tanjiro to carry the orion's belongings
up to her room which he does so happily
when he arrives at the room he discovers
two young girls gossiping inside and
overhears them talking about ashinuko
confused tanjiro asks what it is the
girls explain that ashinoke is when a
courtesan runs off with a customer
without paying off their debts they also
mention a rumor that suma the most
recent courtesan had run away which
catches tangero's attention just then
koenatsu walks into the room and tells
the girls to stop gossiping and thanks
tanjuro for carrying up her belongings
she gives him a piece of candy to
express her gratitude and tanjiru
decides to ask her if the rumor
regarding soma was true or not koenigsu
looks stunned by the sudden question and
asks him why exactly he's asking her
tangido panics and lies telling her that
suma is his older sister but due to
sanjido being unable to lie he pulls a
sour face and ends up frightening all of
the girls koenatsu again questions
tanjido if he was sold into the house
just like his sister causing him to
again uncomfortably lie that he was in
fact sold and was exchanging letters
with suma koinatu reluctantly tells
tangido that she does not believe suma
would run away however when they
discovered her diary in her desk she had
written that she was planning on running
away she also reveals that there has
been no information regarding if she
hasn't managed to escape or not tanjidu
begins to speculate that it could be the
demon that was creating the facade that
suma had run away and might possibly be
responsible for implanting the diary he
then prays for her safety and promises
to himself that he will find a way to
help her at a similar time in the
district tengen is seen on the top of a
roof watching the activity of the public
he fails to notice any unusual activity
and can't help but have a bad feeling on
the lack of action and proceeds to
speculate that the demon must be strong
due to its ability to hide its presence
back at the okimoto house enosuke is
starting to investigate the whereabouts
of makio and overhears two women
conversing in front of makio's room the
woman begins to gossip that makio was
feeling unwell and had not left her room
for the entire day anosuke begins to
speculate on the information and
proceeds down the hall however he
becomes infuriated at having to wear the
uncomfortable kinemon during the hot
weather and recalls tengan's threats
before the boys had separated tenkin had
threatened him not to strip down or
speak due to his deep voice making it
harder for inosuke to gather information
inside makio's room an ominous voice is
seen questioning a woman who she was
sending letters to a large obi-like
demon is then seen holding the woman
hostage the demon calls the woman by her
name revealing the hostage to be makio
while being held hostage by the ob demon
makio tries to formulate a plan to try
to escape however the demon senses
inosuke snooping in the hallway and
decides to make an escape itself inosuke
senses the change in the atmosphere and
rushes into the room he discovers the
room is destroyed and senses the demon
is hiding in the ceiling as the demon
tries to escape enosuke begins to give
chase and rushes down the hallway as he
prepares to turn down the hallway he
decides to punch a hole in the wall in
order to pull the demon out however when
he swings a customer comes into the
clearing and unknowingly gets punched
into the wall the staff look in horror
as zanowski looks around to try and find
the demon but to his frustration he
loses size of it and blames the customer
over at the kyogoku house zinetsu calms
down after his emotional performance and
begins to search for hinatsuru due to
the fact that the staff had been
mourning the manager's death he's had
trouble collecting any information on
her possible whereabouts so far
susanetsu decides to use his advanced
sense of hearing in order to listen to
try and find any information on what's
going on in doing so he overhears a girl
quietly sobbing and rushes to try and
find her when he arrives he discovers
the room is completely destroyed and the
girl is disheveled in the middle of it
he approaches her but she begins to sob
again causing zinetsu to frantically try
to comfort her as he's kneeling on the
ground zenitsu suddenly gets chills and
sends the sunning approach from behind
him the orion of the house warabahime
glares down at him and coldly demands
what business he has in her room without
turning around zinetsu recognises the
sound that she has giving off is not
human and realizes that she is the demon
that the four slayers have been
searching for wada bahime angrily
repeats her question after zenitsu fails
to respond and the other girls of the
house explain that zenitsu is news of
the house zenitsu attempts to apologize
and explain that he was checking on the
girl but this angers wada boheme who
rudely calls inetsu ugly and creepy
leaving him shocked wadahime looks
around to see that the room is still in
a mess and pulls the girl who was crying
by the air causing her to yell in pain
the girl apologizes for failing to clean
the room the wada bahime continues to
harm the girl causing her to yell out in
agony unable to put up with the abuse
zenitsu grabs whatabahime by the arm
demanding that she let go of the girl
skipping back two nights before the
demon slayers arrived at the
entertainment district the manager of
the kiyogoku house omitsu holds a
meeting with the orion of her household
she explains to wada boheme that she has
to restrain herself from bullying the
other courtesans of the house to which
wada bahime feigns her innocence
amitsu expresses her frustration at
having ignored her behaviour explaining
that she has gone too far but wada
boheme guilts her by mentioning that she
brings money into the household omitsu
becomes nervous as she mentions a tale
she heard from an elder when she was
just a child
she explains that the elder had recalled
a courtesan who was extremely beautiful
but had a rotten personality the
courtesan was the orient of their
household and had been around since the
elder was a child and was eerily similar
to the ori and the elder saw when she
was an adult coincidentally the orien's
names both ended in heimei and had a
nasty glare when they were both
displeased as omitsu continues talking
she notices the similarities between the
elders description and wada boheme
however before she questions the
fidelity of her race watabahime
transforms into her original appearance
as and pulls omitsu from the
house as they fly up into the night sky
eerily remarks that the people
around her had managed to survive by
remaining silent on the atrocities that
they've witnessed until tonight
omitsu fearfully brandishes a knife
revealing her intention to kill daki
however she berates omitsu for being
more stupid than she believed and bids
her goodbye dropping her to her death
daki nonchalantly lands on a nearby
rooftop and struts away as the citizens
discover omitsu dead on the ground
when she returns to her room daki
discovers muzan awaiting and humbly
greets him
muzan comments on her appearance and
speculates that she's eating a large
amount of humans he proudly
congratulates her and cautions her to
not act recklessly complies and
receives information regarding the
possible arrival of the demon slayers
she is encouraged by muzan to become
even stronger and crueler than she was
before the flashback ends and rolls into
the situation with zinitsu confronting
whatabahime she becomes angry and slams
him into the wall rendering him
completely unconscious she openly voices
her disgust and demands that he never
touch her again and also scarily remarks
that she will administer harsher
discipline the commotion causes amitsu's
husband to rush over and apologize for
zenko's actions he begs her to forgive
him as they prepare for the customers
suddenly wada bahime has a sudden change
of character and apologizes to the
manager while he quickly orders for her
room to be cleaned as watabahime leaves
the room she has her doubts about
zinetsu and realizes that he isn't any
ordinary human and might actually be a
member of the demon slayers
in her clean room she can be seen
ominously laughing to herself as she
openly welcomes the idea of demon
slayers arriving in the district
promising she'll eat all of them
outside tangier waits looking into the
night sky feeling uneasy as he comments
on the dark and musky smell that has
taken the town
with the manager being informed of
zenko's sudden disappearance from the
kyogoku house the staff member explains
to him that she had disappeared after
being left to rest in her room however
the mention of zenko angers the manager
and he tells the staff member to forget
all about zenko the manager chases her
out before expressing his frustration at
having to submit to wada bahime's
desires elsewhere on the rooftop inosuke
can be seen explaining the demon he saw
in the ogimoto house tanjuro his exotic
description and excitement worries
tanjuro and he tells him to calm down
until tengen and zunitsu arrive for the
meeting tenkan stealthily and flashily
arrives undetected and proclaims that
sinitsu will not be arriving he also
mentions that he might have put the boys
in immediate danger tenkan tells inosuke
and tanjiro that they must leave the
district before the upper ranked demon
makes their move and announces that he
will be continuing the mission alone
tangido tries to argue against his
decision however tengan quickly leaves
as fast as he arrived tanju begins to
wonder if they are trustworthy due to
being members of the lowest demon slayer
rank but inosuka interrupts to inform
them that they've climbed their ranks a
fair birth and he flexes his hand out
and shows tanjido the kano rank which
appears and tells them their status in
the ranking confused about the
revelation inosuke explains to tanchito
that following the final selections
their hands were marked with the
wisteria flower and grey theme tangido
is left slightly embarrassed and not
knowing how to check but enosuke
promptly tells him to cheer up tangero
gets back on track and tells inosuke
that he will meet with him outside the
ogimoto house once night falls claiming
that he wants to finish investigating
the tokito house before he leaves which
angers inosuke he punches tajiro by the
cheek and tells him to follow him at
that moment but tanjudo explains that
there might be a secret passage beneath
the household that might lead to the
demon he tells inosuke that he thinks
the tengan's wives are still alive as
well as zenetsu and he asks him to
comply in order to save them
successfully anosuke smiles and lets
tanjuno know that he was thinking the
exact same thing and agrees to the plan
back at the tokito house koenatsu has
finished with her preparations and is
visited by tanjuro he arrives without
his disguise and informs koenatsu that
he is leaving the house and asks her to
pass on his payment for his meals he's
had she asks why he's dressed that way
and tanjudo explains that he's actually
a boy while apologizing to her but to
her this was no surprise as she claims
that she knew all along and wondered
what he was up to he tells her that he
hopes to save the individuals who have
disappeared from the house and she
expresses her relief while also saying
that she'll be leaving as well they wish
each other well and say their goodbyes
before tanjido leaves the room but when
koenatsu hears a sound she turns around
to discover standing right behind
her as tanjoro hurries off he catches
the faint smell of the upper ranked
demon at the ogamoto house enosuke can
be seen complaining as he waits for
tanjuno to arrive
since the time to meet was long overdue
onoski became fed up and decides to
begin the mission alone he jumps with
such force that he bursts through the
ceiling and calls for the mice to bring
his swords these mice are team
conservants who had been especially
trained to act on missions as zanuska
begins to change and make his leave a
member of the staff can be seen with a
horrified expression as she sees anosuke
with a boar's mask over at the kiyogoku
house omitsu's husband is seen holding a
kimono in his hand in just a moment
tengen appears in the room and holds a
kunai to his throat demanding to know
the whereabouts of hinatsuru and zenko
the man quickly reveals that zenko had
suddenly disappeared and that hinatsuru
was sick therefore she went to a low end
brothel tengan questions the man further
and asks who he thinks is responsible
for causing the trouble within the house
however the man begins to hyperventilate
but tengan reassures him that he can be
trusted and he will exact revenge on the
individual responsible the man envisions
his deceased wife and informs tengen
that it's wada bahime who's causing the
problems he also informs him that she
has the north room where the sunlight
never falls
the man stops talking for a moment and
quickly turns around however by that
point tengan had already left the man is
left alone in the room holding his
wife's bloody kimono when the tengan
arrives to wadahime's room he discovers
that the demon is not there and she is
probably out hunting he quickly leaves
to search for hinatsuru and swears that
he will return to defeat the demon with
his own hands elsewhere tangido has
discovered daki within kawanatu's room
as she attempts to kidnap her within her
obi daki informs tanjiro that she will
not be eating him since he is dirty and
old meaning that only yahashira will
suffice her appetite tangero yells at
her to release koenatsu however his
demands irritate as she lashes
out throwing him from the building
tangier was left stunned from her
immense speed and power but he manages
to regain his composure and stands back
up on his feet he begins to analyze the
situation and realizes that her obi has
a special power that can swallow people
whole at that moment climbs out of
the window and is amazed that tangier
was still alive tangido apologizes to
nezuko after realizing that one of the
shoulder straps is broken on the box he
tells her that he has to leave her here
for now and warns her not to come out of
the box unless her life is in utter
danger he initiates his attack against
by using his water-breathing
fourth form striking tide turbulent to
attempt to slash atu obi he successfully
manages to perform an aerial attack
against daki and slices the end of the
ob that was holding koinatu captive
dhaki states that tanjido is cute but he
makes her sick and compares him to a
dying rat before saying that she likes
him as well
after arriving at one of the keremese
houses tengan is seen caring for his
wife hinatsuru she tells him to leave
her to go investigate the loud sounds
that were heard within the district but
before he can do so she apologizes to
him for failing to complete the mission
when she initially arrived at yoshiwara
hinatsuru was placed in the kyogoku
house to investigate she realized that
wada bahime was the demon but could not
make any hasty decisions in an attempt
to escape and avoid suspicion hinatsuru
drunk poison and pretended to fall ill
however she was gifted an obi by the
orient to spy on her and ultimately kill
her if she did anything suspicious
tengen comforts hinatsuru and tells her
she did well during the mission
revealing the defeated obi in the
background he advises her to leave the
district as soon as the antidote takes
effect to which she agrees as they
embrace as tengen leaves the house and
heads back towards the battlefield he
tries to listen for the sounds of the
demon and hears the vibration coming
through an underground cavern he pulls
out his blades and uses his sound
breathing first form roar to slam onto
the ground causing a large explosion
which can be heard by in the
distance she questions tanchiro as to
how many demon slayers are in the
district but he refuses to tell her she
tries to strike a deal with him that if
he answers her question she will spare
him while simultaneously trying to
intimidate him he begins to discredit
his ability to perform the water
breathing compared to sakonji and geyu
atangido mentions that he needs to rely
on the hinukami kagura in order to land
powerful blows but he lacks the ability
to perform multiple strikes with her
tanjuro tries to regain his focus and
encourages himself that all of his
training should pay off he mentally
envisions kyogiro's voice telling him to
keep his heart burning and manages to
perform the hinokami kagura raging sun
to block darki's obi daki notices the
change in his fighting style as tanjo
cuts off a large section of her obi as
she tries to analyze this change tanjo
suddenly bursts towards her he swings
his blade down using hinokami kagura
flame dance to try and decapitate her
but she narrowly avoids it as tanjoro
tries to attack her again gains
the upper hand and tries to decapitate
tangido with her obi however tangible
utilizes another hinokami kagura fake
rainbow to escape is left confused
trying to locate where tangio has
disappeared to but within seconds
tanjuro appears behind her and uses
hinokami kagura fire wheel to attack her
once again tangelo's blade makes contact
with the neck of medaki manages to
quickly deflect tangero's attack and
sends him flying into the ground he
tries to continue his attack however
he's left exhausted from his use of
hinokami kagura and has trouble getting
up as daki quickly approaches tanjido
manages to use the recovery breathing
technique to overcome his technique and
narrowly avoids darkie's attack tanjuno
goes on the offensive and attacks
however her obi gets in the way
preventing him from defeating her
leaving him with no choice but to raise
his body temperature even higher
tangible recalls an interaction he had
with keo at the butterfly mansion she
begins to worry over tanjuro's
uncontrollable fever and tells him that
she needs to inform shinobu tanjuro
tries to reassure her that he's fine and
not to tell shinobu however kyo mentions
that his fever has been at 100.4 degrees
for over several days now and it could
mean that something is terribly wrong he
confesses to her that he has been
training with the hinokami kagura in
order to improve his skills and begs her
to hold on a bit before reporting to the
shinobu here reluctantly agrees but
tells him that she will only wait for a
bert
back in the battle against daki tanju
begins to gasp as the hinokami kagura
begins to take a toll on his body but he
refuses to let up in order to protect
the people in the district he uses his
determination to promise that he won't
allow daki to take another life and
cause the people to go through the
sadness he and his comrades had to
experience
his breath fumes out from his mouth as
he prepares to attack daki yet again
flashing back to earlier at the ogimoto
house a member of staff frantically
approaches the other woman as she claims
to have seen a monster the other woman
are left confused at the woman's unusual
claims as she explains that she saw a
boar monster destroying the ceiling and
the floor elsewhere in the house enosuke
can be seen cackling as he discovers a
hole leading to the demon's nest he
proudly yells at the hole to prepare
itself before trying to dive in head
first after realizing that only his head
fits he takes it as a challenge and
begins to snap his body claiming that he
can dislocate all joints of his entire
body all the while frightening the life
out of his staff that seem to be
observing him while he's doing this he
manages to somehow slither through the
opening and travels down through the
tunnel until he reaches a main cavern
area once he arrives he discovers the
long trails of the obi draped throughout
the entire cavern as he takes a closer
look he can see multiple people being
held captive within the obi and
discovers zenitsu knocked out among them
as well anosuke becomes disgusted with
the worm like obi and begins his assault
against the obi by slicing sections of
it off while simultaneously assaulting
it with words the women who were held
captive begin to slip out from these
sections causing the ob to panic at the
situation around it the ob analyzes
inosuke's natural abilities and has
trouble formulating a plan however
darky's consciousness takes control as
she orders the obi to capture him alive
as inosuke prepares to slice another
section of the obi it suddenly becomes
more elastic and folds along inosuke's
blade before the obi can attack him
though inosuke gains the upper hand by
maneuvering to perform beast breathing
sixth fang palace side bite however the
obi manages to distract him the obi
mentions inosuke's failure at protecting
the individuals he's freed claiming that
it can just easily swallow them all up
whole again
it proceeds to move towards the
unconscious individuals however a kunai
flies out of nowhere causing the obi to
react two women appear holding kunai and
agree with anosuke's description of the
worm like obi and begin to attack it
they explain to inosuke that they are
there to help him and will protect the
others from the ob anoski reluctantly
agrees but then he asks them who they
are to which they reveal that they're
the tengan's missing wives suma and
makio
makio begins to scold suma who sulks
after revealing that she was the first
one who was captured she also begins to
cry as she realizes that they can't help
everyone and are most likely going to
die the ob seems pleased by summer's
pessimistic attitude and questions who
should get eaten first but before i can
get the chance to attack zenetsu quickly
attacks the ob
amazed by his skill enosuke comments
that he probably shouldn't wake zenetsu
up and summer and marchio question this
man's identity the obi is left amazed by
zenitsu's speed but tries to understand
the sounds it heard it specifically
mentions that there were two sounds like
thunder one came from zinetsu but when
the obi finally recognizes the source of
the second sound the ceiling explodes
and breaks down
suma looks up into the distance and a
silhouette can be seen from the
individual who's dropped down into the
hole tengan brandishes his blades as he
takes a deep breath and within seconds
slashes the obi within his vicinity
makio turns around and calls out to
tenkan who apologizes for taking too
long he then promises that things are
about to get real flashy going back to
makio as a young adult she lived the
lifestyle of a kunuichi and was often
taught to survive instead of trying to
accomplish the mission these ideals were
again reiterated into her mindset when
she married tengen who would tell his
wives to always prioritize their lives
and return to him he would make sure to
let them know that he would take
responsibility to protect the public
after protecting them mahia would often
question if his morals were right or not
however hinatsuru would reassure her
that wanting to live was not immoral
back in the cavern tengan greets his
wives by passing them on the head and
compliments that they've put in great
work enosuke calls out to the god of
festivals and gets mad at him for
allowing the obi to escape but tengan
loses his temper and defends his wives
saying that they save the people that
were trapped makio interrupts him to say
that they need to leave immediately
before things get worse he then quickly
instructs everyone to follow him
now up on the rooftop tengan sprints
towards the battlefield and inosuke and
zinitsu struggle to catch up with him in
the middle of the battle between daki
and tanjido the oh becomes flying and
unexpectedly enters darky's body tanjudo
realizes that the ob is entering
darkie's main body and tries to attack
her but she quickly disappears she then
reappears on a nearby rooftop as her
hair turns white she squeals with
delight as she learns there's a hush era
within the district at that moment a
bystander discovers tanjido acting
suspiciously on the street and tells him
to stop fighting in front of his shot
overhears the man and becomes
enraged by his comment she lashes out a
flurry of attacks on the buildings
around her and ends up cutting off the
man's arm and the process she also
manages to kill other bystanders and
nearby houses destroying them all as
well tangible sees the bloodshed nearby
and tells the man to tie turnika around
his arm despite bleeding heavily himself
dhaki begins to walk away after
destroying the houses but tanjiko tells
her that he will not allow her to get
away with this daki cockingly tells him
to stop speaking to her since an ugly
human's life has no value and he is just
another rotten corpse hearing this and
seeing the damage that she has caused
around him tangero's heart begins to
beat louder and louder and his eyes
start to fill with rage
tanjar recalls a letter that was
addressed to him by shinjuro ringoku who
admits that he wronged him in the letter
he thanks him for mourning kyogido's
death as well as for befriending
sengioro and proceeds to express his
embarrassment for his behavior when they
first met
he explained that he was wallowing in
sorrow over the death of his wife and
incompetence as a hashera that he turned
to alcohol despite his lack of presence
as a father
jiro had proved himself to be a better
son he was managing to become a how
shira even though shinjiro had refused
to continue teaching him shinjuru writes
in his letters that tangier was gifted
with a power and is destined for
greatness as seen from the demon slayer
mark he was born with however tangible
clarifies that shinjuro is wrong because
he wasn't born with the mark he recalls
guessing the mark when he was protecting
his younger brother from a falling
brazier and then it changed his
appearance during the final selection
unlike his father who was born with the
mark sanjido simply acquired it meaning
he wasn't a chosen one nonetheless he
refuses to back down
back in the fight as daki walks away
from tanjuro he quickly grabs her and
narrowly tries to cut her neck but she
manages to avoid the attack and move
away from him she loses her foot in the
process but her regeneration skills
allow her to develop a new one within
seconds tanjuno notices her regeneration
and asks daki why she steals people's
lives and ruins them his tone of voice
comes off as familiar tadaki as she
envisions a different swordsman before
her although she doesn't recognize the
swordsman realizes that she's
envisioning muzan's memories tanjuno
continues to question her reasoning and
taunts her with the fact that she was
once a human who endured hardships as
well proceeds to glorify the
privileges of being a demon seemingly
mocking the circumstances that humans
face her confidence grows as
believes that she is now untouchable due
to the fact that she has returned back
to her original form
she bids tangero farewell and begins to
think about going after the hashira
however tanjo utilizes the hinokami
kagura burning bones summer sun to burn
the obi blocking his path is left
stunned by her wounds and inability to
regenerate to the point where she begins
to shake and is left to defend herself
from tangier's flurry of attacks he
closes in and swings his blade to
decapitate her but she continues to
resist as her neck transforms into an ob
refusing to be cut tanjuro's blade
begins struggling as it tries to cut
through dhaki's obi-like neck the
resisting cloth forces tanjido to
abandon his attack and escape before
has the chance to fight back
however when he tries to recollect his
thoughts charges towards him and
tries to slash him tanjulo analyzes her
movements and has realised that he can
see her in slow motion giving him the
advantage as her wild obi attacks him
from multiple directions tanjuno manages
to pin them all in a single spot and
proceeds to charge at her while cutting
away the obi his flames burn the ob away
within seconds as he comes to a close
proximity to daki however just when he's
about to decapitate her tangent
envisions his sister hanako desperately
begging his brother to breathe in that
moment tangero loses his focus and
begins gasping for air after nearly
passing his physical limitations he
collapses onto the ground finally
feeling the pain that he has been
suppressing and his eyes begin to bleed
it is revealed that he has been acting
on hunger and has been using his life
force to surpass his limitations however
his sister was able to warn him before
he could sustain any life-threatening
damage daki glares down at tanjido and
berates him for his weaknesses as a
human she mocks his injuries and slowly
approaches him to deliver the final blow
before she can deliver the attack a leg
comes down and kicks behind
rupturing her head nisako can be seen
boiling with rage as she stands between
tajiro who's struggling to breathe on
the ground and nezuko recalls the
memories of when her family was
slaughtered on a snowy night and her
rage grows stronger as she prepares to
fight the upper ranked demon darky's
head and face begin to regenerate as she
glares holes into niziko she recognizes
her as the demon
muzan specifically had told her about
nezuko's face begins to transform as her
infinite anger begins to push her
forward leaving everyone wondering what
would happen in neziko's case as she
also gained the ability to have no
physical limitations
flashing back to just before when muzan
arrived at the kyogoku house to see daki
there he had told her to find the demon
who had escaped his grasp just like
tamiyo he identifies her as having a
hemp like pasu and kimono as well as a
checkerboard obi and tells daki that she
is his last hope to catch nezuko
flashing forward now in the present
promises that she will kill neziko
and lay her down at muzan's feet as
proof of this
nisiko faces and charges to once
again try to kick off darky's head
however is able to cut off
nezuko's leg using her obi while niziko
looks down at her bleeding thigh
uses the opportunity to knock her off
the roof and blast her into a nearby
building as the two demons are fighting
tangero falls unconscious and envisions
his brother takio in his dream takeo
mentions how tanjiro and niziko are very
alike when they're kind and angry and
goes on to recall an instance when he
saw niziko get angry he explains how
fearful he was when he saw her and was
worried about her lack of concern for
herself mentioning that within an
instant she could have lost everything
that she holds dear
back in the fight jumps down from
the rooftop and approaches neziko who's
trapped underneath a pile of rubble she
mocks her for being weak and a
half-developed demon
daki continues to provoke her and
cockingly says that she will not fight
nezuko anymore and will simply leave her
trapped and expose her to the sunlight
instead however before can say
anything else neziko comes out from the
rubble and regenerates her leg in an
instant leaving stunned at her
abilities nezuko proceeds to
instantaneously regenerate her arm which
was cut off as well leaving
uneasy as she realizes that her
regenerative abilities are on par with
an upper ranked demon nezuko's body
transforms as she breaks her bamboo
muzzle and a horn grows out the right
side of her forehead and her body also
becomes covered in ivy like demon crests
gets more intimidated by niziko's
change in aura as she tries to defend
herself from one of her kicks
stressfully cutting it off with her ob
however before she can cut nezuko's head
darki is smashed to the ground by
nezuko's kirk
dhaki is left shocked as niziko's leg
pierces through her body pinning her
onto the ground she tries to make sense
of how niziko could attack her with the
legs she had just sliced off but then
realises that nezuko had instantly
regenerated the leg within that moment
admitting that nezuko's regenerative
abilities are greater than her own
nesigo begins to become manic following
her transformation
as tanjudo still remains in his
unconscious state takeo desperately taps
him on his back begging for him to help
he tells tangido to please wake up and
help niziko who isn't acting like
yourself anymore forcing tangido to
awake with concern as this happens
remains pinned on the ground and she
tries to use her obi to free herself
from nezuko's hold her obi effectively
severes multiple limbs from nezuko's
body but before she gets the chance to
scoop them up niziko's severed hands
grip onto her obi her limbs remain
connected by her unusually solidified
blood with some of the blood falling
onto in an instant is set
on fire by the blood causing her to
scream out in agony mizuko's limbs wind
back to reattach to her body and they
self-cauterize each cart she proceeds to
forcefully stomp down on darky's head
causing it to erupt in flames nezuko
continues to stomp multiple times on her
head before she forcefully kicks
through a nearby building and into one
behind it
as she follows to continue her
assault nesuko comes across an injured
woman
who stares at nezuko with fear as she
tends to her bleeding wound
nesco falls into a trance and charges
into the home towards the woman as she
fails to suppress her hunger for blood
out of nowhere though tangero jumps on
top of niziko and uses his blade to act
as a muzzle in order to restrain her he
yells at her to fight the hunger and
encourages her to be strong but she
lashes out at him and scratches him on
the face trying to escape he apologizes
to her for making her fight after
smelling the blood that spilled from her
injuries he proceeds to reassure her
that her big brother is now there to
protect her and that she can now heal
herself neziko manages to regain her
footing and she jumps through the
ceiling with tanjuro on her back causing
an intense amount of damage to happen to
the building as tanjiru struggles to
restrain his sister the walls of the
room are seemingly slashed as
barges into the room with her burned
face she is seen seething with anger as
she is forced to regenerate her burned
body and angrily approaches the siblings
tangerine becomes conflicted on what to
do as he realizes that there are
bystanders he needs to protect but he
also needs to defend dhaki's attacks
without releasing nezuko as tanjido
makes his decision to protect the public
tengan uzoi suddenly appears before him
and expresses his surprise in nezuko's
flashy demonization
tengu goes on to comically berate
tangido for speaking highly of neziko's
ability to restrain herself back at the
ubishiki estate despite him struggling
to restrain her now
daki sees tengen and excitedly reacts to
ahashira arriving before her but is
quickly and chillingly told to shut her
tenkin tells her to scram and says that
she is too weak to be an upper ranked
demon all of a sudden darky's head which
had just been decapitated as tengen flew
past fell into her lap leaving her
completely stunned and simply confused
at what had just transpired
tangier was left shocked by tengan's
swift victory over daki but the sound to
shira reminds him that the fight isn't
over as his sister is still out of
control tangero struggles to restrain
her with tengan suggesting to sing her a
lullaby to put her to sleep but at that
moment nezuko regains her footing and
jumps out of another building window
taking her brother with her again as
they continue the struggle realizing his
words aren't reaching her tanju asks his
mother in a dreamlike state what he
should do he then remembers tengen's
earlier advice to sing neziko a lullaby
he begins to sing her a song that their
mother had sung in the past and over a
short period of time his lullaby soon
reaches her nezuko remembers asking
their mother about the song when she was
a child causing her to break down in
tears neziko comes to her senses and
changes from her advanced demonized form
into her regular childlike state
promptly falling asleep
tanjulo lets out a relieved sigh as he
successfully holds an isako in his lap
back in the house daki screams etengen
for cutting her head off and he responds
by telling her to die quietly the
enraged demon reminds him he had denied
her upper rank status which he affirms
but she proceeds to insist her status
much to his annoyance
to the hashera's astonishment daki
begins to throw attention and cry and he
notes that she's been taking far too
long for when she should have been
showing signs of dying by now
still throwing her tantrum dhaki calls
out to guatara to save her and a male
demon begins to emerge from her body
tengan senses the danger and attempts to
immediately attack the two but his
blades had nothing by ear as the demon
disappears from his sight tengan wonders
why is still alive after being
beheaded as well as the presence of the
new demon who he comments is having a
great reaction speed guytaro tells daki
to heal her burn complimenting her good
looks and he then wounds tenkin when he
attempts to try and attack them again
guatara complements tengan's attempt to
attack him as well as his success at
blocking his attack he reveals that he
was intending to kill tenkan with that
attack and prepares to take him on in a
battle
within the entertainment district there
are men known as goos or barkers who
work to attract customers to enter the
brothels guataru worked as one of these
men and eventually named himself using
the word goo
inside one of the brothels gyotato and
tengen are about to engage in combat but
before they do so gyotaro begins to
analyze tengan's appearance
he comments about his nice face good
skin and height mentioning that he must
attract a lot of attention from woman
guitar begins to creepily scratch at his
face until he begins to bleed and voices
his jealousy over tengen's looks
in the corner of the room can be
seen crying as she whines at guitar to
kill the other demon slayers who burned
her as well
she proceeds to tell him that they
ganged up on her and she tried her
hardest to kill them causing guatara to
seethe with anger using two large
sickles he creates a flurry of large
arc-like slashes aiming them towards
tengen tanjulo can be seen carrying
nezuko as he rushes to put her to safety
he looks up into the sky and sees the
sickles return back in the direction
that they came like a boomerang he
becomes concerned when he smells
tengen's blood and rushes to return to
help
at that moment inosukin zenitsu can be
seen flinging towards tanjuro as they
awkwardly announce their arrival tanjo
quickly informs them to help tengan and
inosuke ensures him that he's going to
be real flashy before quickly leaving
tangido to put nezuko in her box back at
the parlor guataro seeds with jealousy
after witnessing how cool tenkan looks
by protecting the bystanders within the
home causing him to brag about his
appearance and marriage to the three
women girotaro pauses in astonishment
before furiously scratching his face
after hearing tengan's polygamy he
proceeds to use his blood demon art
flying bloodsicle to try and kill the
hashera but tengan manages to block it a
large explosion causes the floor beneath
tengan to give in and he manages to
escape by dropping down one floor
however guataro commands his sickles to
turn and they come straight for tengan
yet again by this point tengen hand
realized guatara's abilities to change
the sickles and the directions that he
wants and tries to formulate a plan on
how we will try and defeat these
siblings he theorizes that in order to
kill the demons he would need to cut off
guatara's head instead of darky's head
and tries to test it out dengen grabs
three small balls and throws them into
the air he proceeds to aim for them and
precisely hits them to cause an
explosion within the brothel as the
brothel begins to crumble tenkin is seen
standing on the rubble as he admits it
won't be easy to defeat the demons he
looks at the large obi ball before him
and the siblings emerge unscathed as
they confidently proclaim that they
fight as one after successfully finding
the box and placing nezuko inside
tangero quickly tries to return to the
battlefield in order to assist uzui
while this happens at the battlefield
gyrotaro scouts as he mentions tengen's
supreme abilities calling him different
and talented compared to the other
hashiro he's killed his comments
somewhat irritate tenkan and he berates
him for thinking that he's talented
compared to the other people on the
planet calling him ignorance he grows
more and more angry as he recalls the
people that he's lost over the years
despite being called the chosen one by
guitaro after listening to him speak
gurotaro grows irritated by the fact
that he has not died yet revealing that
his poison drenched sickle should have
killed him by now
tengan explains that he is a built up
resistance to poison as he was raised in
a shinobi household with nine siblings
but by the age of 15 seven of them had
already died his father was a cold
heartless individual who would regularly
force them to undergo intense training
and as a result his brother adopted the
same ruthlessness and cold-hearted
personality unable to understand that
type of mindset tenkin left his clan
alongside his wives and approached
kagaya yubashiki to become members of
the corpse kagaya had warned them it
would be hard to reject the values they
were raised in but openly welcomed them
and thanked tengan's family for deciding
to put their lives at the risk to
protect others in the present guatara
notices the deterioration in tenkan's
physical state and becomes gleeful when
he realizes that his poison is slowly
taking effect tenga proceeds to refute
his claims saying that he is still in
pristine condition and charges forward
to attack the siblings as they engage in
a battle tenkin manages to kick
away from guitar and releases numerous
dark bees which cause a cluster of
explosions by setting a distraction
tengen attempts to decapitate guataro
while only holding the tip of the end of
one of his blades but it is promptly
blocked by the demon as both sides
reassess the situation has left
whining as she pathetically reattaches
her head to her body once again guataro
comforts tengan about discovering the
method on how to defeat them but he
feigns his innocence pretending not to
notice despite tenkan's discovery
guataro cockingly says that despite
knowing their weakness tinker will still
die from the poisoning since the demons
have the advantage in battle at that
moment zenetsu and enosuke arrive to
question the fidelity of guatara's claim
that they are going to win the two boys
flamboyantly announced their arrival to
the fight which confuses everyone at
that moment but then tanjuro drops down
from the ceiling above them and stands
between the injured tengan and the
demons preparing to fight makio and
sumer can be seen frantically trying to
evacuate the citizens of the district as
the battle resumes against the demons
gotaro tries to discourage the three new
arrivals and manages to intimidate
tanjiro however tengen uzui comes up
behind them and proudly announces that
they are going to win as daki finishes
reattaching her head she loudly doubts
his words by saying that they can't win
since the hashera has been poisoned
unfazed tengan once again proudly
announces their intent to win and speaks
highly of the three boys looking back at
him tangero sees the persona of kyogiro
ringoku emitting from tengen as he
speaks which excites inosuke guatoro and
daki get riled up and reveal that
they've eaten 15 and seven hashira
respectively and begin to attack the
group as daki attempts to attack tenkan
and tanjiro from behind zenitsu bursts
through the home within seconds to block
the attack and nanoscape follows up now
on the rooftop darki finally recognizes
zenitsu from the kyogoku house and he
demandingly commands her to apologize to
the girl whom he had found crying
earlier she mocks her speech by
revealing that the woman are treated
like merchandise within the district and
as the orion she was allowed to do as
she pleased with the other people since
she was the main breadwinner of the
house when she looks up at zunitsu a
third eye appears on darki's forehead
revealing that guitar can see them via
her eye now back at the brothel tangero
becomes intimidated by guatara's evil
aura but formulates a plan to counteract
his attacks and protect tengen however
the demon manages to rush towards
tanchiro within an instant and catch him
off guard narrowly passing him through
his jaw before he can do so tenkin grabs
a hold of tanjuro by the nape of his
clothes and throws him to safety before
engaging in the battle with guitaro as
he crash lands and looks back to see the
two fighting tangero senses an ominous
object approaching them from above and
darky's obi can be seen crashing down on
all around them on the rooftop
can be heard cackling as she admits she
is now displaying her full strength
since guitardo is awake and allowing her
to use his advanced senses zenetsu and
enosuke can be seen covered in cuts and
wounds as they prepare to engage with
in battle guitar disregards the
claims that tenkan made earlier of the
boys being tsuguco and tries to
undermine their capabilities as sword
men the four demon slayers can be seen
engaging in battle with the two demons
of the entertainment district fighting
ferociously on the rooftop and inside
one of the brothels as the building
begins to collapse tengan uzui finds
himself getting cornered between two of
guatara's attacks however tanjuro jumps
in and manages to protect him from these
slashes tengen proceeds to use sound
breathing fifth form string performance
to try to corner guataro but daki's obi
interferes and protects her brother from
the attacks tengan begins to be pushed
back by the obi however tangent moves in
to cut the obi and tries to distract
duotado the hashira is left amazed at
tanjiru's endurance despite suffering a
serious shoulder wound and realises that
tanjulo had tied his sword to his hand
to prevent him from dropping it due to
his exhaustion
meanwhile on the rooftop zenitsu and
unosuke can be seen struggling as they
try to evade the attacks from darki's
obi the boys realize that is now
attacking them with the blood blades
used by guatato making it impossible for
them to approach her now that the
brothel has been destroyed tengan and
tangio are left to fight
and the obi beneath the night sky on a
nearby rooftop henatsuru appears
carrying a large box filled with kunai
darts and proceeds to launch dozens of
them down below on guataro at first he
is left confused by the random attack
but then guitar uses his blood demon art
rampant art rampage to deflect them all
away from him guatara is left shocked
though when tenkan proceeds to attack
him despite getting pissed with the
darts he attempts to decapitate him with
a sickle however tenkan manages to evade
his attacks and successfully cuts off
his leg at that moment guatara is struck
on the neck by one of the kunai darts
and fails to regenerate his leg
realizing that the darts were coated
with a wisteria extract as his body
begins to go numb tangelo closes in on
him to try to decapitate guitaro leaving
him seething with curiosity as the demon
slayers quickly gained the upper hand
the kunai darts which were utilized by
hinatsuru were revealed to be coated in
a poison which would generally paralyze
a demon for half a day or possibly even
immobilize a lower ranked demon she can
be seen on a nearby rooftop pleading for
the poison to work for even just a
moment as the demon slayers attempt to
decapitate guataru
however
at that moment guatara manages to
regenerate his legs and proceeds to
attack them at a close vicinity he uses
his blood demon art rotating circular
slashes flying blood scythes to emit
numerous blood slashes to attack them
before they can reach him uzui grabs a
hold of tanjuro again and throws him
back to protect him from the attack
within milliseconds tengan uses his
sound breathing form constant resounding
slashes to defect guatara's attack but
finds that he has disappeared from his
side to his horror he looks up to the
roof to see that guitar has managed to
capture hinatsuru and is about to kill
her tengan tries to save her however
darki's obi blocks him from reaching her
tengan yells at guitar to stop as he
tries to push through tangido comes
close to the building and tries to use
this hinokami kagura to reach her
however his body refuses to listen to
him tanjulo quickly changes tactics and
uses a form of water breathing to
quickly save hanatsuru from kyotoro
realizing that he managed to save
hinasuru tanjiro decides to utilise both
water breathing as well as the hinokami
kagura in order to increase his
attacking power guataro is left
surprised by tanjuro's unexpected
maneuvers and chases at him at that
moment tenkin comes behind guataro and
swings his blade akuotaro's neck while
openly yelling that he owes tanjido
nearby on a rooftop inosuke can see
tengan move in as he attempts to cut off
guatara's head his frustration grows as
they continue to evade darki's attacks
instead of move in to try and decapitate
her zenitsu calls out to anosuke and
explains that in order to defeat them
they need to make sure that their heads
aren't connected instead of trying to
decapitate the two simultaneously
enosuke stun looks at zenitsu absolutely
amazed and calls him awesome after
seeing the difference in his personality
compared to his usual demeanor meanwhile
tangido assists tenkan by also trying to
swing his blade down on guitar's neck
however the demon manages to use his
sickles to hold both of their attacks
and attempts to absorb their blades
tengan uses his free arm to use his
second blade to pierce guataro but his
quick reflexes allow him to catch the
tip of the blade in his mouth since he
neck guillotaro is about to unleash more
blood blades tengan tells tangero to
hang in there as hinatsuru yanks tanjiro
away from them allowing tengan to leap
off the roof while pulling the demon
with him before he can leap down to hell
a voice can be heard telling them to
watch out as enosuke and zunitsu crash
onto the roof while fighting the obi
inosuke and zinetsu asked tanjiro for
help in order to defeat daki and agrees
asking that they'll finish quickly in
order to help the tengen as well
hinatsuru tells the boys that she will
hide quickly in order to allow them to
focus on the battle and disappears as
they face she gets excited when
tanjido joins their fight and informs
his comrades that they need a fast
attack in order to cut her neck anosuke
realizes that she has slowed down and
decides to go first to attack as xenonsu
agrees with tangido to protect him from
behind and oscar proceeds to dash
forward using beast breathing eighth
fang explosive rush was inetsu and
tangiero use thunder breathing first
form thunderclap and flash eight-fold
and water-breathing third form blowing
dance respectively to protect inosuke
from the ob begins to crack under
the pressure as inosuke closes in on her
and manages to draw both of his blades
on either side of her neck anoski
bruises his heels into the ground as he
uses his beast breathing sixth fang
palisade bites to effectively decapitate
tangelo smiles with joy as he
witnesses inosuke leap and catch darky's
head in the air rejoicing and
successfully cutting off her head
inosuki claims that they have to act
fast and keep your head separated from
her body anosuke quickly tries to escape
with the head in order to prevent her
from reattaching her to her body he
tells the other boys not to worry about
him but to instead help tengan but
before he can even get to safety
uses his hair to put up resistance
he manages to stop her resistance though
but before he can get away guatara
appears behind him and impales him
through the chest tangero looks on in
horror as guataru grabs darky's head
while inosuke collapses to the floor he
then looks down onto the ground and is
once again horrified to see the tengen
laying bleeding and unresponsive on the
ground zenetsu tries to warn tanjido of
the oncoming obi attack but before he
can escape the roof collapses beneath
him and tangier falls to the ground
seemingly buried beneath the rubble
as he falls unconscious he apologizes to
everyone and specifically neziko for
losing the battle
in his dream niziko can be seen telling
him to stop apologising for any faults
in their lives or feeling unworthy she
reassures him that it isn't his fault
that their lives were ruined and tells
him that they'll work together to make a
better future for themselves
nezuko begins to cry as her body morphs
from her human form to her demon form as
she pleads for him to never apologize
for any regrets and tells him she
understands how he feels tanjido awakens
from his dream and tries to recollect
his thoughts but before he gets up
guataro can be seen standing over him
questioning if he's still alive guataro
takes it upon himself to tell tanjido
that ignoski was pissed through the
heart
zenitsu was suffering and trapped
beneath the rubble and tengan's heart
had stopped due to the poison he
proceeds to refer to all of them as
pathetic and asks tanjiro how the demon
in the box is related to him and
responds by saying that she is his
youngest sister guatara begins to laugh
at tanjulo's pathetic attempt to protect
his younger sister and tells him he
should be using his hands before
proceeding to break his fingers as
tanjoru withers on the ground in pain
guatara proceeds to berate him for his
weaknesses and pulls him by his hair he
teases tangier and tells him to try to
decapitate him but instead of attacking
him he slaps his hand on a small bag and
hangs his head down a defeat believing
that he broke tangero's spirit he
reveals his grand idea of offering
tanjido the opportunity to become a
demon for the sake of his sister
tanjiro suddenly looks up into the sky
iguataru asks him if he's been trying to
hold back his tears but to his surprise
tanjiru responds that he had been
preparing for the moments his face gets
close to guataraos and tanjunu brings
his head down and headbutts him with a
great force momentarily stunning guataro
daki screams at him to get up but as his
legs falter he looks down to discover
that a kunai has been lodged into his
leg he realizes that when tanjuro had
looked down he had opened a bag given to
him by hinatsuru which contained
wisteria poison tangero manages to stand
back up while guitar remains paralyzed
and crouched before him tangero uses his
remaining strength to swing the blade
down onto his neck as he tries to force
the blade down and through tangero
envisions himself in guwataro's place
and he thinks that if he were in this
situation he would want his comrade to
kill him before he could live as a demon
on a nearby rooftop daki can be seen
rushing to her feet at this sudden
change of events to try and help her
brother but before she can even get
close to them zenetsu manages to free
himself from the rubble he attacks her
using thunder breathing first form
thunderclap and flash to bring her
attention to him and then uses god speed
to attack her neck zenetsu pleads with
his blade to cut through her neck since
he was given the chance to escape the
rubble and attack her while guitar was
subdued tanjulo continues to struggle to
cut through guatara's neck but before he
can do so guatara manages to emit his
blood blades to repel his sword tanjulo
is knocked off balance as guatara
regains his footing causing them to
re-engage in battle guataru gains the
upper hand and brings his sickle down on
tangier's neck however at that moment
tengen regains his consciousness and
protects him from the sickle despite
being severely poisoned and missing his
left hand denkin engages in the
head-to-head combat with guitar but
remarking that he's perfected the
musical score technique it is revealed
that his technique allows him to analyze
maneuvers of his opponents and read them
like notes on a piece of sheet music
however the poison had hindered his
attacking ability meaning that he can
only defend guataro's attacks guataro
manages to land a powerful attack to the
left side of tengen's face resulting in
the loss of his eye and proceeds to stab
tengan
yells out to tenkan after witnessing him
get stabbed but tengen orders him to
ignore and jump tanjido leaps into the
air towards guatara and attempts to
decapitate him but is brutally stabbed
through the jaw by guitar sickle the
demon begins panicking as they gain the
upper hand and tries pulsating his
poison to kill tanjuro however tanjulo
proceeds to endure through the pain and
swings his sword towards guataro
tangelo can be seen swinging his blade
down on guitar's neck despite the demon
sickle passing through his jaw his arm
strength isn't enough to slice through
his neck so he resorts to forcing his
entire body to push through ignoring the
pain
guwataru notices the change in tanjido's
scar as he develops a demon slayer mark
and his eyes roll back in his head the
change in his demeanor proves to be too
great as tanjiro's blade cuts through
guatara's neck causing him to panic
meanwhile can be seen resisting
zinetsu's attempt to decapitate her she
tries to use her obi to kill zinetsu at
close range but ninosuke unexpectedly
rushes up revealing that he protected
his heart from being stabbed by
rearranging all of his organs he also
reveals that the poison has no effect on
him at all since he was raised up in the
mountains before proceeding to assist
zinitsu by decapitating daki the three
boys let out a roar as they muster out
their strength to slice the demon's neck
after the long battle sinitsu and
inosuke managed to decapitate daki up on
the rooftop while tanjudo can be seen
decapitating guataro simultaneously on
the ground the heads fall onto the
ground and roll until they end up face
to face
as guataro's body falls onto the ground
tinker notices something being emitted
from it and becomes alarmed meanwhile
upon a nearby rooftop suma hinatsuru and
makio have arrived to witness the end of
the battle
as makio begins to bicker with sumer
over her behavior hinatsuru notices
something as a miss down on the
battlefield she looks down to see
tangido is struggling to breathe as he
bleeds out from his jaw while trying to
slow down the poison
tangelo looks over at tengan who's
sitting down in front of him and yelling
at him with a panicked expression
however tangible fails to comprehend his
sudden alarm as tengen looks at him with
horror
under the night sky nezuko can be seen
looking down as her brother with a
concerned expression
as tanjo begins to regain his
consciousness he looks around to see
these destroyed buildings around him
niziko nudges her brother as a way of
letting him know that she was the one
who saved him from the destruction
tangier attempts to get up to search for
the others but his legs give out from
beneath him and he collapses onto the
ground
he hears someone calling out to him in
the distance and recognizes the voice as
belonging to zenitsu and is unexpectedly
picked up and carried by nezuko the pair
moved towards the source of the
commotion and discover zenitsu has
awakened from his slumber not
remembering any of the events that had
just transpired he tells tanjudo that he
can hear inosuke's heartbeat getting
weaker and weaker and points to him
laying unconscious nearby
the siblings rush over to him and
tangero attempts to wake up in oscar but
to his dismay he feels his heart getting
weaker tangier begins to panic and
thinks of exposing him to sunlight or
sending a crow to shinobu for help but
realises that he doesn't have the time
for either options his tears begin to
swell up as inosuke lays dying before
him
but nezuko nonchalantly comes forward
and unexpectedly sets enosuke on fire
tangido looks amazed as he witnesses
enosuke's poisoned skin here right
before his eyes and his comrade suddenly
awakes to announce he's hungry the three
rejoice at the fact that he's okay and
embrace as tanjudo begins to sob
elsewhere on the battlefield zuma begins
to wail loudly pleading for tengan to
live after winning the battle her
co-wife makio begins to panic as she
realises the antidote they administered
is not working to remove the poison from
his body and hinatsuru begins to weep
realizing that he doesn't have much time
to live tengen begins to relay his final
words to his wives but is interrupted by
suma's loud whales makio becomes enraged
as suma's overreactive cries and begins
to pull by her hair and shove rocks into
her mouth to make her be quiet while
henatsuru tries to prevent them from
bickering in a comical fashion though
tenkan sits spectating at his wives
while they continue to bicker during his
final moments as he slips away he then
realizes that he can no longer move
speak or do anything due to the poison
but then everyone momentarily pauses
when neziko suddenly appears next to
tengan they proceed to stare at her as
she raises her hand and grabs him before
setting him on fire his wives look in
horror until suma comically pulls niziko
away saying that it's too soon to
cremate him to their surprise tengan
begins to speak again and asks how it is
possible that the poison has been
removed from his body which brings
relief to his wives
tanjido subtly explains that nezuko's
blood demonard has somehow managed to
remove the poison from their bodies and
expresses his relief to know that tengan
is safe tengan tries to tell tanjido to
rest if not he will die from his
injuries butanjin informs tengen that he
needs to confirm that the demons have
been defeated before he can rest the
siblings proceed throughout the rubble
in search of the demon's heads and come
across a pool of blood
tangido pulls out an apparatus and
decides to collect the blood in order to
be studied
once the blood has been collected
tamiya's cat mysteriously appears before
tanjudo and he puts it in the box to be
delivered to tamiyo as the siblings
continue their search tanjido smelts the
scent of the demons and guides nezuko
towards them when they arrive guatado
and daki can be seen viciously arguing
over their defeat their heads begin to
disintegrate as they blame each other
for losing the battle with guataro
disregarding for being useless
retaliates by saying that someone
is ugly as guatara cannot be considered
her relative which leaves tanjido
looking at them concerned about the
hurtful words they are spewing at each
other daki and guatara continue arguing
as their heads begin to disintegrate she
starts chastising her brother for being
useless and questions if they are even
related guitar grows angry at her
comments and calls her a wet clean even
regretting to protect her in the first
place he loses his temper and goes on
dispute hateful remarks such as
mentioning that his life would have been
better off without her and wishing that
she'd have never been born causing
darky's eyes to well up with tears
tanjido intervenes and covers guatara's
mouth saying that he doesn't mean what
he is saying and that they shouldn't
spend their final moments with each
other arguing dukkhi begins to wail at
tanjiru out of frustration yelling at
him to leave them alone and stop
lecturing them darky's head reaches its
last phases of its disintegration as she
cries out for her brother to save her
saying that she doesn't want to die
guitar hopelessly watches as her head
dissolves away while still calling out
to him before he impulsively calls out
to her by her birth name ume
as he reaches his final moments guitar
recalls his past as a human born in the
kirimise to a prostitute mother before
she died from syphilis his mother tried
to kill him many times even after his
younger sister was born due to his
appearance and lack of hygiene the young
guy was bullied and detested by everyone
that he met
things began to change though after his
sister was born as her beauty dismissed
his inferiority complex and he used his
ugliness plus his newfound fighting
skills to become an efficient death
collector however the good fortune would
not last long for the siblings when ume
turned 13 she blinded a samurai with a
comb and was viciously burned and buried
alive for her crime having been away on
his job at the time guitar returned to
find her barely alive in a hole and he
hugged her body as she clinged to life
he cursed the gods to return his sister
for treating them cruelly before he is
attacked by the same samurai the samurai
slashes guataru from behind and a
manager there brazenly calls guatara a
nuisance and a brute for harassing the
locals of the district before expressing
their pissy at having lost ume as a
courtesan before the samurai could
finish him off guataro viciously kills
the manager and berates the samurai for
having a lavish lifestyle before
gruesomely killing him as well as
guatorre tried to find help for him and
his sister no one would help them due to
their reputation and circumstances he
trudges on through the street until he
ultimately collapses and bleeds out onto
the floor as the snow begins to fall the
siblings lay on the floor dying until
they are discovered by one of the upper
ranked demons who offers to turn them
into demons
yuotaro undermintably proclaims that he
would become a demon again no matter how
many times that he is reborn wanting to
always bring fear as guataro the debt
collector guitar muses how dark he could
have been if he had raised her
differently before taking note of his
surroundings a younger looking
appeared behind him disgusted with their
current location and wondering where the
exit was the emaciated man ordered her
not to follow him anymore getting angry
when she would not comply
a tearful apologized for her
earlier cruel insults stating that it
was because she had not wanted to accept
that it was her fault that they had lost
when guotaro still refused to not let
her come with tackled him from
behind stubbornly refusing to ever let
go vowing to always be his little sister
no matter how often they are reborn and
finally accepting her company guitar
carries his little sister into the fire
that awaits them
and the world of the living tangible and
niziko watches the last of the demon
siblings dissolve into the air
tangier wonders if they made up which
niziko affirms elsewhere obernai iguro
attempts to praise tengen for his defeat
of an upper rank six but is disappointed
to hear that he beat such a low-ranking
member of the twelve kazuki as well as
lost his left arm and eye tengan states
his intention to retire as a shira but
obani refuses to accept this as there is
already a vacant hashera position and
their lower ranks of the demon corpse
keep on dying without improving
tengan disagrees with this last point
stating that tanjuro is definitely
improving while obanite is surprised
that he survived the fight
elsewhere kaguya yubashiki learns of the
group's victory and is elated but is
stricken by the complications of his
illness
he states that his victory will have
mass consequences enough to ensure
muzan's defeat within their generation
he then collapses into a continuous bout
of coughing
over at the infinity castle akasa
ponder's house summoning must mean a
member of the upper ranks has been
defeated akasa looks on with displeasure
as the benwa demon plays her instrument
and is greeted by one of the upper
ranked colleagues gyoko the potted demon
asks him how he's been after 90 years
and proclaims his insincere worry over
akasa being the slain upper rank han
tengu corrects his colleague as it had
actually been 113 years since they had
last been summoned and expresses his
concern over the oddity and the
unluckiness of the number ignoring them
akasa asks the by demon if muzin had
arrived the answer being no and then if
the upper rank 1 had arrived before she
can answer though doma places a hand on
a kaza's shoulder asking him to show
some concern for his well-being as well
as he did not wish to see any of his
precious buddies die gyoku and doma
exchange a small conversation about
gyoko's pot and doma's use of the pot
that gyoko had given him akaza demands
that doma remove his hand viciously
punching him when he does not
immediately do so quickly recovering
from the blow doma pleasantly asks if
ikaza had gotten stronger since they
last met enraging the tattooed demon the
biwa demon finally relates that the
upper rank 1 had been the first to
arrive surprising akaza who spotted his
silent colleague kokoshibo noted that he
was present as was their master as each
upper rank reacted to the silent arrival
of their leader muzan noted that gyotaro
was dead doma apologized for kyataru's
failure wondering what punishment muzan
would give him but the ancient demon
declined all of his suggestions having
already anticipated the upper ranked
sixth defeat he further commented that
he did not expect anything from him
which doma questioned as he did not
believe that he had ever failed to live
up to his master's expectations but mooz
uncounted by stating that the uber
yoshiki family had yet to be killed and
the blue spider lily had yet to be found
making him question why the upper ranks
even exist each of the upper ranks offer
some excuse for this failure save akaza
and gyoko the latter offers muzan some
information that he claims will get him
closer to achieving his goals swiftly
beheading the upper rank muzam berates
gyoko for speaking of change as he is
only looking for permanence he adds that
he is at the height of his displeasure
due to an upper rank being killed for
the first time in over 100 years further
brating kyoko for attempting to give him
unconfirmed information he demands that
the upper ranks serve him with suicidal
devotion from that moment on he then
orders gyoko to head over with hantengu
to see if he can confirm this
information
and then leaves
doma then approaches goku asking to join
him on his mission and then in an
instant has the upper portion of his
head completely destroyed by a kaza
akaza the upper rank 3 demon orders him
to get lost as muzan had not given him
any specific orders
akasa looks in disbelief as his arm is
sliced off by kokushibo doma attempts to
defend his subordinate but kokushibo
reprimands akasa for his actions as they
soil the relationships between the upper
ranks advising him to battle doma for
his spot as upper rank 2 instead if he
is truly bothered
after hearing the suggestion doma
interrupts and asserts that akasa
wouldn't be able to raise his rank given
how much more powerful he was despite
becoming a demon much later than him a
fact that likely contributed to acaz's
rage he continues on describing how he
allowed akasa to use violence on him as
a way to get along with him kokushibo
ignores doma and asks zakaza if he
understood what he meant
akaza confirms declaring that he would
definitely defeat him one day receiving
a word of good luck from his superior as
he leaves the fortress gomer tries to
start a conversation with akaza but he
ignores him as he exits hyoko then asks
nakime to send him and hantengu to their
next destination in which the bee were
demon complies to she additionally sends
doma back to his cold when he tries to
talk to her
after which he mopes over his
colleague's unfriendliness
somewhere else a man is seen sitting by
a house with another individual
sumiyoshi brings some tea and some food
the man thanks his friend for the
hospitality in which the letter
apologizes for his wife being asleep and
the child having to be babysat by a
guest he tells him not to worry about
the situation and that he shouldn't
continue receiving the meals for free
from his friend sumiyoshi denies this
revealing that his family was saved by
him and their lives were thanks to him
he also offers to pass down his guest's
tale as he didn't have any successes
even if his family were just simple coal
burners
sumi yoshi is gently turned down by his
friend as he states that his heritage
will find its way back itself and that
no matter what it will return
he then says that despite sumi yoshi
viewing him as powerful he was unable to
protect what was important to him and
had little worth
tangido internally begs the man to not
think of himself like that and cries as
he wakes up from the dream
heavily bandaged and hooked up to
multiple ivs
he tries to figure out where he is and
is suddenly interrupted by a falling vas
kano stands in shock in the doorway and
reveals that tanjudo had been
unconscious for two months tearfully
stating that she's glad he's awake
goto a male member of the kakushi who
are the clean-up brigade of the demon
slayers is seen walking down the halls
of the butterfly mansion while he walks
through the halls he reveals that two
months have passed since the end of the
battle at the entertainment district
kikushi remembers how badly injured
everyone was especially tanjido hoping
that the smell of his castella will wake
the comatose tangero he is left
completely stunned and infuriated when
he walks in to discover a shattered vas
on the floor noticing kano he announces
the food that he brought and asks her to
clear a free spot for it tanjuro then
wearily thanks goto for the dessert
leaving him completely stunned so much
that he drops his entire dish he then
angrily bursts out at kano for not
saying that tangido had regained his
consciousness and comically abuses her
for her silence before running into the
hall to summon everyone
keo sumi and nahu shed tears of joy
after discovering that he has awakened
but are then immediately frightened when
aoe comes flying into the room after
untangling herself she begins to sob at
his bedside and tangier finds out that
zenitsu had woken up the day after the
battle and had just left screaming and
crying before going on a job tengan the
sound hishera left after the battle
being carried away by his wives despite
his terrible injuries when tanjido goes
to ask about imyosuke he is told by aoi
that he has been horribly poisoned and
that inosuke was on the verge of death
while she's explaining tangier begins to
wonder if he was hallucinating or not as
he spots inosuke hanging on the ceiling
everyone in the room then looks up in
horror to witness inosuke crawling
upside down on the ceiling he loudly
praises tan pachero for noticing him on
the ceiling andoski drops down onto
tanjido's bed then brags that he woke up
a week before him and how he had poison
resistance making him in his eyes
immortal onosuke gloats about having an
apparent immortality and is swiftly
corrected by goto that he is just simply
a because of this a fight ensues
between the two and aoi rushes to break
it up as the bickering gets louder kanu
tries to quiet the room down until she
has to tell the other two to be quiet as
tangero has actually fallen back asleep
anosuke immediately worries that tanjido
has returned into his comatose state but
the others assure him that he just needs
to get more rest a week goes by with
tanjuno making a full recovery and
enosuke embarking on a new mission while
tanjuno works on improving his weakened
stay he asks kio and naho about his new
sword but to his complete dismay they
show him the angry scratched drones of
hate which clearly depict that the
swordsmith would not make tanchito
another sword now distraught kyo tries
to upload tanchiro by saying that hotaru
has been the difficult one and he should
try to meet with him at the swordsmith
village to discuss it in person tanjuno
ends up asking for permission to visit
the village in which kagaya allows him
to go he sends a new kakushi to take him
she informs him that in order to keep
the village safety hidden tanjanu must
be carried there and will have to put on
a blindfold plug in earplugs and
especially plug his nose throughout the
journey tangier was frequently passed on
to new kikushi while the crows are also
swapped in an effort to maintain the
location secrecy once tanjuro arrives at
the village he is amazed by the sense of
the hot springs he loudly shares his
gratitude towards the kikushi for
transporting him which echoes loudly
through the hot springs his voice is
eventually heard by the love hashera
matsuri kanroji who is bathing in a
nearby spring once at the swordsmith
village tanjura was greeted by the
villager's chief titchen titchen
kawahara who dubbed himself the best of
his craft in the village teaching
discloses to tanjido that the village is
currently looking for hotaru haganizuka
after he disappeared a few days prior
tanjido comments on his swordsmith's
cute name which tetchen reveals that he
himself gave him that name the chief
notes about hahutaru had always had a
bad temper and we tanjudo attempts to
apologize for fueling this temper
through breaking his swords titran
refutes it by stressing that hotaru
should be creating swords that wouldn't
break he reassures tanjuro that they
will bring hotaru back or alternatively
have a different swordsmith fortune a
new blade titchen then suggests that
tanjuro relax in the hot springs while
advancing to the hot springs tanju runs
into matsuri kanroji who had just
returned from that set hot spring
kinroshi complains about how she was
ignored when she was asked for an
individual's name at the spring tangero
calmed her by revealing that the
villagers were almost done with the
dinner for the guests which matsuri
excitedly hurries off to at the springs
tanger was suddenly hit with a tooth and
a surprise to encounter guinya
shinozugawa he excitedly jumps in the
water and tries to converse with his
fellow demon slayer but is saddened
after genya angrily strikes him and
storms off back at the village tanjulo
praises matsuri for the amount she is
capable of eating declaring that he
himself would also try to eat lots and
grow strong he then brings up genya with
mitsuri sadly observing how the boy must
be tsunami shinizugawa's younger brother
given that they share their last name
despite the win hashera telling her that
he didn't even have one tattoo asks why
she thought it was pussiful and while
playing with nezuko matsuri replies that
she herself had five younger siblings
and had a good relationship with all of
them the two chair and both hope to
someday be able to have a nice
conversation with genya and tanjura
decides to bring him his leftovers since
he didn't come to dinner as they walk
through the corridor with niziko tanjuno
inquires mitsuri on the reason why she
joined the demon slayer corpse
embarrassed she states that she wanted
to find a man to marry someone who was
stronger than her and could protect her
as she goes on about her thoughts
tangier listens in disbelief the trio
are then approached by kakushi who
informs matsuri that her new sword will
be really soon and that she should check
it out so that it could be adjusted if
necessary the hashira bids farewell to
tanjuro and praises him for his hard
work expressing her approval for the
siblings after tanjuro declares that he
will be sure to defeat mozart matsuri
happily hints about a secret weapon
hidden in the village that could make
him even stronger the next day tanjuro
searches through the forest looking for
hotaru and ponders about the secret
weapon mitsuri told him about
in the distance he suddenly hears two
individuals one of them being the mr
shira muchiro tokito behind the trees in
the forest tanjuro worriedly watches as
a young child yells at the mrshera
proclaiming that he wouldn't hand over
his key and his knowledge to him majira
suddenly strikes and grips the boy much
to tanjuro's horror as he races over to
restrain muchero's wrists in an attempt
to force him to let go despite having a
smaller and thinner body composition in
intangido mushiro does not budge and
asks for tanjiro to release his hold
quickly punching him in the stomach and
calling him weak when he does not do so
the hashera then senses a demon in
tangier's box but he slaps his hand away
and saves the boy in the process when
the boy continues denying muchero the
key he insults him and the other
swordsmiths stating they had no worth
besides making swords and this
conversation was currently wasting him
time that could be used to save people
angry at muchero's degrading words
tanjiru hits him and expresses how he
was too cruel to the child while he
states that he does not deny the
accuracy of his words tanjo stresses the
importance of these sword smiths and how
they too are fighting along with the
demon slayers albeit not on the front
lines mageiro cuts him off and hits him
in the neck knocking him out cold right
before losing consciousness tangero
notices hotaru hiding behind a tree
while unconscious tangier has a
conversation between the child and
hotaru but the latter runs off as soon
as tanjiro begins to regain his
consciousness after picking himself up
tanju excitedly inquires whether hotaru
was just there which the boy nervously
denies the boy also reveals that he gave
the key to muchiro which tanjiro
apologises for intervening as it wasn't
his place to he's thanked however for
standing up to the hashera in order to
defend a complete stranger the two
converse and the boy informs tanchito
about the key's use which is to operate
a deteriorating mechanical doll that had
been built by his ancestors and was used
for swordsmen to train with in the
middle of their conversation the two
suddenly heard loud sounds the boy leads
tangier over to where muchero is
intensely training with the battle doll
dubbed yarawichi type zero while
watching tokito train against the doll
tanjo looks at the doll's face and
ponders the idea that he has seen it
before confused as to its appearance
tanju asks why it has six arms in which
he is told that it was modeled after a
real swordsman they dole's six arms were
necessary to imitate the swordsman's
unrealistic movements tanjuro tries to
push for more information but the boy
apologizes and states he didn't know
much else besides that it originated in
the sengoku period surprised tanjuno
notes how that must mean that the
yoruichi type zero is over 300 years old
and even so it still hadn't been
destroyed the boy replies that his
ancestors were able to construct the
doll at a level that couldn't be
accomplished again at the present time
hence its durability and that he
wouldn't be able to fix it himself
especially without the aid of his late
father given that he himself doesn't
possess the knowledge or skills to do so
because of this tangible realizes the
reasoning behind his resolve to not hand
over the key to someone who could
potentially destroy the doll while they
continue to observe muchiro for a while
longer tanju admires the hashira's
extraordinary degree of skill despite
being of a similar age matura's crow
chips in and refers to him as a
descendant of the sun breathing users
and a genius leagues different from
tanjuro surprised by his bloodline
heritage he curiously asks why muchero
wasn't able to use sun breathing which
receives him an angry assault by the
crow while being attacked by the crow
tajiro suddenly remembers the dream he
had and how the swordsman he saw had a
face that matched that of the dolls
hearing his words the crow stops and
grumpily questions the logic behind his
words given how the swordsman was from
so long ago the young boy pitches in
proposing that perhaps it was a memory
that was passed on providing the example
of a swordsman inheriting memories from
their swords and skills from their
ancestors suggesting it may be similar
to what tanjuro was experiencing the
crow thinks of this idea as nonsense but
cuts it off as tanjuro introduces
himself to the boy and the boy
introduces himself as kotetsu suddenly
the group hears a sound and witnesses
muchero destroying parts of the doll
with pieces of the armor flying away
devastated at the side kotetsu runs away
and hides in a tree crying over the
broken doll tangelo finds him and
attempts to motivate him by saying he'll
eventually be able to improve and fix it
in which kotitsu replies that he is too
pathetic to do so but hearing this
tanjuro climbs up the tree and flicks
kotetsu as a method of snapping him back
into reality exclaiming how he had to
make the effort and develop the skills
so that even if he wasn't able to fix
the yoruichi type zero the generations
after him would be able to do so tangelo
compares his struggle with kotechus
affirming that even if he dies before he
is able to accomplish his goals someone
else will eventually be able to do so in
his place as long as the framework is
said which is similar to what was said
during tanjuro's dream flashback by the
mysterious man cheered up kotetsu and
tangelo conclude to determinely work
hard together while they chat during a
walk through the forest they encounter
muchiro again who expresses that the
training was helpful however his sword
broke so he will be taking one of the
dole's swords he tosses the broken sword
indifferently to tanjuro asking him to
discard of it at first confused by the
swordsman's attitude tangero realizes he
lacked a malicious intent and likely
wasn't acting rudely on purpose tanjiru
rushes to kotitsu who appears saddened
while staring at the broken doll in the
rain tanjuro suggests they check if it
can still move which is met by approval
from the boy as they pick it up it
remains stagnant for a few moments
before suddenly shifting into a stance
randomly kotitsu then fiercely orders
tangero to train with a doll and become
stronger than muchiro with his aid tanju
begins to train with the yoroichi type
zero while ketetsu uses his analytical
skills and newfound motivation to
excessively critique the demon slayer's
movements he states that until tanjiro
can accomplish what he wants he will not
receive any food kotetsu shows tangido
another method of adjusting the doll's
movements through twisting its fingers
such that it'd coordinate with the
user's weaknesses and compares the
actions to that of plane with a wooden
puzzle box after readjusting the doll
tanju continues brutally training with
her still without food water or sleep
under kotetsu's direction just as
tangible approaches the brink of death
comparable to nearly crossing the sanzu
river which is similar to the great
concept of these sticks but in japanese
mythology because of this almost death
moment he becomes capable of smelling
the incoming movement of the doll and
lands a hit on it earning him his first
meal in a few days after gaining this
ability to predict movements tanjuro
continues to train with the doll and
improves his stamina and four sides in
the middle of a spa with a doll
tangero's newly improved abilities grant
him an opening to be headed however he
hesitates mid-swing and worries about
breaking the door but kotetsu yells at
him to strike reassuring him that he
would be able to fix it internally the
young boy begs tangido to not waver so
that one day he will become stronger
than anyone else with kotichu's approval
obtained tanchito succeeds in landing a
blow to the doll's neck and breaks his
sword in the process he apologizes to
kotetsu for the ruined sword but after
kotitsu's sudden exclamation tangero
turns to see a hidden swords held
emerging from the doll's body where the
head used to be these swords hilt
appearing out of the doll stadls tangido
and kotetsu who shout in shock their
surprise quickly shifts to fascination
and excitement as the pair attempts to
deduce the age of the blade kotetsu
urges tanchiro to take the sword but
tanjuro is adamant on the fact that he
could not and the dull breaking to make
it appear wasn't completely his doing
kotetsu insists as the owner of the doll
that he is the final say and that
tanjuro should take it especially
considering how he needed a new blade
anyways caving in tangerine pulls out
the blade as kotetsu watches excitedly
in anticipation but they are
disheartened after seeing that their
blade had rusted with its age ketitsu
tries to apologize to a tearful tanchiro
for keeping his hopes up but they are
suddenly interrupted by a muscular
hotaru haganezuka emerging from their
woods hotaru mentions that he heard
their conversation and tries to take the
sword from tanjuro and kotetsu they try
to get hotaru to explain why he is
acting this way but the swordsmith
continues to try and take the sword and
finally forces it out of their hands
kozo kanamori appears behind hotaru and
tickles his sides making him fall limp
kozo greets tanjiro and kotetsu and goes
on to explain hotaru's situation he
states that hotaru had been remotely
training in order to improve his forging
skills so that he could make a strong
sword for tanchiro that would not chip
or break in which tanjuru happily
admires hotaru's thoughtfulness kozo
continues on saying how tangiers
replaced requests for swords from hotaru
made him happy as he lost many of his
clients with his personality while they
chat hotaru suddenly regains
consciousness and confidently declares
that he will fix the rusted blade while
kotetsu fusses over how he could have
easily just explained that before they
fought over the sword the next day
tanjulo talks about hotaru's progress on
the sword with genya who is angered by
tanjiru's presence and attempts at
friendliness so he tries to get him to
leave when he starts yelling tangzhido
notices that the tooth he had pulled out
a few days ago had reappeared he
questions him on this and shows the
tooth that he had picked up as proof
discussed in genya and resulting in him
being kicked out of the room saddened
tangero ponders his fellow demon slayers
consistent anger somewhere else as the
calm night continued a lone swordsman
strolls through the village after a bath
and encounters a pot mysteriously placed
on the ground
curiously he reaches for it but is
suddenly engulfed by the pot killing him
gyoko the upper rank 5 emerges and
comments on the disgusting quality of
these swordsmiths as meals elsewhere
upper rank 4 hentengu cows on a roof and
cowardly states that they must quickly
accomplish their mission an asleep
tanjido is woken by tokito pinching his
nose the mr shira questions tanjido if
he knew kozo kanamori's whereabouts as
he was his new swordsmith tanjuno
mentions that he was likely with hotaru
and offers to help find them matura asks
why tanjiro would willingly accompany
him when he had many other things to be
doing and tanjuli replies that he
believes helping others would positively
benefit him at tanjido's words tokito
feels a strong sense of familiarity and
questions him on what he just said the
demon slayer tries to reply but is hit
by an awakened neziko breaking muchiro's
perception seeing nezuko mature comments
on her uniqueness and wonders where he's
seen her before while tanjulo worries
about the chachamaru tamiyo's feline
assistant that it appeared before them
the trio keep thinking about their
respective worries when suddenly tanjido
and muchero sense a presence behind the
door when they glance over hand tengu
crawls into the room without radiating
his presence as a demon surprised
tanjiru and muchiro both realise
hantengu is an upper ranked demon and
prepare to attack with muchiro
immediately using misbreathing fourth
form shifting flow slash but hentangu
swiftly dodges to the ceiling and cries
begging the demon slayers and not to
hurt him tangiero tells himself not to
hesitate and uses hotaro's newly forged
blade to attack hintengu with henokami
kagura sunflower thrust hintengu dodges
again but receives a blow from nizuko
who's in her awakened form realizing
this tangier tells neziko to not
transform fully while at the exact same
time muchiro successfully beheads
hantengu tanjuna remembers that
beheading an upper rank does not
necessarily result in its death based on
his prior fight with daki and guitaro
and tells muchiro to keep his focus
right as he does the seventh head and
the body transform into two new demons
one of which holds a leaf-shaped fan
mushiro attacks the demon with the fan
while tanjuro takes on the other as
muchero rushes to attack the demon waves
his fan at him and intensely blasts
monsieur out of the building tanjuno and
niziko managed to hold on to the rubble
and come face to face with the two
demons kiraku asks his partner sikido if
he was having fun in which sakira
responds negatively and uses his staff
to emit bolts of lightning-like attacks
which slowly make tanjido lose
consciousness but just before he does he
sees genya on the rooftop pointing a gun
directly at sekito ginyu shoots both
sekiro and karaku with his nichiren gun
blasting off sikhido's head and nearly
decapitating karaku karaku expresses his
enjoyment towards the fight as genya
rushes in to slash off his head with an
insurance sword but as he does this
tangero yells at genya that his attacks
were futile and the demons were
willingly being beheaded so they could
keep splitting and increase their attack
power tanjunu begins to desperately
analyze his opponents and tries to
pinpoint their weaknesses but his
thoughts are interrupted by a third
bird-like demon a rogue who lifts him up
into the air with his foot realizing
that each demon has a unique ability
tangible instructs nezuko to insist
genya however horrified he realizes that
genya had been impaled by a fourth demon
a zetsu orogi taunts him for worrying
about the others and not himself
proceeding to generate a sonic scream
tanjiru attempts to counter with
hinokami kagura and successfully cuts
off a rogue's leg but is unable to dodge
his scream and is violently struck with
the attack as he falls he plummets
through trees and lands on the ground he
pleads with himself to get up and
protect the village but his injuries
render him incapable of easily moving
isetsu lands near him and holds his leg
down as he directs another shriek in
tanjido's direction elsewhere mochiro
dashes through the forest as he makes
his way back to the village he spots
kotetsu trying to hold off a minion fish
demon and internally decides that he is
not a priority to save but as he hears
the cries of kotetsu while the demon
grabs him muchira remembers tanjido's
words of how helping others would
positively benefit him he slashes the
fish demon's arm releasing kotetsu and
stands over the boy while requesting for
him to run so that he would not be in
the way mature slashes the fish demon
and decapitates it but it regenerates he
tries breaking the pot stationed on the
demon's back and subsequently makes it
disintegrate the hashera then realises
that the pot was the source of the power
for the demon likely the result of a
blood demon art as he continues to think
a crying ketetsu ambushes him with a hug
and thanks him for saving him the
hashera tells kotetsu to leave as he has
to make it back to the village kotitsu
begs him to not go since kozo and hotado
were under attack while hotaru was
finishing a blade machero tries to turn
down his request but he hesitates when
he hears kagaya yubashiki's voice in his
head who tells him to rediscover himself
surprised at the pause mature thinks
back to when he had gotten amnesia after
being saved by kagaya who had told him
not to worry about the memory lost and
that the mist in his head will
eventually clear out with matters that
seem unimportant at first convinced
maturo carries kotechu with him as they
search for kozo as they continue through
the forest mature begins to doubt if he
was doing the right thing as the village
was still in danger however he pushes
the thought away and reminds himself
that he is the mr shearer acknowledged
by his master in the forest near the
edge of the village tangero dodges an
attack from arogi by slicing his head
splitting him into two more demons the
pair of demons generate more sonic
screams and direct them at tanjuro but
the demon slayer is able to withstand
them and observes that hantenku is most
powerful at four separate demons that
represent the four primary emotions any
more splitting would decrease their
attack strength with this information
tangible continues to attack orogi and
is slashed across the chest with a demon
sharp claws but manages to land multiple
blows on his head back in the building
neziko struggles against karaku sakiro
impatiently asks for his partner to
defeat her and azitsu volunteers to land
the final blow however as izetsu
attempts to pull his spear out of genya
the demon that point his gun at him and
blast off his head sakira berates izitsu
for his foolishness after genya shoots
off his head and the demon responds by
forcibly pulling the spear out of genya
mortally damaging him he comments on how
the spear lodged in ginya's body had
prevented him from dying after it hit
his vitals points and now he will perish
ignoring him kenya quietly chants the
amida sutra which is recognised by
azitsu angered at the delay sequito
yells at azitsu to kill genya but the
demon slayer dodges his spear and
attacks azitsu from behind with a
natural sword however before kenya can
cut the demon's head he gets blasted
from sequito's lightning and becomes
incapacitated
though he manages to hit zaquito with a
bullet izetsu responds by hitting him
with a spare shaft noggin him into the
wall still struggling against nezuko
karaku gleefully watches his companions
fight and then impales nezuko through
the stomach with his foot he gives
instructions to sikido and pulls
nezuko's arm off but he receives a hefty
kick from her and nearly loses his head
using blood demon art nesiko proceeds to
burn karaku and pulls herself from his
grasp when karaku is yelled at by
sequito she takes his fan and blows him
out of the building she tries to do the
same thing with aikido but he sticks his
staff through her neck and shocks her
with bolts of lightning paralyzing her
back in the forest tangido continues
fighting against hirogi who continuously
slashes him with his talons tanjo forces
himself not to panic and makes it a
priority to return to the building
internally telling kenya and nezuko to
keep holding on ginyu recovers from
being hit into the wall and continues
muttering the chand surprised that he is
still alive sikido questions him smiling
ginya holds up his gun and tells him his
name stating that he will be the one to
kill him while tangero continues his
fight against orogi he considers using
the demon's flight ability to escape the
forest and return to niziko and genya
after finalizing his plan tanjiru stabs
the demon in the mouth after being
picked up and uses the force to smash
into the building's exterior wall
completely destroying it tangero picks
himself up in time to see cicado
paralyzing mizuko when he dashes to save
her cicada generates another staff and
tries to hit tangido but the boy uses
aroki's foot to defend himself and
prevent the lightning from reaching him
he then slices the demon's head and
tongue stalling for some time to pull
the staff out of niziko's neck suddenly
tangero gets slammed down on the ground
with his second staff and is about to
receive a shock of lightning but niziko
recovers in time to burn cicada and
prevent him from hurting him relieved
that neziko's blood demon art is
effective he looks up to see karaku saw
through the air and hit the building's
floor with enough pressure to bought a
hole through it and rendered tanjido and
nezuko unconscious the demons then
regroup and gaze over their opponents
planning on dealing the final blow in
the depths of the forest tokito defends
the fish demon and saves kozo after a
reunion muchero requests for kozo to
provide him with his fixed blade to
replace the chipped one he is currently
using kozo agrees that mushiro needs a
new blade and mentions that it was
tanjudo who asked him to fix the old one
he leads the mrshira and kotetsu to the
shed where haganizuka is currently
working kozo explains that he has a
sword for machiro and is shed and after
he receives it he should immediately
head back to the village to protect the
chief monsieur denies this proposal and
pulls kozu back when he tries to advance
towards the shed he tells him he senses
something and instantly sees a pot
rattle in front of him emerging from the
pot gyoko the upper rank five comes out
and identifies tokito muchero as a
hashura for realizing that he was there
gyoko introduces himself to tokito
kanamori and kitsu and asks for a brief
moment for he kills them he calmly
presents his art piece titled death
throws of the smiths which consisted of
multiple mangled smiths and blades
passed through their bodies the demon
starts describing his detailed work
while the horrified kozo and kotyetsu
name these swordsmiths gyoko taunts them
by their reactions and twists one of the
swords resulting in one of the
swordsmiths screaming out in pain
aggravated by his demonstration mature
attacks gyoko but he retreats into his
pot before the hashera can cut him he
reappears in another pot on the shed's
roof and mature notes his ability to
switch between the pots then slices up
the one on the roof gyoko swiftly
switches to yet another pot appearing
out of thin air on the ground and
expresses the great irritation at mature
for destroying his artwork the demon
summons a couple of fish demons which
surprised matero with blood demon art
thousand needle fish killer and kyoko
showers hundreds of sharp needles at him
the swordsman manages to dodge the first
onslaught of needles but is forced to
take multiple hits from the second
attack of needles to protect kozo and
kotetsu he tells the civilians to get
away as the fish continue to attack him
gyoku stands on the side and laughs at
muchero's appearance which consists of
multiple needles sticking out of him he
reveals that the needles contain poison
and chides him for having to die because
he saved insignificant people gyoko's
words spark an intense sense of
familiarity to muchero as he tries to
remember where he had heard them before
suddenly recalling a hot summer day in a
small abode the demon expresses his
eagerness to create a nice sculpture
with a sharer but is interrupted by
muchero attacking him joko uses blood
demon art water prison pot to surround
his opponent with a pot-shaped prison of
water rendering him unable to breathe or
attack as his blade could not pierce
through the layer of water he laughed at
his predicament and proclaims that the
twelve kazuki desire to weaken the demon
slayers and reach kagaya yubishiki
nearby a crow cores through the night as
matsuri kanroji runs through the forest
she tells herself to hurry and
enthusiastically states the convenience
of this swordsmith village being close
to where she was stationed in the
village a group of swordsmiths try to
defend themselves as a fish demon
approaches them matsuri kanroji arrives
and slashes the demon killing it she
apologizes for her late arrival and
heads towards the chief's residence at
tejin's location a swordsman tries to
save him from being crushed by a fish
demon but his injuries rend him unable
to move masudi appears right before him
and instructs him to stay still to
prevent his injuries from becoming worse
the lavishera then attacks with love
breathing first form shivers of first
love slicing the demon and making it
release the chief after defeating it
matsuri angrily mutters how those who
hurt others will never make her heart
throb as titchen falls from the demon's
grasp she manages to catch him before he
hits the ground crying she begs him to
wake up and after a few coughs he
comments on how he was caught by someone
so cute relieved to see that he was
alright matsuri quickly goes to help the
others that were wounded elsewhere
tanjuro suddenly awakes to hear the
voices of huntengo's various forms he
looks to see neziko carrying him through
the building as she dodges bolts of
lightning and tanju remembers that they
were previously knocked unconscious they
get hit with a shock of lightning and
tangerine manages to defend niziko and
himself from urugu swoop running out of
their room sakiru yells at kiraku for
being too slow and tells him to use his
uchiwa fan to destroy the building to
which he agrees the pressure from
kraku's fan attack makes the building
collapse with nezuko caught inside the
mess she grasps onto tangero's blade
making herself bleed while tanjulo begs
for her to let go and says he will find
a way to move the rubble but she refuses
to stop holding the blade and uses her
blood demon art to set us on fire
tangido notices the blade burning from
the heat and is shocked to see it change
color from black to red as it gets
enveloped in flames all of a sudden
through an inherited memory tangero sees
an unnamed man and woman comment on how
a swordsman with earrings had a blade
that was normally jet black but somehow
turned red when he was in combat tangero
links the swordsman's blade with his own
noticing the similarities and their
colour changes and how his was thanks to
nezuko's blood demon art he pushes
himself to ignore his body's fatigue and
injuries and tells himself to meet the
expectations of those who have helped
him so far the three demons belittle
tanjiro and rush towards him to attack
but they see the red sword and muzan
kibijitsu's memories trigger the forms
recognize the red sword as one used by
the demon slayer that nearly killed
their master and as tanjiru swings his
sword back his motions greatly resemble
those of these swordsman stunned the
three forms are all then slashed with
the hinokami kagura dragon sun halo head
dance after decapitating him tanju
recognizes the fiery sensation when
cutting down the three demons as the
same one he felt when he dealt the final
blow to guatara at the entertainment
district he goes to look for hantengu's
last form izetsu and sees him impaled to
a tree with his own spear as genya
shinozugawa stands in front of him
holding the demon's head tanjiro's
relief over genya's safety and the
defeat of aizetsu quickly switches to
horror as genya turns to reveal the
demon-fired face his thoughts are
interrupted by a yelling karaku who
complains about his inability to
regenerate and the burning sensation in
his wounds tangero feels uncertain if
defeating the four emotion demons is the
correct way to finish the upper rank
four and at that moment he smells a
fifth body he tries to think of how to
find it but kenya grabs him declaring
that he will be the one to defeat the
upper rank four and become a hashera not
tangido realising that genya has not
succumbed to the demon instincts tanjuro
and niziko give him full support of his
goals much to ginya's surprise their
conversation abruptly ends when cicada
blasts lightning towards them tanjoro
splits up with genya and izuko to run
off and find the fifth body surgenya can
be the one to behead him he rushes
around and desperately searches finally
spotting the body cowering and quivering
behind a bush he hears it muttering
encouragement to himself saying the
emotion demons would defeat these
slayers tangelo gives directions to
genya about where to find the fifth form
of hantengu and asks nezuko to provide
him assistance he then is nearly swept
away by karakou's wind attack nezuko
attempts to slash shakedo before he can
release lightning on her brother but she
gets impaled by z2 spear tangero hinders
kato's movements by cutting off his hand
holding the staff and the demon notes
tanjiru's exceptional battle adaption
skills orogi is slashed by the flaming
blade and niziko grabs izitsu enveloping
him in fire and burning him kuroku
counters tangita by slamming his fan and
forcing tanju to the ground with
pressure however before he can again
attack his arm falls off and he curses
tanjuro for kasi nerds genya receives
some more directions from tangido as the
latter yells them out and he desperately
keeps searching for the fifth body after
more continuous searching genius spots
hentangu behind the bushes shrunk down
he shoots him with his gun but the demon
dodges and runs away while pursuing him
ginya inwardly chastises the demon's
wimpy nature and swings at his neck with
his maturing sword he pushes himself to
force the blade through hunting's neck
but his sword suddenly snaps due to the
demon's thick neck he tries shooting
again with his gun to no avail all of a
sudden cicada appears behind genya and
aims his staff at his neck distressed
kenya remarks that he cannot regenerate
his head and is about to die but before
he gets struck he thinks of his elder
brother sunimi and how he wanted to
become a hashera so he could apologize
to him for something that had happened
between them kenya thinks back to his
past where his small and weak mother
would often be abused by his father
alongside himself and his siblings one
night kenya notices that she was late
coming back even after their older
brother sunimi went to look for her he
calms her siblings and tells them to
sleep but they suddenly hear a knock on
the door kenya tries to tell them not to
open it in case it was a stranger but
they ignore his warning and are
immediately slashed upon reaching it
ginya is also cut across the cheek and
he states in horror at a figure grasping
onto the ceiling within the darkness
preventing him from identifying it
suddenly sanemi appears and tackles it
out of the window while yelling at genya
to run terrified ginyu checks the status
of his siblings and tries to cover their
wounds despite their bodies already
being cold when he runs off to find a
doctor he approaches an injured sunimi
standing over the corpse of the
demon-fired mother dismayed at the site
genya runs over to cradle his mother's
body and his arms and cries calling
tsunemi a murderer genya after
remembering this past internally
apologizes to his older brother for a
shock that overwhelmed him to the point
of labeling sanemi as their mother's
killer even despite the struggles that
he must have had to protect him by
killing her isukito aims for ginya's
neck the demon slayer thinks of all of
his regrets and flaws a memory of sanemi
is a heshira declaring that he had no
brother sad and scanya and he thinks
about how he wasn't able to reach a
share of status to earn the right of
apologizing to him right as cicada
scrapes kenya's neck with his staff
tanjuro appears above them and saves him
by cutting cicada's neck he shouts at
ginya to not give up reminding him that
he was supposed to be reaching for the
goal of hashera and that he should only
think about beheading hantengu as
tangero finishes speaking he notices
izetsu approaching him from behind the
demon uses its blood demon art weeping
spears to attack tanjido but he is
shielded by genya who gets impaled and
multiple spots on his body ginya tells
tanjido that he should be the one to
behead hintengu and tanjuro willingly
accepts dashing over to hantengu and
hitting him with his flaming sword as
tajiro makes contact with his neck
hentengu lets out a piercing scream
tanju puts pressure on his blade and
attempts to force it through hunting his
neck the demon continues his high
pitched screaming but tangier refuses to
waver suddenly a dark figure appears
behind him and tanjunu notices that it
does not smell like any of the previous
emotion demons opting to ignore it he
tries to behead hunting you but his
sword loses its power from niziko genya
aims at the figure behind tanjido but he
is unable to shoot without possibly
hitting his teammate the mysterious
demon hits a drum and a giant
dragonfaced tree immediately sprouts
nezuko barely manages to jump and and
save her brother losing one leg in the
process she immediately regrows it right
before they land but suffers a massive
loss of energy as tanjuna makes sure she
is safe the demon begins talking and
names the negative emotions that
individuals who are pure evil emit
specifically those who harm the weak
infuriated kanjiru realizes that there
are now six demons but notices he can't
sense the previous four genya witnesses
the appearance of the sixth demon and
alarmingly recounts how it used to be
the anger demon sikhido however after
tanjido struck hantengu's neck skado had
forcefully absorbed his three
counterparts and transformed into the
childlike demon in front of them the
demon hits another drum and wraps
antengu within his tree trunks shielding
him tanjulo tries to stop him but he and
genya are both held back by the pure
strength of the sixth demon's aura a
result of hantengu's power growing as
the situation worsens the demon labels
them as evil and when tanjoro demands an
explanation as to why he replies that
the label is reserved to those who try
to hurt the weak furious at his words
contradicting the fact that he had eaten
hundreds of innocent humans tanjo loudly
vows to cut him down
still trapped in gyoko's water prison
pot tokito thinks to himself that he has
enough air for one more attack
proceeding to use missed breathing first
form low clouds distant haze but his
attempt is unsuccessful and without any
more air in his lungs he accepts his
fate thanking kagaya yubishiki for his
support and wishes him luck finding
someone to replace his ashira position
however he is surprised by a vision of
tanjuro who tells him that nobody knows
what the future will be like a statement
tanjido had never said to him in the
nearby shed kanamori gets slashed by
gyoko as he desperately shields hotaru
from the demon unaware of their presence
hotari fixates on restoring the blade
given to him by tanjudo and mutters
about the incredible quality of its
craftsmanship goku observes him
confirming that he is not the chief due
to his age the demon calls out to him
but hotaru does not respond and
continues muttering about the
eccentricity of the blade a level of
concentration that astonishes kyoko
jealous of otaru's fixation for his
craft kyoko slashes him multiple times
and summons another fish demon that
attacks kozo hotaru continues to ignore
him and his mask falls off from the
attack revealing his face and kozo
rushes to try and snap him out of this
trance goku vows to break the
swordsman's continuous persistence
outside mature loses his ability to
breathe tangible's vision keeps
appearing in front of him and expresses
how muchero himself would decide his own
fate muchiro dismisses his words but
tanjiro continues and informs the mr
shira that someone would come to save
him although he tries to disclose his
distaste for relying on someone else the
vision of tanjido tells him that
sometimes he has to rely on others as he
cannot do everything on his own mature
listens to his remarks and berates
himself for not working hard enough to
prevent mistakes from happening and
additionally for overestimating himself
suddenly a knife enters the water and
kutetsu begs muchero not to die as he
futile he struggles to pierce the prison
mature tries to get him to go protect
the chief rather than worry about him
but kotitsu persistently keeps trying
one of gyoko's minions appear behind the
child and slashes at him as he runs the
demon uses its claw to stab kotetsu
seeing this attack mochiro deems the boy
is dead however kotichu stays standing
and returns back to the water blowing
air into it and transferring a breath
from him to machero
as much inhales the air he remembers
tangero's words about how helping others
would in turn help him and connects his
words to a man maturo's father freshly
motivated the hishera uses missed
breathing second formed eight-layered
mist and successfully destroys the water
prison as he escapes the prison tokusa
realises that tanjiru's eyes are the
same shade of red as his father's mojiro
pulls out the needles numbing his face
and begins regaining more of his
memories remembering that his father was
a woodcutter kagaya yubishiki's soothing
words enter his mind and he sorrowfully
thinks about his master's disease as he
crawls to kotetsu cutting apart the fish
demon that had attacked him muchuro's
memory progression continues as he
recalls his mother's death from illness
and his father's death from falling off
a cliff when he tries to speak with
kotetsu machira suddenly remembers about
his older brother yuchiro toquito his
twin and sole companion after their
parents death when they were 10.
thinking back to his past mature recalls
yuchiro's blunt personality after they
were orphaned and how he ridiculed their
father for trying to save their mother a
man who had died when aiming to help
others crying matero unsuccessfully
attempts to get yuchiro to stop
insulting their father and instead
received insults from him regarding the
first character in his name moo which
could literally be interpreted as
nothingness the twins continue to live
together despite this strained
relationship which mature had attributed
to his older brother potentially
despising him after surviving on their
own for a while the siblings were
visited by kagai's wife who had told
them about their swordsman heritage
angered by her presence yuchiro drove
her away and intensely berated muchero
after he had expressed his interest in
becoming a swordsman straining their
relationship to the point of forfeiting
any communication between them one
summer night a demon entered the twins
home cutting off yuchiro's left arm and
insulting the sibling's lack of worth
angry muchiro to the point of releasing
an explosive rage the boy managed to pin
the demon down and crush it watching it
disintegrate as the sun rose calling
back to yuchiro maturo witnessed his
brother's final words begging the gods
to spare machero as he was a good person
that desired to help others unlike
himself as muchero held his brother's
hand he told him that the mo in his name
was actually meant to represent the moo
and mugen
finally recovering his memories mature
awakens his true strength and gains mr
like markings all over his face as he
powerfully grips his blade finally
receiving his demon slayer mark yutiro
apologizes to his brother for his
inability to be nice to him and that he
truly tried to protect him clutching his
hand as his memories are shifted back to
reality in the shed goku was infuriated
to see hotaru continuing to work on the
blade despite the numerous injuries that
he had inflicted on him including the
loss of one eye on the side kanemuri
struggles to move and gyoko goes to
finish him off but is interrupted by
mature's attack surprised at his escape
from the water prison kyoku sees these
strange markings on his face and
realises it is similar to the boy with
the hanafuda earrings that muzan had
told him about the boy's composed face
and attack speed despite being struck
with paralyzing needles earlier bothers
the demon as muchuro rushes in to attack
again anticipating that gyoku uses his
blood demon art octopus vaz hell octopus
legs fill the entire shed and trap
muchero as they destroy the building at
the last moment kozo gives muchiro his
mended nature and sword outside hosaru
is knocked aside from the attack but
pays no mind to it as he returns to
sharpening his blade his stubborn
persistence puzzling the demon goku opts
to temporarily ignore these swordsmiths
and instead focus on muchero as he wraps
him and kozo within his attack
exclaiming that he will crush them
despite gyoku's claims that the octopus
is too powerful to be cut machiero
cleanly slices through it and releases
him and kozo mature thanks the
swordsmith though kozo denies stating
that he simply followed the instructions
from his previous swordsmith mature
thinks back to a conversation with the
aforementioned swordsmith tetsuedo and
when he had expressed deep concern for
his client after learning how hard he
had worked and how difficult it was for
him to cope with his memory loss
eternally apologizing to him for causing
worry mature tells tetsuedo that he is
alright and proceeds to use a
misbreathing fifth form sea of clouds
and haze to cut apart the rest of the
octopus's tentacles goku watches it and
praises him for his speed but retorts
that this swordsman will not be able to
catch up to his pace however majira
refutes his warning and suggests that
the demon centers have become sluggish
then a confused gyoko witnesses his neck
he cut from the hashera's previous
attack angered kyoko tells him not to
underestimate his string mature said
that his rival's looks are absolutely
disgusting and that he thinks he
scurries around and filth which angered
gyoko who tells tokido to shut up but
suddenly as gyoko speaks machira notices
something about the demon's pot he tells
him that he just noticed that it wasn't
symmetrical and was shoddy workmanship
which causes gyoko to explode in anger
screaming at majero he uses his blood
demona 10 000 gliding slime fish but the
mr shearer dodges with complete ease he
then uses missed breathing sixth form
lunar dispersing mist which manages to
cut all of the fish that kyoku had
released however when those said fish
are killed by an aturan sword they spray
a poison which is absorbed by the skin
just before they turn to dust because of
this gyoku has a quick moment to ensure
michiro's demise
however to kyoko's complete surprise
mature uses his misbreathing third form
scattering missed splash which manages
to make all of the poison that was
falling down towards tokito fly off then
with the momentum gained from his
previous attack he cuts into gyoko's
neck but just as he begins to cut
through he realized at that moment that
gyoko had begin to appear on a nearby
tree while transforming into a new form
one of which only two other people had
ever seen he tells tokito that his
transparent scales are stronger than
diamonds and to kneel down before his
perfect beautiful form but in a complete
contrast to kyoko's expectations muchiro
doesn't react any differently to his new
form which fills gyouko with rage he
dives towards muchero and goes to hit
him with more demonic fish however
mature manages to escape and flees to a
nearby tree branch while still on the
branch gyoho asks muchero what he thinks
of his speed and his god-like power
which can turn anything or anyone he
touches with his fists into his adorable
fish after gyoko has finished his
monologue about his perfect beauty
mature antagonizes him some more saying
that even the strongest attacks are
pointless if they do not hurts mature
thinks back to his master's words
remembering that if he digs in with both
feet he can use his full strength and
that if he knows who he is then no demon
can ever run when you are bringing down
a blade that knows no hesitation or
confusion he urges himself to remember
the boiling anger when he saw maggots
crawling all over his brother's rotted
body and how he himself became infested
with those said maggots slowly being
eaten alive he thinks that even if he
loses his memory his body will remember
the anger they will not leave him until
his death that is the true reason as to
why he is trained so hard to the point
of vomiting blood as kyoku rushes at
tokito he tells him to behold his true
magnificence before using his blood
demon art killer fish scales yoko says
that his scales make it unable to
predict his law-defying movements and
begins wondering why he should turn
muchero into after he kills him but
taquito uses misbreathing seventh form
obscuring clouds to disorientate the
enemy he then appears and seems to
vanish whenever gyoko attempts to attack
him goku is confused as he looks for the
slayer only to find that the whole place
has been entirely enveloped and missed
all of a sudden mature then appears as
he utters the words asking the demon if
he had actually thought that he was the
only one who wasn't being serious before
as he says these words the demon's head
gets completely sliced in half cutting
him from the base of his neck
decapitating him in that moment kyoko is
confused as to why everything is upside
down all of a sudden as his head flies
through the ear and falls to the ground
as this happened mochiro tells him that
this is the end goodbye you don't ever
need to be reborn yoshi begins screaming
and becomes enraged at his complete
disbelief when he realized he's been
beheaded by a mere child it is then
revealed that muchuro drastically
changed the speed of his movements to
disorientate the enemy and that when he
wants to he can go really slow or really
fast with the higher speeds even
exceeding kyoko's gyoko then starts
completely freaking out about how he
can't lose to such a low life form he
tells tokiso that he is with a hundred
of him and that he is a chosen one as he
yells at muchero he gets halfway through
calling him a maggot but before he can
get it out his head is completely sliced
into bits by tokito as he tells him to
just go to hell already immediately
after muchiro toquito defeated gyoko
kanamori was extremely concerned for his
health but taquito was convinced he was
fine even though his health was
obviously deteriorating when kozo kept
persisting for machero to actually
realise he is heard he instead insisted
that he was fine and asked him to check
up on kotetsu but as he says this
muchero starts vomiting foam from the
mouth due to the poison that had finally
reached his blood circulation and
because of this he passed out cozy
begins panicking and calls haganezuka to
help him but instead kotetsu shows up
beside him and told him to put mishiro
on his side kozu instantly remarks that
this must be the ghost of the boy
kotetsu bakutsu insisted that he wasn't
a ghost and goes on to prove that the
wound on his arm is extremely deep and
he may die if he does not stop the
bleeding though when it came to his
stomach the help that tanjudo had
entrusted to him to put back on his new
katana had ended up saving him meanwhile
mushura was having a flashback of
kuchiro and goku supporting him and
doing their best his father then
appeared behind him patting his back
comforting him and telling him that it
all worked out
uchiro suddenly appeared telling his
younger brother that he had done well as
mutual wakes from his flashback it flies
over to tangero who was still fighting
against the other remaining demon
tanjulo thinks to himself that there are
five dragon heads that can stretch
around 20 yards as he thinks he has
figured something out he begins to use
hinokami kagura clear blue but is
immediately stopped by one of the
demon's scream attacks sitting in him
flying back and crashing into the trees
as he tries to stand back up he begins
vomiting and realizes his eardrums had
burst making it almost impossible to
stand due to the dizziness when another
attack comes flying in tangier barely
manages to escape having his foot almost
completely crushed by the shock wave
tangible realizes that the demon can use
the strength of the previous kiduraku
demons and that the overall power of its
attacks are increasing as he barely
manages to dodge another attack he is
caught completely off guard by its
technique as it stretches out and
attempts to chomp down on him again just
as tangible gets caught by the demon's
attack the love hashera finally makes
her arrival apologising for barely
making it in time kanroji tells tangido
to just rest and that he had done a
great job before proceeding to yell at
the upper rank 4 demon to give back both
niziko and genya but immediately gets
told to shut up as only one person in
this world can ever give him orders the
demon child uses crazed cry of thunder
death but kanjiro easily counters using
love breathing cat love a shower it is
revealed that matsuri sword is very thin
and flexible the speed of her techniques
plus that of even tengan uzui that speed
is made possible not only by the
flexibility of a powerful katana but by
her own flexibility and incredible range
of motion her katana is extremely
difficult to use and is liable to injure
anyone else who uses it making a weapon
that only she can use as the fight
continues matsuri uses her love
breathing seeking form love pangs and
love breathing sixth form cat leg winds
of love consecutively zohar tuken the
child demon notices that she is keeping
up with the speed and decides to try and
smother her with a flurry of his
techniques he then uses blood demon art
countless striking trees but matsuri
uses her love breathing fifth floor my
swaying love wild claw to cut through
the attack reaching zoho tarkin's body
as tanjido sees this he shouts at her
that he is not hinting who's real body
which causes kanruji to get caught right
in the firing range azohaku-tin then
releases his blood demon art compressed
sound waves which matsuri had no other
choice but to face the attack head on as
matsuri is left paralyzed and begins to
lose consciousness the demon realizes
that she has an immense strength and
decides that because she is a special
constitution he is going to eat her and
says that eating her superior flesh will
directly lead to gaining strength as he
ferociously bears down on her head
maturity's life flashes right before her
eyes and she remembers her first fiancee
telling her that only a bear boy or cow
would take her as their wife along with
continuing to insult her hair color he
says that it makes him shudder just to
think about it being passed on to his
children then tells you to forget about
him and the fact that their marriage
interview had ever happened i then
explained that mitsuri has a special
muscle composition her arms are thin and
look weak but her muscle density is
actually eight times that of a regular
humans at 14 months old she was able to
pick up a 33 pound pickling stone she
had an almost unsustainable appetite
eating almost the same amount as three
sumo wrestlers the day her marriage was
called off she decided to hide all of
her peculiar traits until one day a man
appeared saying that he wanted to marry
her as she suddenly gets snapped back
into reality kanroji finds that tanjiro
nezuko and genya had managed to save her
from sohaku 10's first tangero and genya
say that matsuri is their last hope
encouraging her to get back up and fight
hansenku releases another attack however
matsuri manages to get up in time and
cuts through his attack protecting the
four of them all the while matsudi is
screaming at hantengu saying that she
will not let her comrades die as the
demon slayer core is an important place
to her as she goes into another
flashback she remembers kagaya telling
matsudi that she is a special person
chosen by the gods and she should be
proud of her strength telling her that
whoever speaks ill of her actually just
fears her talent maturity sincerely
thanks her father and mother all of the
demon slayers who had taken her in all
of the people she had protected and a
guru for giving her her striped socks
she rethinks how she wondered if it was
okay to be strong because she was a girl
and realizes that she herself suppressed
her own strength out of fear but she
isn't like that anymore she has driven
to protect people back in reality as she
flies forward she cuts through
hantenku's attack and urges herself to
get stronger tanjuro genya and nezuko
start looking for hantingu's real body
while matsuri deals with the other
hansengu notices the trio looking for
the body and tries to relate an attack
their way but it is cut down by matsuri
before it can reach them matsuri is
moving faster than before and hintenku
doesn't know how he then notices a
birthmark on his chest start to grow and
remarks that it looks similar to a demon
pattern antengu releases another attack
but mitsuri easily cuts through it
meanwhile ginyu tanjido and niziko are
fighting a tree that is controlled by
hintenku and his real body is hid inside
it but they cannot cut it while your
arms are occupied holding on to the tree
which leaves genya no choice but to eat
the tree it is then revealed that genya
cannot use the breath but instead has
the special ability to temporarily
inherit the traits of the demon if he
eats their flesh the top part of the
tree falls to the ground after ginya
eats the lower part of the plant cutting
through the trunk of the tree tanjuro
then attempts to cut the tree up but is
blocked by the branches which act like
whips as this happens nisiko sets the
tree and tangero's sword on fire with
her blood and tangier uses dance of the
fire god flame waltz to cut the tree in
half to reach the hollow inside where
hantengu's real body is but
unfortunately he already made his escape
as tanjiru screams at hantengu saying
that he will make the demon pay for
every sin he has committed hinting
remembers someone saying that everything
he does in his life is his
responsibility but he says that he
hasn't done anything wrong in his entire
life in that moment kenya screams at him
calling him a throwing an entire
tree towards the miniature hentengu
niziko and tanjiro duck as genya angrily
rips trees from the roots and throws
them at hansenku despite ripping out
numerous trees each one fails to
accurately hit hanshengu niziko then
emerges and attempts to quickly swipe
against hingu but he evades her and
quickly speeds off thinking of what to
do tanjulo recalls a conversation he had
with zinitsu regarding total
concentration he circulates air
throughout the fibers and his muscles
and the blood in his veins and through
the small conversation tangent was able
to quickly blast towards tentengu in an
instant
as tanjuro catches hansengu he swings
his flaming blade down and makes contact
with a miniature demon he begins willing
himself with all of his might to push
through but all of a sudden the tiny
hentangu transforms into a grotesque
oversized demon screaming at tangido
asking him whether or not he felt sorry
for him hentinku grabs a hold of
tanjulo's face and begins to attempt to
crush his head but just before he is
able to do so ginyu makes it in time and
plies the fingers of the demon away from
tangero's head while he does this nezuko
flies over top and instantaneously likes
to transfer demon on fire but this also
affects kenya because he had eaten some
of han tiengu's flesh as he backs away
from the burning pile of bodies they
slip off the side of the cliff and smash
onto the ground below hunting who begins
to worry as his counterpart currently
fighting kanroji is using too much
strength not leaving him with enough to
escape he thinks to himself that he must
replenish himself with human flesh and
notes that there are three sword smiths
nearby he concludes that he will first
power up by eating those three humans
and then make his escape estanjudo
struggles behind he goes to use total
concentration to kick himself towards
hentingu but all of a sudden a katana
flies through the air and landed right
in front of tangido giving him the
perfect opportunity to finally defeat
the demon as he wonders who threw the
sword he can see an intensely injured
muchero screaming at him to use the
blade tanjulo grips the blade and thanks
everyone before using hinokamikagura
dancing flash to completely decapitate
the demon finally ending their struggle
as the first light of dawn singles
daybreak tangier realizes this and tries
to tell neziko to go and hide in the
shade but this only hits del ears
causing niziko to run his way and worry
he yells at niziko to go hide in the
shade but then notices niziko is
pointing at hinting's decapitated body
which is still moving and attacking the
villagers tangero looks at the
decapitated head and reads resentment
written on the tongue of the body where
there should be the word fear meaning
that the body tantrude decapitated was
not the real one before tangero can take
any action to find the real body the
rays of light from the rising sun reach
niziko which causes her to begin to burn
up tangier shields her with his body and
tells her to shrink smaller but this is
all for naught as she is still getting
burned and all the others are too far
away to help him he realizes that
antingu's body will get to the villages
before he can put nezuko in the box and
save them leaving him with an almost
impossible decision but before he can
even make it nezuko kicks him in the
direction of the villagers and smiles as
she sacrifices herself for the sake of
the villagers tanger cries as he decides
that he needs to find the real body
running in the direction of the fake
body
he starts by sniffing out the real body
finding that it's in the headless body's
heart as the headless hentingu catches
the villagers tangero lands directly in
front of him and tells him tengu that
now it's time to pay for his sins
because of these words memories from
huntinghu's previous life flash before
his eyes revealing who the demon slayer
truly was just before tangero slices
through the headless demon into
hantengu's real body hid inside his
heart finally cutting his head off this
time tangero instantly collapses on the
ground in sadness and exhaustion as he
realizes that he has won the fight but
in the same moment he has lost his
sister but as tanjiru weeps the
villagers shake him and point in the
direction behind him to the complete
surprise of everyone standing in the sun
healed and uninjured as naziko looking
more stunning than evo tangero stares in
utter disbelief as his sister greets him
under the warmth of the sun for the
first time in years
skipping away from niziko we go over to
tamiyos where she is writing a letter
mean fatanjido in the letter she thanks
him for giving her the blood of the 12
kazuki moons and neziko she tells him
that the components of niziko's blood
changed in a very short span of time and
explains that she thinks the reason
nezuko hasn't been able to regain her
consciousness is because she has been
prioritizing something else she says
that she thinks neziko will soon be able
to conquer the sun
it then jumps back to nezuko and tanjuro
tangilo shakes nezuko and cries tears of
happiness as he asks sinesiko if she has
become human again but her only response
is a misarray of happy words tangita
realizes that even though she is
standing in the sun she still has fangs
in the eyes of a demon tanjuro is in
disbelief that she is fine and hugs
nezuko while he cries with joy niziko
pats his head and smiles as kenya
watches the display and smiles too
changido soon passes out due to
exhaustion and in the distance matsuri
screams as she loses her strength just
as the body of hantengu she was fighting
disintegrates to dust
in another place a maid and a child's
mother walking on muzan disguised as a
child cackling and glee before cutting
the head off the child's mother the maid
stares at muzan and horror as he talks
about how there is no more need for the
blue spider lily when all he needs to do
now is find niziko and devour her then
he can finally conquer the sun we then
go into another flashback where we find
out why muzan wanted this blue spider
lily so much there was once a generous
doctor that had turned muzan into a
demon to try and save him muzan had been
angered that he would not live longer
than 20 due to his worsening sickness
even though he had suffered so much just
to only live a little bit longer because
of this he killed the doctor out of rage
but after killing him he realized that
the medicine the doctor had given him
had made him stronger he had obtained a
strong body but could no longer walk in
the sun angered by this he tried to make
the medicine but he didn't have the blue
spider lily that had been used to make
it he searched and searched and searched
for the blue spider loli flower but he
never found anything the only person who
knew how to make it was the doctor who
he had killed muzan had wanted the
perfect immortal body and now that
niziko had conquered the sun all of the
battles will be centered around her and
they will be ever the more dangerous
than before back in the main group
mature thanks tanjido for helping him
get something important back just before
kanroji crashes into all of them hugging
the entire group exclaiming that they
had finally won
so after niziko's sudden change and the
end of the battle between the two demons
we find that there have been plans to
move the swordsmith village due to the
battle these planes will set into action
right away as come nightfall the demons
will undoubtably attack once again we
also find out that even though two upper
ranked demons had attacked the village
its damages in general had been kept to
a minimum because of the work that the
slayers had put in
back at the hideout tanjulo chats with
goto the kakushi at the butterfly
mansion after waking up from resting for
seven days straight after the fight goto
tells tanjido that these swordsmiths
have several empty villagers that have
been prepared in case of emergencies
like this after chatting some more goto
says that he wanted to especially ask
tanchito something
which was that he'd heard something
incredible happen to niziko nonchalantly
tanjuli replies that she is now walking
around in the sun commenting on the
complete absurdity of the situation
while he continues to stuff his face
then without thinking tangier slips up
and tells gotho that tamiyo is looking
into why and how nezuko has conquered
the sun because goto doesn't know who
tamiya is he questions him on this
causing tanchiro to choke on his food
distracting goto from the topic as goto
jokes about how everything will be
peaceful until zenitsu shows up it
suddenly cuts to the yellow-haired
maniac arriving at the butterfly mansion
after a mission and finding out that
nezuko can now walk in the sun and speak
sinister screams out loud and says that
he's having a heart attack and grabbing
niziko before screaming more about how
cute and absolutely amazingly wonderful
and marvelous it is that nizika was able
to be out in the sun he screams at her
to please marry him then she utters the
words welcome back inosuke zenesu's mood
immediately changes as he says that he
is going to burn inosuke alive and then
quickly explains that enosuke had
visited the butterfly mansion a few days
ago and made it his mission to make sure
that nezuko could say his name later
that same day an emergency pillar
meeting was held at the ube yoshiki
estate sunimi aguro muchuro matsuri
gyomei shinobu and giu are all present
after the hashera greet each other a
main ubishiki kagai's wife makes her
appearance in place of her husband as
his illness has left him completely
beard-ridden and unable to move the
stonehishiro gyoume immediately bows to
the ground after he hears this
information and says that he prays from
the bottom of his heart for his master's
life to continue to burn even if it was
for only one more day
once the meeting begins amen brings up
the information about a certain demon
who has managed to conquer the sun
obviously referring to the stunning
mexico she says that because of this
they will soon find themselves in a
full-scale war
after a while she brings up these
strange marks that appeared on matsuri
and muchiro that day anime explains what
they are these are marks that many of
the first swordsmen who were only one
step away from beating muzan head they
had all manifested marks similar to
demonic patterns this information had
been hidden due to the fact that many
people brooded over not actually having
the marks over time the information had
become unclear but one thing that was
passed on indefinitely was that whoever
had the mark would start spreading it to
others who fit the qualifications a main
thing says that the first person to
manifest the mark did not have the rank
of a sharer instead the first person to
gain this mark in generations was no one
other than tanjudo though when they
asked him how he felt when he had got
the mark he had absolutely no idea so
they decided to not pursue him for it
but now that two more people have gained
the mark main asks them to teach the
rest of them how it was done
sadly kenroji had a hard time putting
into words and only embarrasses herself
when all she can do is come up with
vague descriptions that are mostly made
up of noises about how it felt but
maturo does have some kind of idea about
what could possibly cause the mark to
appear on anyone
muchiro explains that during his fight
he got poisoned so he used breathing to
slow his blood circulation then a boy
who tried to help him almost got killed
and he began to remember his past
memories he became so consumed by his
anger that he lost complete control of
his emotions he says that he thinks his
heart rate exceeded 200 beats per minute
and his body temperature went over 39
degrees celsius mature continues saying
that those who do not have the mark
appear even though they do have the
qualifications do not get the mark
because they will die but those whose
bodies can withstand the extreme
circumstances will having mark appear
and enhance their ability to fight
confused about the specificities amane
asks what made him think that his
temperature was 39 degrees in which
maturity says that when he was 9 shinobi
was treating his wounds he was reported
to have a fever at 39 degrees and he
says that he felt the exact same way
when the mark appeared after everyone
reacts to how they will try to gain the
mark amane says that there is one thing
she must tell everyone regarding
manifesting the mark she states for
those who have already manifested the
mark it is too late those who do not
manifest the mark without any exception
will all
amine then leaves as the pillars are
about to have a discussion about
training tomioka stands up and claims
that there is no need or reason that he
has to stay any longer this then leaves
the other pillars confused as to why he
doesn't think he needs to be there but
his only explanation is that he is
different from them completely
aggravated by this shinozugawa says that
he does not buy that and asks tomioka if
he looks down on the other hasheras
tomoyoku doesn't explain himself or what
he means which causes zanimi to strike
at him but as this happens the stone
pillar and complete beast kyomei says
that they should all sit down and
continue talking as he has a proposal it
then cuts to hagen izuka who has arrived
at the butterfly mansion to deliver
tanjido his reforged sword while he
struggles for air sweat pours off the
mask of the swordsman suddenly
haganezuka whips out tanjido's new sword
which has ring goku's health firmly
attached then gives it to him and at the
request of goto he sits down before
urging tanjido to unsheath the blade
tanger was left in complete awe by the
beauty of the blade and haginezuka says
that it is made from high quality steel
and must have been used previously by a
very strong swordsman the blade has the
character for slay pronounced mitsu
which can also mean destruction in the
japanese language haganezuka also
explains that this blade was probably
made before the demon hierarchy was ever
established and this was why many of the
hashera have the kanji pronounced aki
misatsu engraved on their blades which
means destroy all evil demons in the
japanese language tanjido then says that
he did not remember seeing those words
on these swords when he had used it
quickly hakanesuka is set into an angry
monologue on how tangiero has put
irremovable damage on the blade because
he had used it while it was still in the
early stages of sharpening the blade he
then leaves after tangier promises him
to bring him dumplings until the day he
dies over here in the commotion an
annoyed ginyu then complains about how
noisy tangido and his guests were
tanjito apologizes and goes on to say
that he is done but he doesn't get to
finish because inosuke enters the room
by breaking through the window
completely destroying it in the process
the shirtless ball boy then relentlessly
begins screaming out loud that it is
here group strength training starts now
as a large group of demon slayers are
seen heavily sweating they run down and
through a mountain pass it is explained
through zenitsu that the special
training known as hashira training had
begun this training was to ensure that
those who are ranked lower than the
hashera get to actually train with each
individual pillar in a different order
to strengthen the demon slayers this is
actually a special exercise because
generally hashera would only train with
their successors but since nezuko's
sudden change the demon's appearances
have completely stopped leaving heshira
to do their security details by night
and focus on training the demon slayers
during the day
after hearing all this information
tangier happily remarks that it is
amazing but zenitsu instantly cuts him
off and tells him that it is not amazing
at all and instead it is awful it is
complete hell tanjuro retorts though
saying that sparring with someone who is
stronger than you is the best way to
quickly improve and that when you face
them you can absorb wisdom through the
fight to also get stronger yourself
hearing this zenitsu strikes out and
bites down on tangero's head screaming
at him and telling him that they are no
longer friends as of right now then goes
to leave tanjuro tries to stop him and
eventually zanetsu turns around to hear
tanjudo tell him that during his fight
with the upper rank he had used the
trick that he had taught him for thunder
breathing he tries to use this to get
sunitsu to realize that this is how
connections with other people help you
get through tight spots so everything he
learns during this hashira training will
eventually pay off for him in the future
again instantly zinetsu's mood
completely shifts from upset to an
overjoyed who tries telling
chanjito that this doesn't change his
mood at all while he sprints out of the
room a random crow comes flying into the
room through a window and hits tangido
directly in the forehead he then gives
tanjido a letter as it skips away from
the mysterious lesser we find ourselves
with the flashiest lord our retired god
the big man tengan uzoi tengan screams
at the younger slayers who are training
under him for being late and says that
they are barely even able to run
screaming at them to stop licking the
ground while he smashes down on them
with his bokuto it then reveals to us
the positioning ichishira has taken and
training the younger slayers with tengen
and his grueling basic fitness workouts
being the first trial followed by
lessons by matsuri in flexibility and
tokito and high speed movement then
comes swordsmanship with a serpent
heshera and lessons in making infinite
strikes with the wind finally finishing
with the ultimate strength training
session with the stoneheshira gyome with
this constant sparring going on for
hours at end it should further improve
the heishira's overall strength and if
this somehow grants the right conditions
for manifesting their mark that would
also be perfectly ideal as for people
who have already manifested the mark
they just need to maintain their
condition hopefully with all that has
been learned among every member it will
also raise the overall strength of the
actual core itself in preparation for
the up-and-coming battle as it flashes
away from the explanation we find
tomioka sitting alone
suddenly tangido shows up and without
any hesitation makes his entrance into
giu's house leaving tomioka completely
stunned at the random scenario after
tanjudo explains the training session to
the water shearer he tells him that in
seven days he will be able to return to
active duty and would like for tomioka
to train him in which he denies tomioka
explains that he is not angry but more
that he was supposed to become the new
water heshira tanjunu apologizes saying
that he spoke to urokidaki about
breathing styles and how it isn't
unusual that sometimes you can change
your breathing style and give birth to a
new one he states that the water
breathing techniques especially are
close to the basics so they help give
rise to many new styles baking tells
tanjiro to not say that because there is
currently no water hishera so someone
must fill that role as soon as possible
confused tanju asks him about this to
which he is told that geyu tomioka is
not the water heshira
as tanjiro sits there stunned he thinks
back to the letter he received earlier
this letter was from kagaya yubishiki
and he specifically had asked tanjido to
go and talk to giyu as he doesn't think
he can do so in his current state gagaya
tells him that this is an incredibly
important time where everyone must come
together becky you goes at things alone
as he remembers the master's words he
reiterates the thought that he will be
persistent and continuously talk to gee
you he constantly hung around him and
talked nonstop to the point that geyu
was left completely complexed wondering
if this would go on for the rest of his
life after a painful four days geru
eventually gave in and revealed that he
hadn't passed the final selection exam
he you explained that a boy like him
named sabito had taken the final
selection at the same time as him cebito
had killed all of the demons almost
completely alone and yet somehow ended
up failing where in a complete contrast
giyu had been injured by the first demon
and fallen into a daze the next thing he
knew was that the exam was over and that
he had somehow survived giu tells
tanjiro that he thinks he isn't worthy
of becoming a hashera because of this he
doesn't even feel like he should stand
near his other pillars as he feels like
he doesn't really deserve a place in the
demon slayer core as he begins to walk
away from tangido he states that he will
not manifest the mark although sabito
may have so don't bother him anymore as
it is a complete waste of time tanjo
thinks to himself about guillot's
feelings and how he bet that he wishes
that he'd died in sabito's place
he realizes he understands that feeling
so well that it hurts noting that when
someone is so important to you that you
wish you could die in their place it
feels like you're being ripped apart
from the inside he begins to remember
about sabito and makomo who had trained
him even though they were supposedly
dead as he compares himself to sabito
tanjudo admires him for being able to
protect and save everyone else at the
final selection while tanjuro himself
could not and he remarks that sibiso
would have become a formidable swordsman
had he survived which is obviously
another reason that may geru feel like
he'd be better off dead instead tangido
understanding his emotions remembers
kyojiro who had also lost his life to
protect him in his mind tangible too
believes that the flame hashera could
have become someone capable enough to
defeat mouzad and that he wishes he
could have died in his place
pondering on what to tell giu he
eventually decides to ask giu a question
regarding whether or not he wants to
exploit what sabato entrusted to him
which leaves the supposed water hashera
completely stunned by tanjuro's question
the important memories of his past
suddenly began to come flooding back
into giu's mind the supposed woody
hashira recalls his past with sabito
slapping him and telling him to never
say that he'd wished he died sebiso went
on and insisted that giu had to live to
protect others so not to disrespect his
sister who had lost her life from
protecting him from a demon back in the
present in his mind he you apologizes to
both sibiso and his sister for being so
immature and forgetting this basic
morale as tanto stands there observing a
silent gilu he believes he could have
made a mistake for asking the question
and comes up with the idea of having an
eating contest which may solve the issue
after finally deciding to train with
tangido giu turns around and before his
words could reach him tanjido suggests
that the two have an eating contest and
much to his initial confusion the water
hashera ends up accepting elsewhere the
insecticida shinobu can be seen running
through the corridors of the butterfly
mansion as she sits down in front of an
altar she tells herself to calm down as
only the immature can't handle their
emotions leaving her pondering the idea
that she's probably immature as she
slumps saddened at the overall situation
aoi welcomes her back to her room
announcing herself at the same time
before asking her if it was possible to
train with a stonehishera chinobu tells
her that she can't help it with training
this time to the confusion of aoi when
she is told to come closer she tells
shinobu that she would like to train
with her some more which brings up the
overall mood of shinobu who tells kanua
that she has gotten much better at
speaking her mind still confused aoi
asks if this wasn't the right time but
to her visible surprise shinobi retorts
telling her that it is now time to talk
about how to kill the demon who killed
her sister kane
far away a crow cause as it flies
through the night and makes its entrance
into the top room of tomio's household
warning her that it is dangerous to
leave her windows open at night
the crow then introduces himself as
kagaya yubishiki's messenger and tells
tamio that she was extremely good at
hiding herself so good in fact that the
crow's master had lost the ability to
completely move during the time it had
taken to find her after some more
conferring between the two the crow
begins telling tamio about their plan
which is that they would like for her to
come to the ube yoshiki mansion to help
study niziko and finally help defeat the
one and only muzan kibitsuji as tamio's
heart races her thoughts also race
through her head as she ponders how even
though she's a demon they have asked for
her to come to the main hideout to help
having recovered from his battle against
hantengu tangelo joined the joint
training effort he is greeted by tengen
and his wives whose training he
completes in just 10 days he then
travels to muchiro's residence who
complimented him on having even faster
swords play and who also sought to
increase his stamina via helping his
muscles ease and tense up more smoothly
having accomplished this muchero
cheerfully allowed tanjiro to move on to
the next teshira training despite its
only having been five days the next
dayshira to train tangido was matsuri
who exchanged some pleasantries with the
youth before they got down to the task
at hand and the love hoshira's training
they mendeus up in a mena reminiscent of
ballerinas and dance constantly at the
same time she helps them improve their
flexibility with their own strength this
led to the next place of tanjuno's
training with the serpent hashera obanai
after an unpleasant greeting from his
superior tanger was thrust into his
variation of the ordeal with room being
covered and bound swordsmen on the floor
and walls expected to deliver blows to
obani while avoiding striking these
unfortunate souls during the training
between the two tangier was struck by
his teacher whose blows were able to
weave like a snake between the tied up
individuals despite these hardships
which included being able to hear the
terrified victims begged not to be hit
tangier eventually began to counter and
avoid overnight strikes after four days
of hard work after striking off the
heyori the hashera was wearing he was
permitted to go onto the next section of
the training with the windhishera sunimi
shinozugawa on his way there he
encounters a visibly terrified zinetsu
who had fled from the intense and brutal
tutelage however as he screams for
tanchiro to help him escape sanemi
catches up with him grabbing his head
and threatening him to return him to the
facility before ultimately knocking him
out sanemi then forces tanjido to carry
his unconscious friend while running
behind the hashera the two exchange
harsh words with each other affirming
their hatred that they have towards each
other after the training ended it was
revealed that shinozugawa's training was
so grueling that he understood wazinitsu
had become so rabid he goes on to say
that it was just a simple striking
exercise where he would attack sunimi
each session continued without rest
until he ended up vomiting blood and
eventually passing out once he awoke
xenitsu cursed him and tanjura realized
that shinozugawa was overly tough on
tangio to the point that if he lost
concentration for a moment he would have
gotten seriously injured still
incredibly beat up from all of this
training while walking back to his room
tangido then witnessed sanimi and his
little brother it was obvious genya was
trying his hardest to talk with his
brother but despite this kenya gets
threatened by the hashera who insisted
that he had no brother and if he didn't
knock this off then he would kill him
leaving kenya standing there saddened
and completely speechless as tanjudo
listens in on the attention-filled
confrontation between the shinozugawa
brothers sunimi straightforwardly
disowns genya as his brother distraught
by this denial and his brother's lack of
empathy ginyu further tries to apologize
for his wrongdoing while being secretly
encouraged by tanjido who was
eavesdropping and reveals his
desperation to where he acquired the
ability to fight by eating demons
tsunami stops in his tracks and peers
back menacingly at genya questioning his
words about eating demons he vanishes
within the moment causing tanjiro to
make a break towards kenya to tackle him
to the ground safely protecting him from
having his eyes gouged out by sunimi the
two boys crashed through the sliding
door into the outside garden scaring
zinetsu along with the other demon
slayers tangero questioned sunimi for
trying to kill his brother but the
latter corrected him stating that he
will only beat kenya until he has no
longer the ability to regenerate
resulting in his retirement from the
demon slayers in disbelief tangero
defended kenya stating that he was
instrumental in defeating the upper rank
during their last encounter and declared
that he will protect him from his
brother who disowned him sunimi then
turned to attack tanjuro but angelo was
able to block his punch and counter
attack once the brawl between tangier
and tsunimi started tanjunu quickly
requests to zunitsu to take genya away
with him doing so straight away but as
the netsu takes kenya away he insults
his brother which results in kenya
smacking zinetsu over their head
everything turned into a mess from that
point onwards and the chaos continued
all the way until the late evening
tangido got an official scolding from
the higher-ups and his training with the
windhashera not only came to a halt but
he was also banned from ever approaching
him in the end tanjaro was unable to
help mediate and repair the
shinozugawa's brother's relationship as
the bruised tanjido and zanitsu make
their way to the stone hashira's
training ground they find inosuke and
the other demon slayers training under a
waterfall and are greeted by the stone
heshira who was close by meditating in a
hellish way this ended up resulting with
zinitsu screaming out as he sees that
the hashera was standing barefoot and a
pet of fire guillaume begins explaining
the importance of his training as
stabilizing one's body with strong limbs
will lead to accurate attacks and an
industrious defense his training module
included three simple things first
training by having the waterfall beat
down on you second carry three logs on
your shoulders and finally push a
massive boulder over one show which if
in a normal measurement would usually be
around 0.1 meters as one square meter is
approximately 100.83
cho despite the training seeming easy it
was actually horrendous and constantly
zinetsu kept on complaining about the
freezing waterfall even inosuke who was
working hard ended up drowning after
reviving his friend tangero also trained
under the waterfall and realized that
the chants taught by kyomei were for
focusing and informing the others that
he is still conscious while eating
grilled fish together with the other
demon slayers inosuke asserted that the
rock hashera is the strongest in their
organization
tangero supported this as he also
noticed that kyomei is the only one with
a different scent of smell zenitsu on
the other hand was still in disbelief
that kyomei was able to move the boulder
easily but was dumbfounded when he saw
the hashera pushing an even bigger rock
eventually tanjuro and his friends were
able to complete the waterfall and log
carrying training but they were still
unable to push the boulder in any kind
of way guillermo's training was hard but
it wasn't completely compulsory if you
wanted to quit you could always go down
the mountain and give up six more days
passed and tanjido was still unable to
move his boulder and despite all his
training the mark still didn't show up
while tanjo was contemplating about the
current situation genya suddenly
appeared and asked about tanjido's scar
noting that it is getting bigger he then
told tanjiro what happened to him after
the scuffle with his brother he got
himself scolded by gyome and he was told
to never go near sunimi again apparently
genya was also on the rock training and
compared to tanjo he was able to move
his boulder which led him to question
the latter if he knew about repeating
actions he then explained that kyomei
sucks at teaching so one must watch him
closely in order to not fail at passing
his training kenya goes on to explain
that gyome was actually doing a
predetermined set of movements in order
to maximize his concentration guru may
can be seen eavesdropping while the two
continue talking about repeating actions
elsewhere the demon eyeballs are quietly
stalking a lone demon slayer as he walks
through the streets the eyes turn out to
be nakimese who were spying on the
whereabouts of the demon slayers while
she and muzan stay hidden inside the
infinity castle she states that she has
determined the location of about 60 of
all of the demon slayers but she has
still absolutely no idea about the
location of the girl who conquered the
sun she reports her findings to muzan
who praises her growth and quietly
states that he will soon find both
nizuko and ubiyashiki
according to what genya taught tangido
repetitive action is a technique that
opens all five senses kenya may not be
able to use breaths but he can achieve
total concentration another way which is
through these repetitive actions when
gyome and genya use it they remember
their anger and painful memories that
makes their heart rate and temperature
go up the signs were pointing to the
possibility that this might be the same
as tangiero's mark coming out but gyome
and genya had no marks so they cocked
their heads in confusion by doing these
repetitive actions you can focus on any
given movement and tanjudo thought how
it would be nice if he could learn how
to maintain his darkened mark forever
his repetitive actions were remembering
all of the faces of his loved ones then
recalling ringoku's words keep your
heart burning and with that he was able
to raise his focus to its maximum limits
tangero couldn't do it at the very
beginning but he was able to use all the
strength that he had by doing these
repetitive actions as he did them again
and again his body began to remember the
way to bring out that power through this
specific set of actions eventually he
was able to push the boulder slowly but
surely surprised by tajiro's sudden
growth inosuke immediately jumps into
action and by thinking about the rock as
tempura he was able to push it some
distance ezinetsu looks in dismay at
howie is the only one remaining to move
the boulder suddenly a sparrow appears
next to him chirping and holding a
letter tangential was able to move his
boulder across one cho finishing the
rock he share his training but was left
completely dehydrated by this task as he
writhes in pain on the ground giumei
walks up and pours water over tanjido he
then accepts him as a swordsman
recalling tanjiru's actions from the
swordsmith village when he prioritized
the villagers over his younger sister's
life during the crisis tanjido however
did not accept this praise as nezuko was
the one who had made that decision and
not him upon hearing this guy may noted
how different tanjuro is as to him
children are pure and naive weak quick
to lie completely fine with cruelty and
selfish little things gyome then begins
to tell tanjudo his story about how he
raised some kids who had no family in a
temple before he became a demon slayer
their affirmative and having no blood
connections helped them bond together
very well and he raised them like his
own family gyomi wanted to keep life
that way forever but then one night a
kid disobeyed the temple's rules and
didn't come back after sunset and sadly
ran into a demon in order to save his
own skin the boy told the demon the
location and the number of people inside
the temple he also so that the demon
made it past the temple's defenses put
out all of the wisteria and sense that
gyome had burning as protection and
invited the demon inside the temple
which resulted in four kids dying
immediately as they got sliced in half
yami tried to protect the other four but
they did not listen to him so they tried
to run and sadly died only sayo the
youngest listened to him and hid behind
him in order to protect sayo gyomo
fought and punched the demon's head
again and again until the sun came up he
was able to protect sayo but when people
came to help saya was only four years
old at that time and got confused and
labelled gourmet as a murderer and a
monster who had killed all of the
children as a result guillerme was
imprisoned and charged with murder if
kagaya had not intervened he would have
been executed and ever since he had come
to harbor deep doubts and suspicions
that no matter how virtuous you are once
you get pushed into a corner your true
nature will come out but angelo never
ran he always stayed honest and never
lied seeing that tanjaro indeed as a
special child kyomay promised him to
help so that tanjido would not make a
wrong turn in his life after this he
then told tanjido that he had officially
finished his training with the
stonehishera later on while eating
together ginyu recalls to tanjuro how
gyome made him his disciple despite the
fact that he doesn't have the talent to
be an apprentice and guessed that he was
actually eating demons as a way to get
stronger guillermo introduced genya to
shinobu for her to check up honest
conditions but every time he sees her
she puts on a disgusted face and scolds
kenya tanjuro however comments that
shinobu was just worried about ginya's
body and invited him to go see geyu
together to talk about his brother once
they are done eating virginia declines
as he is still not finished with the
rock his share is training saying that
he was still yet to move the boulder one
cho
while on his way to geyu tanjiro saw
zanitsu on top of his boulder and asked
if he will be okay since they have not
talked for a while which worried him
zenith who tells tanjido that he has
simply achieved clarity about what he
should do
what he must do tanjiru tries to pull
more information out of zenitsu but all
he manages to get was that he must do
what he must do
still before leaving zunitsu ends up
slightly caving in and thanks him
telling tanjido that he is truly a nice
guy
but standing there with the most
determined look of his life he
reiterates that there is something that
he absolutely must do
tangier then visits giu's place and upon
his arrival he saw geru and sunimi fight
him with wooden swords on hand their
movements are so fast but he notes that
he can follow their movements the battle
ended with both geyu and tsunimi's
swords broken after a clash of breathing
techniques and tsunami suggested that
they continued their fight with their
firsts suddenly target oh then
interrupted them and suggested that they
just share some ohagi which pissed off
sunimi even more given that him and
tangeno are not supposed to get near
each other after the group awkwardly
have somewhat of a passive aggressive
conversation tsunami storms off after
and giu notes that every heshera also
takes part in each other's training he
also plans to sneak some ohagi and sweet
bag to give to sunimi in order to try
and get along with him whilst anime is
walking angrily away from giu's place he
notices something following him nearby
and the foliage and instantly snatches
it from the ground then proceeds to
crush it in his fingers as it falls from
his hand it confused sunimi wonders what
it could possibly be
elsewhere at the exact same time the
meeting of generations is about to take
place
under the starry moonlit night kagaya
yubishiki welcomes muzan kibijutsu to
his household as their first ever
meeting commences
as the demon muzan slowly closes in on
the bed-ridden ubishiki he tells him
that he looks in an unsightly condition
before
muzan kibitsuji a demon the yubiyashiki
family and the demon slayers had been
chasing for a thousand years has finally
come kagaya who is now completely unable
to see because of his illnesses asks his
wife amen for his descriptions
muzan on the other hand mocked him as he
who they have been chasing showed no
signs of aging while kagaya on the other
hand is already smelling like a corpse
it was then revealed that muzan and
kagaya are actually from the same family
which led to the ubishiki family being
cursed where every child born will be
weak and die right away in order for
their family to not die out the ubishiki
family dedicated themselves in defeating
and have received wives from their
priests for generations which made them
resilient but nobody in their family was
able to live beyond the age of 30 years
old upon hearing this muzan ridiculed
him as even with all their efforts and
even with the thousands of people killed
by muzan he has never been punished
kagai however questions him about his
dreams which make muzan uncomfortable
who also notes that there are only four
humans presence in the mansion kagaya
his wife and two children who are
currently playing nearby muzan's dream
is to be indestructible and it will come
true once he gets his hands on nezuko
but kagai was able to turn the ridicule
on muzan and his dream stating that it
will not come true he continues
recalling how the demon hunters still
exist and have existed and never died
out for over a thousand years kagaya
tells muzan that he is going to prove to
him that human thoughts are
indestructible and the thought of never
forgiving those who have taken the lives
of people's loved ones away senselessly
is eternal telling him that not once has
he ever been forgiven over the past 1000
years he always proceeded to step on the
tiger's tail constantly finally now
incurring the wrath of the dragon he has
just awoken further noting that even if
he dies the hunters will not feel any
pain as they do not need him that much
the connection to human thought is
something that demons cannot understand
because they will cease to exist once
muzan dies upon hearing this muzan
becomes enraged and appearing in front
of kagaya he demands him to be quiet in
which kagaya retorts instead thanking
him
as muzan goes to grab pagaya it flashes
away to a nearby crow rocketing through
the forest and informing the hasheras
along with the demon hunters of the
attack on the ubyashiki estate
in a previous hashera meeting tsunemi
draws attention to the problem of kagaya
being unguarded but leaving two hashers
and the least need to be protecting him
he and the others ask yom if something
can be done to change this problem gyome
having known kagaya the longest only
responds that he had been asking the
same question for eight years and kakaya
had always denied his protection he
insisted someone like the hashera
shouldn't be wasted on someone like
himself worrying them shinobu adds that
she heard the ubishikis had never had a
bodyguard of sorts throughout their
history
back in the action salimi hurries
through the forest towards the ubishiki
estate as he catches sight of the
mansion a massive explosion destroys the
mountainside to sunimi's sheer horror
the explosion is noticed by the rest of
the hashera horrifying them all tangido
realizes this sense of blood and burning
flesh is in the air
muzan caught directly by the explosion
tries to regenerate and curses kagaya in
his final moments kagaya had the smile
of a buddha before killing himself
alongside his wives and two daughters
the demon lord never believed he was
capable of such commitment towards
killing him and underestimated him
adding he knew kagai had planned
something but nothing at this scale
hypnosis as kagaya even added spikes to
the explosions to delay his regeneration
even further muzan senses that kagaya
has something else planned knowing
people and most likely her sharers must
be close by he thinks back to the
oyukatsu's final moments he had hid all
his anger and bloodlust without muzan
even noticing something he begrudgingly
commends him for as muzan tries to put
his mind towards regenerating quicker
flesh seeds appear around him without
warning they burst into gigantic black
branches he realizes that there must be
some sort of blood demon r but is
completely immobilized the spikes don't
harm him however and muzan believes he
can simply absorb them to escape out of
nowhere though tamiya appears and stabs
her hand through muzan's stomach muzan
is angered at her sudden appearance and
asks her reason
tamiu mentions the flesh seeds belong to
the man in asakusa he turned into a
demon he realizes she must have hidden
herself with another blood demon art
using yushira's talismans she tells
muzan the drug in her first absorbed by
him turns demons back into humans though
muzan claims that it's impossible but
she states it became possible with
someone's help muzan curses her
stubbornness and makes the claim that
her hatred of him is unjust he reminds
her that she alone was responsible for
the death of her family she carefully
responds all she wanted was to survive
her disease and see her children grow up
but the demon lord mentions she had
eaten other people after that and states
she had fun doing so tamiyo doesn't deny
that fact and states that in order to
atone for those deaths she and muzan
will die together tamiya calls out to
gyome the first to arrive at the scene
and with a single swing of his spiked
flail he decapitates mu's arm
at the young age of just 23 kagaya
ubishiki is confirmed to be dead
before his death he spent every day
visiting the graves of fallen demon
slayers till his affliction finally
prevented him from doing so gyome
recalls the first time he met kagaya
when oyakata was 14 and he himself was
only 18. immediately kagai knew that
gyome had protected the children he was
accused of killing germain remembers
even back then kagai spoke in a way that
people wanted to hear and his solemnness
remained till his last moments during
the last time he personally spoke with
the stoneheshera kagaya predicts that
muzan kibitsuji will come within five
days instructing kyomei to decapitate
him as kagaya acts as the decoy himself
it is then revealed that the ubyshiki's
family's way with foresight and instinct
was unmatched using their power to
protect themselves from disasters kagai
knows the other hasheras would not
accept his decision of self-sacrifice
and asks the hashera he is known for the
longest to carry out his wish gyomi
manages to successfully behead muzan
assisted by tamiyo keeping the demon
still as kagaya had predicted muzan
regenerates his head completely
unsurprising to gyome he recalls his
late leader's words that sunlight is the
only way to kill the demon lord and he
resolves to keep him restrained till
dawn
muzan attempts to ensnare the hashera
with blood demon art black blood
brambles but the attack is only
deflected by gyome stone breathing third
form stone skin
sunimi arrives and angrily asks what has
become of kagaya the rest of the hashera
then arrive asking each other about
their leaders states yerumi announces
that they are now facing muzan himself
to the shock of all the hashera as none
of them have ever directly encountered
him tanjido the only one present who has
personally faced him angrily calls out
to him all of the remaining heshira use
their respective breath techniques in
order to cut muzan down as they converge
on the demon muzan laughs to himself
giant doors suddenly appear and slide
open under the demon slayers causing
them all to plummet into the infinity
castle and he declares that he will kill
them all tonight tangier responds back
though that the only one who is going to
die will be muzan muzan answers his
challenge telling him to do it if he can
as tanjuro falls he is caught by geyu
and thrown onto a nearby platform to
safety the two are suddenly attacked by
numerous demons but quickly kill them
all using the water-breathing sixth form
whirlpool and breathing third form
flowing dance respectively tanjulo
comments on how amazing gee you is
internally noting how he can accurately
predict the type of form he would use
through slight movements all the while
staying unnerved the two then head out
further into the castle obernau rescues
mitsuri from several demons using
serpent breathing fifth form slithering
serpent much to her exuberant gratitude
gyome and muchiro rush throughout the
castle slaughtering demons they note all
the demons they encounter are roughly
the strength of a lower moon suggesting
muzan intends to wear them down the two
lament the loss of kagaya yubi ashiki
mature remembers the time he was near
death from attacks and kagai encouraging
him to continue kagai did so with all of
the injured demon slayers in a fatherly
manner maturo seethes with rage that
muzan had killed his twin and his second
father in hopes to bring him to hell
something the normally calm kyome
furiously hopes to do also
sunimi laments his inability to protect
kagaya when demons appear before him he
rapidly slaughters them all
inosuke is excited falling into the
infinity castle eager to test his
abilities on numerous demons zenetsu
hears something nearby and believes a
particular someone is close calling them
unforgivable shinobu smells some blood
and decides to open up a nearby door
inside the room are numerous corpses of
woman and a demon standing there
ashinobu remembers kane kocho's death
she is seen crying and kane tells her to
quit the demon slayer court she tells
her to gain the happiness of a normal
girl and to live until she became old
shinobu desperately asks her sister
about the demon that attacked her
stating that she could not live a normal
life like this
sadly the flashback ends with shadowball
recalling that it was a demon that
looked like blood was dumped all over
his head
as she witnesses a demon devour his
victims while surrounded by female
corpse strewn about the demon smiles and
takes off his crown introducing himself
as doma shinobi recalls her sister's
words that the demon would laugh in a
carefree manner and would talk softly
one of doma's victims reaches out
desperately for help only to be told by
doma to be quiet as he was in the middle
of talking however shinobu carries her
away from doma and sweetly asks whether
she is all right to which doma asks
whether she was a hashera due to her
speed just as the victim attempts to
reply to shinobu she is murdered by
doma's attacks doma smiles and tells her
to leave the body there stating that he
will eat it later shinobi remembers what
her sister had stated the demon's
weapons were a pair of sharp fans
the demon then explains that he was the
leader of the eternal paradise faith
claiming that it was his duty to be
happy with himself and his followers but
shinobu tells doma disgustedly that the
girl he had killed was clearly in pain
and begging for help to this he responds
that he had saved the girl claiming that
she no longer feels pain suffering or
fear doma then goes on to say that
everyone fears death which is why he
eats his followers for their sake so
that they can live forever with him
he claims that he takes his followers
hopes blood and flesh to heart and leads
them to a higher salvation but shinobu
angrily spits that he couldn't possibly
be sane and asks whether he is all right
in the head telling him that he makes
her want to vomit doma gives a surprised
expression noting that she's been rather
harsh for their first meeting he then
realizes that shinobi must have been
through something quite difficult
pitying her and suggesting he listens to
what she has to say about it shinobu
angrily clutches her heyori and growls
that doma was the one who had killed her
sister fiercely demanding if he has no
memories of this specific kaiori doma
then recalls kanae as the girl who used
the flower breathing stating his regret
over not being able to eat her before
sunrise shinobu cuts him off the strike
to his eye with her insect breathing
dance of the beasting true flutter doma
compliments that it was so fast he
couldn't prevent it with his hand he
then unleashes his demon art frozen
lotus and shinobu backflips and dodges
however she inhales some of the ice
powder that he had scattered about doma
compliments that she was fast but he
states that she wouldn't be able to kill
a demon with stabs and the slicing of
her neck was the best option to go with
to this she never responds that if a
stab wound didn't kill him poison would
just as the wisteria poison goes into
effect he falls onto the floor and hacks
our blood telling shinobu that this
poison was much stronger than the one
she had used at the mountain saying that
muzin had warned him that she changes
her poisons for every demon she faces
doma quickly breaks down the poison
widely grinning as he apologizes that he
has broken down the poison even though
she had gone to the effort to use it on
him he comments that shinobu's katana
made a distinctive sound whenever she
sheathes her he wonders aloud if that's
how she changes the concentration of the
poison he clasps his hands together and
joyfully exclaims how it was fun and
interesting to get poisoned and how it
may become a sort of habit he asks
shinobu whether she thinks the next
boyzone formulation would work excitedly
asking for her to try it out shinobu
notes though that it was already
speculated beforehand that he would most
likely be able to break the poison down
domicles's past and his childhood born
with rainbow-colored eyes and white hair
he was believed to be special and
connected to god his parents whom he
considered stupid arranged a cult with
him at the head called the eternal
paradise colds worshipers flock to doma
to repent their issues and problems in
life hoping for advice doma however had
no feelings and found it problematic
that adults had seeked wisdom from a
child when they begged him to guide them
to paradise he cried believing paradise
gods and buddhas was all a fairy tale
that never even existed confused why
people wouldn't believe that they're all
just destined to die and rot doma
believed that it was his duty to make
these people happy durma then notices a
fifth slash on his hand and heals
himself of shinobu's poisoning asking
but she is okay now that she has started
to breathe heavily shinobi realizes the
true strength of the upper rank noting
doma's resistance and the inability of
the poisons to work on him doma notes
shinobu's lungs must be destroyed having
taken a blow of his blood demon
technique she realizes the fog of his
frozen blood is hazardous of breathed in
and decided to use multiple blows to
poison him again using her insects
breathing dance of the dragonfly
compound eye hexagon shinobi rushes
forward and stabs doma multiple times
doma states that he believes the insect
hashira might be the fastest one but as
she backs away shinobu bleeds profusely
realizing she herself was also hit in
return doma taunts her mentioning that
she could have easily cut off his head
with her immense speed but can't due to
a small frame as blood falls on her
hands she remembers how small they
actually are remembering that she'd
never grown any taller in her childhood
she laments she could have killed demons
the usual way if she had grown more she
never knows larger hands and legs meant
more muscle and that it was a
distinctive advantage she recalls kane
was able to do so despite only being
slightly taller and also with a dainty
and thin frame she remembers kane's last
moments with her telling her that she
would likely lose to doma kane's spirit
suddenly appears before the injured
shinobu telling her to stand shinobi
believes that she can no longer though
heavily bleeding and with her left lung
shredded by doma's fog she can't breathe
normally as well
kanye declares that irrelevant and
states that she will win with the right
resolve to kill him no matter the
sacrifice noting that she promised to
her and kano remembering their younger
sister she nobody crouches down while
doma approaches her noting the slash he
gave her was only half-hearted but it
must be painful for her kane urges her
younger sister to keep trying causing
her to stand which shocks the upper moon
as she stares at doma shinobi starts to
cough up blood prompting doma to laugh
that the blood in her lungs is causing
her to do so
resolving to end her pain he tells her
to give up saying she is already beyond
saving kenobi takes a stance and using
her insect breathing dance of the
centipede hundred legged zigzag she
speeds towards the upper ranked demon
doma becomes shocked at this feat noting
the destroyed bridge from the impact of
her feat's force derma tries to slash
you back but is just too slow only
managing to hurt her cave shinobu
crouches down and launches into the air
driving her sword through doma's neck
and forcing his body into the ceiling
and one final thrust
shinobi remembers her childhood
believing that happiness was an endless
road throughout life that belief though
was shattered when a demon entered her
home and killed both of her parents
leaving her and kane orphaned they were
saved however by gyome who quickly
defeated the killer shinobi realises
that her happiness was forever destroyed
other people's wound and resolved to
defeat demons and prevent other people
from suffering the same fate as her
shinobu and kane promised to each other
to both become demon slayers to do so
the two believe that despite their weak
strength stopping one demon could save
tens of people and stopping an upper
rank could save hundreds recalling the
time when tangero asked if she was angry
she states that she has been angry for a
long time remembering her parents death
her sisters and those of all of her
successes
she remembers aoi sumi keo and naho and
how their families were killed also most
of all she's incensed that her poison's
inability to hurt doma her sword slips
from doma's neck causing her to fall
doma however uses his ice to catch her
and pull shinobu into a hug the demon
tearfully congratulates her for making
it thus far
while mocking her for being weak and
less talented than kane to her fury doma
acknowledges her foolishness at trying
to kill him despite all of the odds and
calls it the thing that makes humans so
fleeting as he decides she is finally
worthy of being eaten by him doma asks
her for her final words in what shinobu
responds telling him to go to hell kanoa
opens up the door of the cult room and
looks up to see doma clutching shinobu
near the roof as she watches doma breaks
shinobu's body in his arms takana was
horror killing her and causing her sword
to fall from her hand kanawha
desperately leaps upwards to use
flower-breathing fourth form crimson
hanaguromo but misses when doma escapes
and lands onto the floor the demon
advises her not to attack him in the
middle of absorbing someone causing
kanua to seethe with rage doma fails to
taunt her and instead fondly recalls
that shinobu only had a short time with
him due to his abilities and decides
that this night might be really good
having two gorgeous meals at once all
while licking shinobu's hairpin zinetsu
approaches a room and calls for the
being inside to come out
they only respond that zenichu's
beckoning is the improper address to a
senior kaigaku walks out and taunts him
for being as dainty and as seedy as ever
zinetsu responds back however that as a
demon kaigaku is no longer his senior
as tanjiro and geu continue through the
castle the former nearly falls through
an open floor commenting that the
building is seemingly trying to separate
the two while wondering how long tamiya
can withstand muzan and unsure of their
exact location
akasukai crow announces that shinobu
kocho has encountered and was killed by
the upper rank too while tanjuro holds
back tears geru notices that the crow
has a piece of paper on its neck in the
new demon slayers headquarters karaya
ubyashiki has become the new head of the
organization as the only remaining male
doing so at the age of only eight he is
supported by his sisters kunai and
kanata despite the deaths of his parents
and two elder sisters he willingly
hasn't grieved them in order to focus on
the mission kunai and kanata also hold
back their emotions to also aid him
their father with his short life span
was strict racing them quickly into
adults as quickly as he could their
elder sisters hinaka and nichika had
never left their father or mother's side
their mother was also kind but strict in
raising them the three each have one of
ushero's talismans helping them map out
the infinity castle karaya notices the
lacking information they need and
suggests telling the crows to spread as
many eyes as they can kunai decides
muzan hasn't left from his place and
instructs corria into guiding them north
to face him she mentions the only
demonstrator is currently facing upper
moon demons akanua and zenitsu the
letter now facing the new upper rank 6.
zenitsu and kaigaku face off mocking
zenitsu as puny and weak scoffing at his
status as a sharer since he is only able
to do one form
zenitsu retaliates though by mentioning
how happy his former superior seems as
the bottom upper rank leaving kaigaku
stunned at his barbed comment zenitsu
questions him on how he could have
turned into a demon but when kaigaku
tries to answer sinister cuts him off
and continues saying why would someone
pose to acquire thunder breathing become
a demon zenitsu angrily yells that
jigoro had committed seppuku by himself
upon hearing what kaigaku had done and
zanitsu gets angered telling him that
someone was actually meant to assist him
at that act but instead he died in
agonizing death all alone all because a
user of their thunder breathing became a
demon kagaku scoffs at the news and asks
him if he's meant to be sad or repent
unapologetically refusing to care he
declares he will always stick to those
who value him he states he is glad
jigoro died a painful death angered at
all his efforts to please him never led
to him being named his successor and
insults him further by scoffing at his
idea of sharing the successorship with
dirt and calling the former hashera
senile zenitsu furiously tells him that
if he was dead kaigaku was garbage since
he can only use the first breath and
kaigaku never managed to learn it at all
commenting that jigoro only died a
miserable death because he wasn't lucky
enough to have a true successor kagaku
angrily tells anetsu though not to lump
him in with the likes of himself and
unleashes the thunder-breathing fourth
form distant thunder sending lightning
at the demon slayer however zenitsu had
already avoided the attack and slashed
the demon's neck mocking him telling him
that he is too slow and that he was
filth leaving kaikaku stunned wondering
why his opponent seems like a completely
different person
kagaku then remembers his unfortunate
encounter with the upper rank one
kokoshibo
he comments it isn't shameful to kneel
before an overwhelmingly powerful foe
recalling when he quickly surrendered to
the demon he believes as long as he is
alive he can always do something even if
he has to scrape his head on the ground
drink dirty water or steel to survive in
a flashback we said that kokoshibo
offers a portion of muzan's blood from
him if he wants to become more powerful
and if muzan accepts him he can take a
place among the upper ranks kokoshibo
advises him that it takes time to become
a powerful demon as powerful as a strong
swordsman and at that he gives kaigaku a
large amount of blood since he's also a
breath user he tells kaigaku to be
thankful for the blood he has given but
threatens to behead him should he spill
a drop at that time his whole body was
terrified before his transformation but
now facing zanetsu kagaku's fear is a
non-existent
he is assured no matter how powerful he
is sinitu cannot beat an upper rank
declaring everybody has to die
eventually and saying ji guru and
zinetsu are no exception kagaku uses
thunder breathing second form rice
spirit to kill him zenitsu takes notice
of his five simultaneous attacks
deducing he must have eaten numerous
people already he asks the demon if he
knows right from wrong but kagaku
responds that those who accept him are
right and those who don't are wrong as
he uses the thunder breathing third form
thunder swarm he then uses thunder
breathing fifth form hate lightning
hitting zenetsu and burning him as he
asks his former swordsman how he likes
his newfound demon enhanced forms kagaku
follows up with more thunderbreathing
sixth form rumble and flash hitting him
again with numerous slashes
as zanetsu falls after being hit he
removes back to his days training
alongside kaigaku ironically zenitsu
only managed to do the first form kagaku
was able to do all of them but the first
of the thunder breathing techniques
zenetsu knew deep down that kagohoo was
never going to be a hashera one day
sinitsu had hit a senior demon slayer
and kaigaku reprimanded him then mocked
him for doing so he knew kagaku velently
hated him zinitsu himself also hated
kaigaku greatly but despite this he
genuinely respected kaigaku for his work
ethic and drive and despite his place
especially with geoguru's students it
never satisfied him finally he
considered kaigaku's feelings like a box
of happiness in his heart his happiness
always leaked through and he must always
close that box to feel satisfied
apologizing to jigoro and kaigaku
zenitsu lands on the wall and stops his
fall as a confused kaigaku looks on
zinetsu uses his thunder breathing
seventh form honokazuchi nokami and
speeds upward decapitating kaigaku in
that moment as the upper ranked demon
becomes enraged that he never saw it
coming he curses his former master for
teaching zenitsu something he never knew
and playing favourites sinister replies
though that jigoro was never such a
person and that he actually created this
form for the day that he would fight
alongside him
after zinetsu beheads kagaku they both
fall in the infinity castle to their
deaths zinetsu plummets unconsciously as
the disintegrating kaigaku grows furious
from his defeat at zenitsu's hands he
comforts himself with the idea that
zanetsu will die with him when they hit
the floor until yushiro comes to save
zinetsu while coldly reminding kaigaku
that without friends he will end with
nothing since he gave nothing to anyone
finally commenting that dying alone sure
is pathetic esinitsu awakens in a land
full of red spider lilies and sees his
master jigoro across a river that
separates the two sinitsu breaks down in
front of him crying in remorse and
regret for not being able to save
kaigaku and being unable to become a
hashera prior to his death as initsu
struggles with being caught by the
lilies he realizes that jigoro hasn't
said anything to him and shikuro breaks
his silence by calling out zenitsu's
name and with tearful eyes he proclaims
that sinitsu is his pride and joy in
reality zenitsu is being parched up by
yushiro while being guarded by murata
and another demon slayer morata realizes
he remembers zinetsu and calls out
hoping for a survival leading yoshiro to
tell him to shut up esmerata angrily
comments back that he cannot be treated
like this as a demon slayer of rank
yushira responds back as a demon he
ignores them as he patches zenitsu's
eyes and morata shouts at the demon that
they blood from zenitsu's wounds
continues to bleed yushiro tells initsu
he was lucky kaigaku was inexperienced
with his demon powers and that if he had
fought him a year later he would have
ended up dead for sure maratha yells not
to be so negative attracting demons to
their location to the other's dismay
yashira was brought along by tamiyo to
help assist the demon slayers much to
his frustration despite the fact he bore
the demon slayer's uniform to enter no
one even recognized him the others
members knew something was off but the
fact that he was a demon created by
tamiyo went unknown shira grows
frustrated at murata's inability to
behead the attacking demon and places
zenitsu in a safe spot to assist
meanwhile tangido and geru are
continuing to run throughout the castle
he tells shinobu that they will win and
that he is sure of theirs suddenly a
powerful trimmer strikes shaking the
area and worrying the two water
breathers
as tanjuro wonders if it is a fight or
someone's death the trimmer gets closer
and stronger gear tells tangero to stay
back as the source of the trimmer
punches through the ceiling revealing
the source of the noise to be a kaza
akaza tells the demon slayers long time
no see i'm surprised a weakling like you
is still alive tanjudo kamado causing
tanjido to yell his opponent's name back
elsewhere we see that tamiya is trapped
in a flesh cocoon made by muzan slowly
being absorbed in all the while she
desperately pleads for help
while in the process of mapping out the
floor of the infinity castle kunai
begins to envision the recently deceased
members of her family her emotions begin
to overwhelm her and her eyes well up
with tears but her brother karia
reassures her to stay strong in order to
win the battle after the small delay she
recomposes herself and continues to map
out the floor plan sitting outside of
the room are former hashira tengan and
shinjuro standing guard they begin
conversating at how mature and wise
kariah has become despite losing his
father at such a young age shinshudo
mentions how the youth are risking their
lives and how he had decided to follow
his late son kiyojoro and put his life
on the line to protect them elsewhere on
the estate tsukanji is seen caring to an
illness
he reveals that he had given niziko a
medication that would revert her back to
a human be questioned if it was actually
taking any effect the idea of nezuko
returning to a human would ruin muzan's
shame of trying to conquer the sun and
she would be deemed the only demon in
history not to be destroyed by sunlight
sikonji begins to tremble at the idea of
the conflict ending on that night and
being alive to witness it he reminisces
on the day when he first met tanjudo and
how he felt that the beginning of the
end had finally come he quietly begins
to root for tanjuro and niziko begging
them not to lose meanwhile within the
castle tangero has begun to engage ikaza
in a fight whom lunges forward to
forcefully attack first tangier was
narrowly able to escape the blow by
using hinokami kagura firewheel to whip
over a kaza
now behind him tanju wills himself to
slicer kaz's arm off and successfully
manages to do so but is swiftly attacks
when akasa manages to regenerate his arm
to his advantage tanjuno narrowly avoids
his attack by using hinokami kagura fake
rainbow and slices zakazia across the
face in the process akasi regenerates
his cut while he stares stunned at
tanjuro's ability after having witnessed
this small scuffle geyu stands amazed at
tanjido's techniques thinking of how his
ability is equal to that of a heshera's
he recalls the snow day of when they
first met and how all he could do was
beg for his sister's life compared to
how we can now fight without losing his
life or dignity akasi recalls the final
word spoken to him by kyogiro this boy
isn't weak and do not insult him and
acknowledges tanjido's strength and
informs him of his newfound respect for
him akasa then begins initiating his
technique development to fight tanjiro
in a serious manner geyu uses
water-breathing third-form flowing dance
to manoeuvre around a kaza the lesser
recognizing him as the water hashera and
stating it has been 50 years since he
last faced a hashera that uses the water
breathing akasa responds by using
destructive death disorder disrupting
giu's movement and forcing him to use
the water-breathing 11th form dead calm
to negate the attack the upper moon
mentions the last water hashera he faced
never used such a form tangible appears
from behind using henokami kagura raging
sun to slash atakaz's neck only for the
blow to miss and for the demon to appear
behind him instead about to punch
through his neck tanjido nearly gets hit
trying to use the hanukamikageta fake
rainbow to dodge when geyu saves him by
slicing off hikaz's arm using water
breathing second form water wheel
kaza's arm grows back nearly instantly
however and gear quickly attacks again
followed by tanjiro using hinukamikage
flame dance akasa sees him trying to
slice his foot and use his leg type
crouch splitter knocking the demon
slayers tangero tries to parry with his
blade and though he nearly comes out
unscathed akazi's leg catches tanjuro's
nose slightly causing him to bleed
heavily from the sheer force tangero
crouches down to soak up the pain
leading geyu to face akaza alone
akasa compliments his opponent's sword
and asks for his name only to be denied
as giu tells him that he does not have a
name to tell the demon and that he hates
talking so do not bother the demon
happily responds and will continually
ask him until he gives in using leg type
explosive flurry to hit his blade handle
knocking the hashera away through
several walls tanjulo sees the impact
and calls out to giu only for akasa to
appear alongside him excited now that he
knows the opponent's name
the two swing at each other and tangier
uses hinokami kagura burning bones
summer sun and a kaza deploying his
destructive death eight-layered demon
core and retaliation hakaza survives the
clash unscathed while tanjuro is forced
back slamming into the wall akasa
complements his moves and for training
so much in a short period of time he
praises kyogre ringoku for the day of
their battle as tanjuro was a weakling
lying down that night now however he
sees tangero's growth in battle and is
now excited to face him akaza voices his
gratitude akiojoro's death as he
believes he would have never become
stronger than that day also insulting
his belief to remain human tanjiru hears
these words and remembering kyogiro
shinjuro in senjuro he becomes enraged
telling him to stop insulting the former
flame hashera akaze is confused
retorting he is praising the two while
tanjuro only tells him he is insulting
kia judo as well as hating anyone who
faces him the demon claims tanjiru is at
a misunderstanding as he only hates the
weak as he states that the laws of
nature dictate the weak to be eliminated
the demon slayer responds back that the
upper rank himself is the product of his
wrong views as he himself was once weak
as well and had become powerful tangero
yells that they strong protect their
weak then their weak get stronger and
help those weaker than themselves
calling it the true laws of nature he
calls the kaza's beliefs unforgivable
and voices that he will not let him do
as he likes any further facing off
against tanjiro akasa cannot brush aside
this unpleasant feeling he is giving him
he is unsure why he feels angry fighting
him since he believes tanjuro is no
longer weak yet cannot shake the feeling
of his eyes voice and words cutting into
him
at that moment someone grabs the kaza's
shoulder and confirms tanjido's words
starts off weak they get help from
everyone around them but he should only
compare his own progress against himself
not that of others the man tells him
that the only thing important is
becoming stronger than he was yesterday
and soon he can be the one to help
people anger akasi tries to punch behind
him to hit the man but strikes nothing
as a bewildered tangible caesar casa
punched the air suddenly akasa angrily
mutters tanjudo you really are extremely
unpleasant
akazi uses destructive death crushing
type 10 000 leaves flashing willow and
ruptures the ground around him with
tanjuro just barely dodging the attack
as he becomes stunned a kaza's new speed
the demon then quickly engages the demon
slayer from below and uses his
destructive death leg type flying planet
thousand wheels with tanjuno taking the
attack and vomiting as a result he tries
to reason as to how akaza manages to
nearly hit him with every move all his
strikes seem to aim for his vital areas
and his attacks seem to be attracted to
them he thinks back to when the demon
deployed his technique deployment
compass needle but before he can figure
it out tangier dodges to the side to
escape an oncoming kick tanjulo uses the
hanokami kagura solar heat haze but only
manages to cut halfway through ikaz's
neck who manages to heal the cut
instantly however the upper moon is
curious as to how the tip manages to
appear hazy before hitting him asking
the demon slayer how he did it elsewhere
sinjiro prays for his late brother
kyojiro that a major part of the battle
is now active pleading for him to
protect tanjiro and spirits sinchiro
thinks to his written letter to tanjiro
about the conversation between the sun
breathing swordsman and the flame
hashera of that time and how the
swordsman was the first breather user
and had engaged muzan in battle as
senjiro continues to pray for his
brother and that tanjiru will survive it
is revealed that the kazuki crow with
his letter is sitting nearby watching
the battle forcing tanchiro to survive
the battle in order to read it as tanju
attempts to use his hanokamikage to fire
wheel akaza catches the blade in his
hands startled that he will attempt to
break it tanjidu instantly headbutts the
demon but doesn't injure a kaza at all
he attempts to kick him but akaza
continues to grasp the sword suddenly
akaz's hands are sliced off freeing
tanjuro and his sword as gee returns
stating that he's angered at the searing
pain in his back and sarcastically
thanking the upper moon for blasting him
through several walls as geyu and akaza
face each other geyu comments on the
reason he fights he doesn't want to
battle to the best of his ability and he
doesn't like battles whereas opponents
continually swing for fun but now he'd
never face someone who overwhelmed him
with his first clash girl states that
akasa's senses are all finely tuned and
polished his own senses are now switched
on to a state where only the strong
battle as he finally understands here
that the moments of life in a battle
truly test someone's abilities tangero
watches as giyu unlocks his demon slayer
mark he rushes towards and swings the
blade just missing a case's neck akasa
tries to punch his head off but the
hashira ducks down and swings again with
the demon bending back to escape the
strike akasi realizes the mark has
appeared and his speed has now increased
giu uses water breathing fourth form
striking tide and slices through akaz's
forearm the latter however had attacked
as well and had struck the side of
giulio's head tangier watches the battle
commenting how to spike geyu and ikaza
are now virtually as fast as each other
akaza had immediately matched giu's
newfound power he knows and a battle of
stamina humans will lose and despite
this battle taking place the final goal
is to beat muzan tanjura tries to think
how akash's attacks manage to be so
accurate and how he can also predict
attacks he doesn't see immediately
remember in the moments akasa mentioned
battle spirit in the battle with kyojiro
he attempts to define it and recalls the
conversation he had with inosuke anoski
claims that battle spirit feels like a
stinging sensation where the enemy is
aiming for tanjulo believing it to be
the reason he could notice guitar's
attacks anosuke is asked to demonstrate
and he asks tanchiro to look at the part
of his body which he accurately
determines as his right shoulder as
tangier becomes amazed anuska notes that
when someone is looking at him with a
murderous gaze it is easier to determine
when they will attack and his whole body
will sting if that set attack really
wants to kill him however he becomes
angered that someone looking at him
without the attempt to kill becomes
difficult to notice remembering how the
old lady at the wisteria house suddenly
appeared behind him without him able to
notice it
he then reasons that if he battled a
demon without showing the attempt to
kill it would be easy to kill them but
tangier believes it impossible to kill a
demon without showing any kind of intent
despite remembering it as a childish
conversation tangero notes interesting
points within it and tries to use them
with the current battle against the kaza
he believes zakaza does send something
in his opponents and that gives him the
edge in combat but angelo cannot figure
out what it is he tries to think how he
can interfere with the destructive death
compass needle he uses seeing the kaza
open from giu's blow he attempts to use
his hanokamikage flame dance on the
upper moon's exposed neck but akaza
catches the blade without seeing it as
they shock tangero watches helplessly
akasa mocks him for his open flank and
uses his other hand to strike a
tanjulo's stomach but only manages to
cut him slightly at that moment tangero
figures out the entire situation
tundra remembers how his father seemed
like a plant he had never shown any
emotional outburst and was always gentle
maintaining his demeanor till his death
whenever he remembers him he immediately
pictures his soft smile and calming
voice tangent remembers a question he
asked him about what he thinks when he
performs the hanokami kagura even as a
child tanjiru knew that the dance
involved performing all 12 moves from
night till dawn continuously worried
about his frail body tangido asks if he
can be the one to do it next year
tanjuro thanks his son for his concern
but brushes aside his worry stating that
in his later years performing it he
hasn't felt tired he remembers learning
it from his own father but knows that
even though when he was younger and
healthier then doing it exhausted him
greatly he figured out though the forms
had useless moves
what mattered was using the correct
breathing and movements as well as
releasing all your strength through
minimal movement tanjuro states that by
doing this your mind becomes invisible
but to properly do so here to find his
movement and sensations utilize all his
senses and gain complete awareness of
his body he tells his son that by doing
all of this he can learn to remove
unneeded parts of the hinokami kagura
and learn just to do what is necessary
and close off everything else tanjidu
asks how he can do everything else and
his father responds by saying it's like
people closing their eyes to hear better
his body will adapt and their movements
will become natural tanjuro tells him
that when his mind becomes invisible he
will see into the transparent world but
this is the end as his body would have
reached its absolute limit as an amaze
tangero asks if he can do it as well he
is told that he can do so by working
hard and not slacking off an incident
happened 10 days later before tanjuro's
death a bear had come to the mountain
killing and devouring people as the
kamado family sleeps through a blizzard
tanjuro suddenly awakens and gets up
after which he asks his sleepy elder son
to accompany him as tanjoro and tanjiro
wander outside the two encounter the
very beer which is standing over two
meters tall and is already believed to
have killed at least six people a
frightened tangible watches his father
confront the bear with only an axe and
his frail body tanjordo apologizes for
its hunger but warns the creature that
coming any closer will mean facing him
he tells her that if anything tries to
harm his family he will show no mercy
and take its life as the bear roars and
lumbers forward to kill him tanjuro
swings his axe and leaps up decapitating
the beer before it could move a step
forward as its giant head drops to the
ground tanjulo tries to piece together
what had just happened in that instant
tanjura would have to swing twice to get
completely through its neck and with his
sense of smell he realizes tanjuro never
wavered in the slightest he had no
hesitation fear no intent to kill with
his plant-like presence he just simply
killed it tanjiru looks behind and asks
if his son had witnessed what happened a
shaykh in tanchiro confirms he saw what
took place and runs into hager's father
as he tells his son to never forget what
he saw tangero looks back and realized
that this moment was a form of training
his perception he was supposed to learn
to see into the transparent world just
like his father grandfather and great
grandfather before him they would have
had to learn in this way he finally
understands his father's words and
thinks back to when he managed to
suddenly dodged a kaza strike earlier
that seemed like it was about to connect
though it would have surely killed him
he managed to somehow escape her for
just a slight moment when akaza grabbed
his blade and it was poised to swing
tangero had entered that transparent
world seeing a kaza's muscles through
his body as he did to hantengu managing
to close off his other senses to dodge
something completely unavoidable his
body became even faster he apologizes to
anosuke for doubting him and tanjido
steals his resolve that while geu
battles akasa he will use his newfound
power to his best ability and beat the
demon having seen the transparent world
momentarily tangier realises his own
movement and speed had increased greatly
he was able to see how akash's body
reacts in battle and concludes he may be
able to behead him if he removes his
battle spirit completely to avoid his
senses akasa begins to overwhelm geyu
the latter having used all of his water
breathing forms only for akaza to
immediately adapt to all of them and
anticipate what one he was about to use
the upper moon decides to finally kill
him commending the hashera for lasting
this long and battle as tanjiru attempts
to enter the selfless state geyu tries
to strike the demon's head directly
akazu responds though then using the
side of his fist to break guillot's
nature and sword without getting harmed
as gu becomes stunned at having his
sword broken akaza fear wells him before
crouching down and going to punch
through his stomach suddenly akasa's
hands fall off saving gee you from
getting hurt as tanjulo has managed to
enter the selfless state and bypass the
kaza's compass needle giiyu looks on at
tanjido's new appearance and power
akasa's body becomes stricken with the
uncertainty at tanjudo's changed aura so
he deploys his final form technique
development blue silver chaotic
afterglow he giu looks at this new
threat and is uncertain if he can negate
it with his own dead calm tangido
however seen into the transparent world
again is able to detect the attack with
his increased perception and vision
gehu is unable to beat akash's new
technique and is knocked back against
the wall with his dead car being unable
to handle the force the demon commends
him for surviving such a large number of
fatal blows and tells him don't die like
keojiro or tanchiro instead become a
demon geyu however the water hashera
becomes confused wondering how akashi
can state that he killed tanjuro
watanjiro standing directly behind him
realizing maybe he is unable to sense
his partner he mutters to tanchiro to go
for the neck now that akaza is unaware
tanjudo calls out to the upper moon and
declares that he will decapitate him
annoying for announcing his attack out
loud akashic retaliates by attempting to
swipe the demon slayer's head only for
tanjuro to duck down to safety
suddenly he notices he cannot sense
anything seeing tangido is completely
different from before with his battle
spirit seemingly gone akasa tries to
calm himself and believes that he will
be able to sense an attack but without
warning his head is sliced completely
off by tanjido who was using the
hanokamikageta setting sun
transformation with geyu stunned at
tanjiru's sun improvement akasa declares
that this is impossible despite being
beheaded by tanjiro akasa internally
reflects on the battle spirit of people
he had never encountered someone who
could remove theirs commenting that
fighting tangier felt like fighting a
plant despite his senses and compass not
working properly on the battlefield
anything unexpected can happen he
notices tanchito managing to surpass his
own speed in a short amount of time but
his eyes showing no intent to kill ikaza
believes tajiro has achieved the
selfless state he so badly wanted to
attain himself something he believes
that he should have done so by now the
upper rank tries to put his head back on
top of his neck with the resolve to
continue fighting however give flings
his broken sword at his head knocking it
away from his grasp the upper rank
repeats his drive to continue to get
stronger as his head starts to
disintegrate tanjuro becomes relieved
but immediately stiffens up due to his
body hitting his limits however upon
seeing akash's body not disintegrating
geyu and tanjuro worriedly look on
akash's headless body activates
destructive death compass needle again
and immediately attempts to hit
tangero's neck though he barely misses
the demon changes stance and hits
tangero square on the side knocking him
away tangier realises akazu is trying to
make his head a weak spot no longer
similar to muzan earlier he tries to get
up but faints due to his body reaching
its absolute limit geyu sees akasa going
for his unconscious comrade and uses
water breathing fourth form striking tai
to stop him though the cut instantly
heals giu then declares that if akaza
wanted to kill tanjuro he would have to
go through him first and takes his
stance to fight once again akaza sees
his indomitable spirit one that does not
bend in the face of any obstacle
suddenly he sees the same man from
earlier who comments that we wield the
sword in our hearts the things we use
are our fists calling the man an eyesore
akasa moves forward to engage geyu but
is internally held back by the vision of
a young woman wishing hakugi-san to just
stop already
as geyu reads the fight akasa once more
he realizes the severity of this
situation his body has reached its
limits his senses are failing his body
is numb and the only thing keeping him
up is his breathing calling it a miracle
for him to continue battling despite the
heavy toll on his own
gear now focuses on protecting the
unconscious tangido resolving to never
let friends or family die on his watch
again knowing tanjuro would do the same
the woman's spirit grabs a casa telling
him to not go
akasa tells you to go away asking who
she is and she carefully begs for them
to go to the other side but he only
responds to her that he must kill
tanjuro and giu when asked why akasa's
only answer is that he must get stronger
but when she asks why he needs to get
stronger he answers because if i don't i
won't be able to bring the medicine back
for dad as zakaz's memories come
flashing back to him we dive into a
flashback whereakaza was once known as
hakuji an 11 year old boy who stole
money and food to keep his father alive
one fateful day he was caught beaten and
given tattoos to mark him as a thief the
villager's magistrate warns the boy his
hands would be removed the next time he
steals only for him to say that he can
go and cut them off as he still has his
feet and will steal with those instead
the magistrate tells him the beatings he
received would cause a strong man to
become numb calling him a demon child
for being able to handle it the boy
continues on telling him to call him by
that name saying that he was born with
fangs after his beatings and threats by
the authorities hakuji walked home until
a man informed him of terrible news his
father had heard he was caught and had
hung himself in shame while hikuji was
in the cemetery he read the final letter
that his father had written out before
his death his father wrote to him
dihikuji please live an honest life so
that you can turn over a new lead i
don't want to live off money that has
been stolen from others and i'm sorry
for being a nuisance
after reading the letter and finding his
headstone hakuji tearfully grabs it and
grieves his death he asks how his father
can make peace with such people finally
cursing the world and telling it that
everyone can just go to hell hikuji
recalls his beatings for stealing money
and how he could endure anything for his
father no matter how severe he wonders
why he had hung himself declaring he
would have died for him after being
expelled from edo due to his rage he was
left to wander the streets eventually
making his way to a village where he
found seven men and almost beat them to
death leaving them there unconscious all
while saying his father never hurt
anyone he didn't bother him and he
didn't need to apologize afterwards a
martial artist came by drawn by the news
a boy was about to be killed instead
finding that said boy had actually
beaten the seven men barehanded amazed
at this feat the man cheerfully asks if
he would like to be a student only for
the still hikuji to threaten him back
later on the man takes the awakening
herkuji for a tour of his dojo and he
introduces himself as kaizo a master who
teaches the bare-fisted martial art
called soryu style however he didn't
have a single student so he made his
living off handyman work kaizo asks the
boy to care for his sick daughter a task
his recent wife used to do but had
killed herself over due to its
exhausting nature
hikuchi asks why he would leave his
daughter with a criminal only for kaizo
to cheerfully remind him that he beat up
that said criminal keizo's happy
demeanor reminds akaza of why he hates
tanjudo so much because tanjida reminds
him of kaizo a figment of his boring and
worthless past as he continues to call
his past worthless he reaches the memory
of where he first met kaiyuki kiyuki's
sick appearance reminding him of his own
fathers
as kaizo goes away to work he leaves the
two together kyuki asks if he has heard
seen his injured face akasa curses his
human life remembering the promises he
made and failed to deliver he declared
his life worthless filled with empty
promises
hikuji asks himself why sick people are
always apologising remembering the times
his father did so and kayuki now
apologizing that he can't train while
caring for her kyuki was born with a
weak body and had to be attended to day
and night however hikuji was fine with
the task as he had previously cared for
his ill-father and his resilient nature
meant that he never tired he never felt
like playing around anyway and simply
trained in his free time hakugi mentions
there would be fireworks on display and
that he was willing to carry her to the
bridge to watch with him when kayuki
seems unsure he reminds her of next year
and the year after there she begins to
cry somewhat annoying him that she would
burst into tears mid-conversation he
believes she cries due to the depressing
nature of her illness while commenting
her crying made him feel uncomfortable
while keizer and akuji share a drink at
the well the master mentions how their
names are actually similarly structured
to be based on a phrase meaning protect
therefore they must protect something a
fact that makes keizo laugh keizer
recalls how the dojo came to be he says
he had protected an old man with the
suryal style of combat and that man
amazed at the feat had given him the
land and place for the dojo later on
however the nearby kinjutsu dojo found
out and began to harass the sorry dojo
which led to him having no students this
was mitigated in keizo's eyes by
training her kuji and caring for kayuki
something that he said healed his heart
years later hakuji turns 18 and kiyuki
turned 16. in that time kyuki had gotten
better and no longer needed to
continually lie down she was also now
happy and bright while cleaning the
floors hikuchi was summoned to the dojo
and spoke with kaizo where he told him
that he wanted to take over the dojo and
casually mentions how he can also have
his daughter kiyuki as well a statement
which ends up shocking the both of them
hakugi never believed he could ever
future as a criminal much less a future
as a husband with a wife he remembers
his father's letter to him and recalls
this swelling feeling his life could go
anywhere declaring now that he wants
more than nothing to protect koyuki and
kaizo even at the cost of his own life
hikuji travels back home to tell his
father's grave about his marriage but as
he returned to the dojo he suddenly
began to breathe heavily and a sinking
feeling came over him there someone
informed him the well they drank from
was poisoned by the kinjutsu dojo
killing kaizo and koyuki seeing their
bloodied lifeless bodies on the dojo
floor hikuji laments that he's never
there to protect his loved ones in a
crisis he suddenly remembers a moment
back when kyouki came with him to watch
the village's new year fireworks while
there kyuki asked about the conversation
they had about the fireworks while they
were younger something that he had
forgotten but something that she had
never forgot
when he was unable to watch them that
year he suggested the next one to her or
the year after that and she recalls when
she didn't believe in herself living
another year or so on hugh remembers
when her mother killed herself being
unable to care for her any longer and
believed in a way her father was tired
of caring for her as well she saw hakuji
casually asking if she was willing to
see them next year giving you hope of a
future kuki asks if he would like to be
your husband and hakuji graciously
answers so yes i will become stronger
than anyone else and protect you for my
entire life in the end though akasa
laments that it was just simply words
and he couldn't manage anything in his
life filled with rage and losing the
people he loved once again hikuji went
to the kinjutsu dojo and brutally killed
or 67 members inside using this suryu
style he eviscerated their bodies the
dojo was found with crushed skulls
destroyed organs brain limbs and
eyeballs strewn throughout the building
all the corpses destroyed to the point
they were unrecognizable as a human body
the incident was so horrific and absurd
that it was regarded as a fictional
story before being erased from history
in the wake of the destruction a blooded
and broken hakuji encounters muzan
kibatsuji
muzan had heard about the carnage and
mistakenly thought that he had sent a
demon to do so instead finding that a
mere human had actually done it leaving
him somewhat disappointed hikuchi
threatened to kill him when the demon
lord suddenly rushed forward and pissed
his head with his hand before he could
fight back
muzan comments he was thinking about
building a group of 12 powerful demons
and asked sakuji if he could withstand
the amount of blood that he was about to
be given hikuchi declares to him that he
no longer cares about anything anymore
and transformed into the demon a kaza
then and there akasi recalls losing his
human memories in the wake of turning
into a demon but continued to have the
drive to get stronger and stronger
though in reality he had nothing left to
protect
in the end akaza comments that his life
was nothing more than a pathetic comical
uninteresting story as a kazil laments
he cannot go to heaven like his father
kaizo and kiyuki he becomes furious that
tanjuro and geyu have reminded him of
his painful past he curses humans as
weak soft brittle they die right away
and disappear into nothing
suddenly tangier awakens from his ordeal
shocked at how he fainted mid-battle as
zakaza begins to regenerate his head he
begins to deploy his annihilation type
as tanchiro yells at him to stop the
demon becomes shocked that tanchiro has
managed to survive his kirk declaring he
will behead akazu again tanjiru's sword
ignites with the fire of the hinokami
kagura however his sword slips out of
his grasp forcing tanjido to punch kaz's
face instead the punch reminds him of
when he first meet kaizo making him
remember why he hates weak people weak
people never fight face to face they
poison wells they are impatient he
killed these weak people with his fists
and he suddenly realizes throughout his
life as a demon he turned his master's
fighting style into a bloody weapon and
never respected his father's last words
finally realizing who he must truly kill
as tanjudo panics about his lost sword
and seeing a kaza about to use the same
technique that killed rengoku he
suddenly notices geyu in the attack
range though geu tells him not to worry
about him tangero grabs him and throws
both themselves out of the technique's
path suddenly he sees a kaza smiling
slightly followed by an immense
explosion the attack leaves the
surroundings devastated as well as a
kaz's body now a broken bloody mess
wondering why akasa would attack himself
tajiru smells a scent of gratitude
coming from the corpse as well as asking
himself why he had smiled before
self-determinating the body begins to
regenerate but akasa stops the process
telling himself that the fight is over
he had lost fair and square he comments
that tanjiru had magnificent technique
anticipating and slashing before he
could react the broken body begins to
walk away while akash's spirit comments
he would go to hell as a man when he
stops to tangido's confusion his spirit
mates with his fathers asking if he was
all right his father comments yes
calling him hikuji and thanking him as
he bows and crouches down apologizing
for being unable to fix himself his head
is held by keizo's spirit kazoo tells
him that they would never abandon him no
matter what despite akasa not being able
to go to heaven with them as he calls
out for his master muzan appears grabs
his head and scolds him reminding him
that he had to get stronger and continue
fighting with that his body starts to
regenerate again even quicker akasa
voices his will to keep his promise and
get stronger declaring once again that
he will kill everyone suddenly though
kaiuki touches his face thanking hikuji
and saying that he has done enough
though muzan appears again calling him a
kaza once more he overcomes muzan's
control and grabs kaiouki's spirit on
the verge of tears as once again the
human hakuji he tearfully apologizes for
being unable to protect her for not
being there when she needed him for not
being able to keep his promise
while he cries for forgiveness kyuki is
glad that hikuji had remembered them all
despite his long demon life and
returning as a human again
with his words welcome back my husband
akaza stops his regeneration and tangier
watches as his body finally fades into
ash
hikuchi calls out to his father keizo
and kiyuki that he is back home his
spirit becomes engulfed in the fires of
hell joined by kyuuki tanjiru watches as
zakaz's body finally fades into nothing
declaring that the battle is finally
over
realizing that he must reach tamiya to
help her his body can no longer handle
the fatigue and he falls on his face
unconscious
surprised that tanjuno had suddenly
fainted geyu tries to call out to him
but faints from exhaustion as well
resting his body on his sword akasugai
crow calls out the aftermath of the
battle tangero and geu have managed to
defeat the upper moon 3 but are now
unconscious elsewhere we see that
kokoshibo no longer feels akash's
presence and realizes he is being
defeated as a kaza has lost the upper
moon won comments that he could have
never been able to beat him remembering
his threat earlier at his life as he
voices that akasa had opened up the path
to reach further heights and abandoned
it he grabs his own sword and furiously
slashes the pillars of his room cursing
a kaza as weak
over in the cult room doma hears the
news of akasa's demise and comments that
he felt like a kaza had turned into a
different being before he died as he
brushes aside his comment he asks kanoa
for her name she introduces herself as
kanua adding that she is the little
sister of kane and shinobu kocho derma
is confused judging that she doesn't
appear to be blood related to the two
but nonetheless comments that the young
girls are delicious either way
while on the subject of eating woman
doma mentions the subordinates conscious
decision to not eat woman owing that
fact to his demise despite mentioning
that women have more nutritional content
to demons than men akasi refused and was
even given special permission by muzan
to do so since kaza was only deployed by
muzad on special missions
as he mourns for his best friend's death
kanoa tells him to stop the lies she
figures out easily derma does not even
feel the least bit saddened as the
colour on his face has stayed the exact
same when doma responded back it's due
to him being a demon though kanoa
retorts by mentioning that demons and
humans both circulate blood and the
colour of their faces can change she
mentions that kane had felt sorry for
him as he feels nothing she talks about
how all people are born with the ability
to feel happiness as well as sadness and
anger doma could not understand these
feelings but knowing he was intelligent
kanoa instead tears into how he covers
up his lack of feelings with a facade of
lies pretending to experience emotion
to hide the fact his heart feels nothing
he feels no happiness no bitterness no
pain calling him an empty shell and
saying his facade is so comical it's
stupid finally she mockingly asks why
were you even born
doma comments that throughout his life
he has talked with numerous young women
but never a bully like kano and asks how
could she say something so cruel kano
retaliates by saying it's because of her
outright hatred of him her desire to
completely cut off his head she changes
your opinion of him and tells him that
he's not very smart calling him a
disgrace and smiling as she mentions it
was better to kill him as his life is
utterly pointless and meaningless therma
instantly appears behind her trying to
slice her neck bokano reacts in time
however and crouches down to slash
through his abdomen when he tries to
send out ice dolls to hit her she dodges
the incoming attack to safety as doma
heals he comments that her reaction
speed has accelerated and she is
adjusting to his own movement also she
has not inhaled any of his ice despite
it being an extremely difficult task to
attack in her manner without using a
breathing technique doma suddenly
realizes that kano might actually be
more powerful than shinobu
kano feels that the goosebumps
throughout her body aren't stopping she
even knows to put strength into her
fingertips to hold your sword or risk it
shaking she mentions the demons she had
faced in the past pale in comparison to
doma but she is able to face him due to
the immense anger she feels anger so
powerful it feels like her body is
literally burning she feels she must
rampage at him or her body would rip
itself apart the dizziness in her head
and her anger turning into hatred she
calls out that she hates doma and asks
how he could kill her entire family
khano vanishes and instantly appears
before him using flower breathing fifth
form peonies of futility to rapidly
slash him doma comments that the
consecutive attacks are pretty and
retaliates with his blood demon art
baron hanging garden kanu attacks back
with the flower breathing second form
honorable snow plum to destroy the ice
created doma notices the key to
withstanding his attacks are her eyes
she notices his movements and predicts
his next actions in anticipation
complimenting her as smart and above the
average swordsman the demon decides the
best course of action is to gouge out
her eyes doma slashes at her face bucano
bends back in time only sustaining a
small cut to the left side of her temple
using flower breathing sixth form
whirling peach she attacks back at the
upper moon who compliments her body and
her flexibility saying that it is
extremely well trained doma deploys his
fearsome freezing clouds forcing kanua
to close her eyes or risk freezing them
while on the defensive she is attacked
again by doma using blood demon art
lotus fines the ice vines converging on
her and forcing kano to slice the
incoming attack to defend against them
when she is finished cutting them apart
germa quickly attacks with his blood
demon art cold white princesses kano
again backs away to avoid the fog but
must dodge again when doma unleashes
another blood demon art wintry icicles
from above and nearly impales her doma
taunts her for getting away from him
mentioning that in order to kill him she
needs to actually get up close he
disappears for a moment and reappears
clutching her nature and blade despite
kano aware and anticipating his next
moves doma mocks her for not holding
onto the sword and sticks it into the
bridge near him he tells the demon
slayer to come and get it and deploys
his blood demon art scattering lotuses
in her direction kanoa forces herself to
look through the incoming hail of ice to
find the area of minimum damage but
sustains multiple cuts to her face still
suddenly arnosky smashes through the
roof announcing out of the blue that the
lord himself enosuke is coming through
and using beast breathing fifth fang
crazy cutting he destroys the incoming
wave of ice shards saving kano he thanks
the kasugai crow for leading him to the
right room anosuke looks intently at
durma's eyes and enthusiastically
realizes he is the upper moon too he
declares he will defeat him and finally
become a hashera
a confused doma mentions that he isn't
hiding his identity as upper moon too
anosuke sees the injured kano and warns
her that chernobyl will get angry at
seeing her condition but when kano
doesn't respond and she becomes upset
anosuke is completely stunned into
silence doma overhears him and mentions
that shinobu will live forever inside
him as that's how everyone i eat gets
saved inosuke is left completely shocked
as he remembers their memory he had
where shinobu pinky promised him to not
remove the bandage of his injured hand
anosuke angrily declares on noor at your
shreds trash and charges towards doma
despite kano warning him not to inhale
the cold air he creates using beast
breathing fourth form slice and dice
anosuke slashes at doma at the same time
the demon comments on his messed up
technique as well as noticing his
chipped blades in unorthodox fighting
style when doma attempts to slash in
anosuke's neck he flips back and
deflects the fan with his feet earning a
compliment from the upper moon for his
flexibility and intrigued by his mask
inosuke lands next to kano and presents
her with her blade stolen from the
unaware doma to her shock doma comments
that the demon slayer is fast and grows
more ice to attack only for enosuke to
deflect them back and kick him in his
stomach knocking him away anosuke
charges forward and readies a slash doma
comments that the attack is far from the
sword's range so when the ball-headed
figure swings he becomes completely and
utterly shocked that the attack had
managed to reach him and slashed him
across his eyes and nosquay had used his
beast breathing ninth form extending
bendy slash dislocating the joints of
his arms to extend his range he
relocates the bones of his arm but is
angered at the new attack's inaccuracy
made him miss doma's head takano's
complete shock doma is left amused at
his unusual opponent and comments that
throughout his own life he had never met
a fighter like him anoski takes the
compliment and says that it's because
the other riff-raff are losers and
nothing compared to him but walinosuke
is talking his mask instantly appears
off his face surprising him and shocking
kano doma in that moment had stolen it
without either demon slayer noticing and
comments that the boarskin is quite old
as inosuke angrily demands his ball mask
back doma suddenly responds that he
knows he has seen inosuke's face
somewhere before doma asks if he and
enosuke had met any past causing inosuke
to get angry and retort at his statement
demanding him to hand his mask back
however doma is sure that they have and
he knows him from somewhere enosuke
responds again that he has not met doma
before but doma mentions the only one he
encountered before was shinobu leading
in oscar to comment that he felt as if
he had met her before when kano attempts
to lead in oscar away saying doma is
spouting random nonsense doma becomes
surprised and offended stating his only
saving grace is his seriousness and long
and clear memory even during his human
years with that gemma pierces his own
skull with his finger takano and
inosuke's shock and disgust doma fiddles
with the inside of his brain until he
reaches a particular memory and retells
it to the two fifteen years ago there
was a young woman with a baby roughly 17
to 18 years of age she was abused by her
husband and mother-in-law daily and
encountered doma's paradise faith cold
she had no siblings or parents and had
no place else to go when doma first met
her her face was severely swollen from
the bee teens commenting that it was
pretty rough even to him the woman was
even partially blind but when he touched
the woman's face her face went back to
normal she was so beautiful it left an
everlasting impression on the even
epithetic doma he mentions she had the
same face as in oscar and concludes that
it must have been his mother enosuke
says that he has no mother and was
raised by bores to which doma replies
that you're a human so a human must have
given birth to you but inosuke charges
forward without listening and reduces
beast breathing sixth fang takano's
concern only for doma to state this
encounter is a miracle and
simultaneously slashes adinosuke's chest
twice creating an x-like mark he quickly
summons more ice and knocks both demon
slayers into the cult room's pond
as kano urges inosuke to calm down doma
continues his story he says that he had
no intention of eating the woman as
having someone as beautiful as her next
to you felt pretty good though he
considered her unintelligent she was
talented at singing the woman
continually saying a pinky promised
lullaby to her baby doma mentioning that
she's saying with different lyrics each
time and adding that this song soon
became a village song inosuke realizes
that the pinky promise song was not
because of shinobu doma says that he
purely planned on letting her live her
life but learn that though she wasn't
particularly smart the woman named
kotaha was sharp she soon learned that
doma devoured the followers of the cult
and ended up confronting him for his
lives and fleeing the temple kotaha
apologizes to inosuke cursing herself
for continually making mistakes even
going the wrong way after she left the
temple all the while she repeatedly kept
saying that she was sorry she became
lost in the forest and unable to find
the village cornered at a cliff's edge
she apologizes once more to winosuke
before dropping him off the cliff into
the water doma kills her shortly after
this he believed the baby would have
definitely died from the drop of the
cliff and cried at how sad the situation
had become anoski suddenly figures out
that she was killed and that doma had
eaten her to the very bone and noted if
she went to her husband he would have
continued to beat her and if she was
alone by herself on the road she would
have ended up dead as well
doma mocks kodah's life for being so
unfortunate asking if there was ever a
happy moment in it and calls your
existence pointless kano furiously tells
him to shut up though as inosuke grabs
his fallen swords from the water he
remembers his mother's love for him doma
comments that it was truly a miracle
meeting in oscar here which fills him
with more rage as he declares that the
demon who killed his mother and his
friends is standing right before his
eyes he stands back up and thanks doma
for letting him remember everything the
voices that the demon won't cut off his
head now he takes a stance and readies
to fight doma declaring that he's going
to show him what hell is truly like
doma tells enosuke that though he was
raised by bores and knows his way with
words he is still mistaken the demon
claims that heaven and hell don't exist
and that they are figments of human
fantasies to him the humans who live
righteously suffer tragedies while the
evil live free to do whatever they want
adding that since divine punishment
doesn't exist mentally weak people
therefore believe the evil go to hell
upon their deaths he tells them that
they keep this belief deep in their
minds and calls humans pitiful anastas
screams out that he decides then that
he'll instead create a hell for doma as
he charges telling doma to stop talking
about his mother's life as unfortunate
doma retaliates with his blood demon art
freezing cloud and an oscar uses his
tenth fang whirling fangs rotating his
blades to disperse the icy cloud kano
attempts to attack doma from behind but
he anticipates her swiping his fans at
her neck though she parries the fan his
swipe still knocks her into the water
doma clings to the roof causing inosuke
to yell for him to come down and face
him doma tells them that akasa is
defeated and he no longer has the time
instead creating ice stalls to fight the
demon slayers as they land enosuke and
kanoa are confused but are soon shocked
when the dolls use scattering lotuses to
fight them doma tells them the ice dolls
are as powerful as him leaving him to it
as he leaves making inosuke furious kano
tells him to focus on their battle as a
doll uses frozen lotuses to slash
arinosuke forcing him back doma notices
ignosuke isn't breathing in his fog
confusing him as the dolls use cold
white princesses and envelop the room
with more fog anosuke becomes incensed
that everything around him is freezing
durma is intrigued by him as a fighter
that he had never faced before he
decided to force the demon slayers to
use all their techniques as the
information would be useful to him in
the future as kano is forced to hold
back another lotus vine onslaught she
hopes shinny nosuke can keep doma inside
the room with them for a little while
longer however doma immediately decides
to create a fifth doll to kill the
combatants quicker or face getting
scolded with that he forges one in his
fans and releases her the doll
immediately deploying wintry icicles to
nakano a further back
soon inosuke's arms get slashed by the
icy vines worrying kano as she tells
them to hold out for just a while longer
she herself becomes overwhelmed by the
continuous slashes of ice lotuses doma
overhears her and is confused at how
they will survive for any longer knowing
his dolls will record anything during
the battle he decides to leave but as
doma opens up the door of the occult
room his face suddenly begins to melt
confusing him to kana was gratitude he
collapses to the floor and suddenly
thinks back to shinobu from earlier in
the past when shinobu and kano had
confirmed about if they ever encountered
the upper moon too shinobi believes if
she encountered him and kano happened to
fight alongside her she would need to be
eaten first shocking her younger sister
kano pleased that she and her would
fight the demon together only for
shinobu to respond back to abandon those
thoughts she tells her that she knows an
upper moon is as strong as at least
three harsher at minimum and according
to their late sister kane the upper moon
two is gluttonous with an obsession for
eating woman shinobu knows if the demon
faces a hashera with great abilities a
body in excellent condition and as a
woman he would definitely eat her
worrying kano further she tells kano
that her body is currently concentrated
with wisteria poison
as kano tells her she is also willing to
go through the exact same thing shinobu
tells her that it is impossible to reach
the level that she is at as she has been
absorbing the poison for over a year now
shinobu confesses that she was the first
to do such a feat herself unsure of the
potential side effects in the future and
unsure if her plan would work on the
upper moon or even muzan she states her
sword has 50 milliliters of poison but
whatever demon consumes her would also
consume 37 kilograms worth of poison and
her body weight derma collapses further
from the effects of shinobi's poison his
arm falling off his bones beginning to
melt and his regeneration failing he
realizes he never felt the poison
circulate through him until now his eye
stalls soon fracture and collapse as
well to enosuke's confusion
kano realizes shinobi's poison is
working and they now have doma cornered
shinobu tells kanua that she doesn't
even know if her life's worth of
expertise on poison would even work on
an upper moon demon kagaya ubishiki
himself had deemed it impossible but
advises her to consult with a certain
demon for further knowledge shinobu
tells her sister if the poisoning did
start working she must never let her
guard down adding that the only way to
kill the upper moon is by severing his
neck she knows she will definitely
weaken him but she tells kanu to deal
the finishing blow
back in the reality of the fight kanoa
becomes assured she will kill the upper
moon too and resolves to not let
shinobu's life go to waste
as shiandonosuke converge on doma he
summons his final technique blood demon
art rime water lily bottastiva with the
two stunned at his new threat the giant
ice figure slams down onto the colt's
pond sidney inosuke and kano flying back
kano realizes if they get forced away
from the fog durma will have the time to
recover and if they entered the fog and
inhaled it they would no longer be able
to fight however she notices though that
doma's body sliver is powerful it is
still shoddy doma has lost all of his
precision and creating it was a
last-ditch effort she decides to use her
own last technique and remembers her
last moments with shinobu shinobi warns
her that using the technique might blind
her eyeballs are delicate with very thin
blood vessels and nerves telling her to
not endanger and burden herself by
releasing such a powerful technique
bakana rejects her warning asking why
should she worry about her vision when
shinobu gave her own life she calls her
sister sweet and an honourable person
declaring that she wanted to protect her
life with her life and she wanted her
aoi keo sumi and naho and herself to all
go home together kano activates
flower-breathing final form equinential
vermilion eye causing her eyes to flush
full of blood and her perception
heightened to an even further level the
giant bodhistiva becomes slow in her
eyes she realizes her protective cosine
that wraps around most of her eyeballs
are turning red and in that moment
quickly slices up the ice figure's hands
to reach doma as she swings at doma's
decaying head the bodhistiva turns back
and blasts kano with icy fog freezing
her back and arms her sword reaches his
neck but she can no longer swing further
with her arms stuck frozen inosuke
seeing this and having been recently
saved by kano uses his new technique
sudden throwing strike hurling his
blades at doma his swords connect with
kanos gripping into them and driving her
blade through doma's neck decapitating
him in that moment
domer expresses his disbelief at having
his head sliced off he expresses his
self-pity for losing to a sword wielder
who didn't have enough strength to slice
off necks even though he had put much
effort into what he believed was for
other people's sakes however he doesn't
give up right away and thinks to himself
that he still has a chance and might not
die like muzan he also knows akasa was
also able to start growing back his head
however as doma's head falls to the
floor and bounces his body begins to
disintegrate and he realizes that he is
truly going to die he thinks to himself
how he doesn't feel anything recalling
back to his childhood his mother had
stabbed his father to death and the
latter had flirted with numerous female
followers later committing suicide via
poison shortly after despite this
tragedy his only thoughts were about
ventilating the room he couldn't
comprehend the deaths because of his
apathy and was only bothered by the
smell of their blood doma remembers how
he was turned into a demon at the age of
20 and lived for over a century but in
the end human emotions had been alien to
him
in the afterlife shinobu holds doma's
head in her right hand the former
expressing relief at doma's death will
they smile she states that she can now
be at rest derma greets her asking
whether her name was shinobu or kane
shinobu smiles and tells him that he
doesn't have to remember their names
asking him not to address them because
it was creepy durma compliments shinobu
about the intensity of the poison
claiming he didn't even notice the
poison until it had fully circulated
through his body shinobu explains that
tamiya had assisted her in making the
poison expressing her slight frustration
that if she could she would have wanted
to kill doma with her poison she had
made herself suddenly doma claims that
his missing heart feels like it is being
asking shinobu whether this was love
expressing his surprise that emotions
did indeed exist he then goes on to
think that heaven and hell may exist as
well asking shinobu whether she wanted
to go to hell with him to this the
lesser tells him to just go to hell
already as she is completely and utterly
sick of him meanwhile inosuki stomps on
the place where doma's disintegrating
head once was yelling insults growing
dizzy he then falls to the ground he
recalls the conversation he had with
tanjiru and zanetsu inosuke had been
yelling that he didn't have a mother but
tanjuro tells him that everyone has a
mother to chinoski responded that he was
abandoned which meant that his mother
did not want him zenitsu replies that
ifanosuke had truly been abandoned his
mother wouldn't have bothered to name
him an oscar retorts back that he
doesn't have memories of his mother
which was the same as not having one at
all but tanjiru gently reminds him not
to speak of his mother that way
stating that his mother must have loved
him a lot
suddenly inosuke begins to cry as he
remembers his mother kano on the other
hand looks for shinobu's hair clip
noting her inability to see clearly from
her right eye
she realizes her own hair clip formerly
kane's is now broken to her sadness kano
apologizes to her sister and recalls the
time when kane had died she was unable
to cry at that moment bothering her
greatly kano had been making excuses
inside of her heart and clutches at her
chest but when she feels the apparitions
of shinobu and kane softly passing her
on the head and telling her that she did
well kane looks up to only find that
they weren't there elsewhere in the
dream world shinobi reunites with her
sister and her parents in the pond
holding both her adoptive sister's
hairpins kano begins to cry as tangido
sleeps he smells something burning he
tries to sleep further but he realizes
that it is a fire quickly jolting awake
he sees geyu putting his sword through a
small fire he builds when asked by
tanjuro giu states his wounds haven't
stopped bleeding despite putting
pressure on them resulting in him
burning them to tangero's disgust geyu
extended the offer to tanjuro noting if
the bleeding in his arm didn't halt he
can burn them as well to which tangier
worriedly agrees tanjuro stands upright
and holds his sword out to be on guard
mcgee states that this fight is only the
beginning the final goal is muzan but he
is worried they may soon face upper moon
2 or even 1.
at that moment akasugai crow announces
that shinobu kano and inosuke had
defeated upper moon 2 to the shock of
both of the water breathers tangero then
realizes that all of the slayers are
slowly getting closer to mu's arm
meanwhile matsuri had found nakime now
the upper moon 4. obani realizes the
previous one defeated by machiero and
company had now been replaced matsuri
laments that shinobu risked her own life
to win despite being younger than her
giving her the motivation to attack
nikime head on the demon summons a door
however slamming matsuri away to her
embarrassment obani catches her though
and takes her to an upper platform to
safety only for the floors to be opened
by nakime causing both of them to nearly
fall
they regroup however nakimi retaliates
by causing the flaws matsuri is standing
on to rocket to the ceiling resulting in
her nearly getting crushed till she
destroys the floor she is on the lover
shara claims that she won't fall for
that trick earlier nearly hitting nakime
who subsequently opens another door
causing an annoyed matsuri to fall
through obinna uses snake breathing
second form venom fangs of the narrow
head but misses when nakime summons a
building to block his path to this he
comments that though nakime's blood
demon art isn't deadly it's by far the
most annoying and troublesome elsewhere
gyome and mochiro continue through the
castle sensing muzan is close
suddenly a wall compartment pushes
muchero separating the two he is forced
through multiple walls before landing in
a room full of numerous pillars inside
the room the demon notices him and
comments he looks rather familiar matera
was shocked as it reveals that he is now
face to face with the upper moon one the
upper moon one kokushibo examines
muchero tokito in the transparent world
and recognizes something in the boy as
mature looks on adam thinking that the
upper rank 1 is quite dignified and
majestic mature notices the blade at the
demon's side and wonders if he had been
a demon slayer in the past suddenly
mature's hands start shaking with a
sword handle and its grip unable to
shake the feeling of dread from being in
front of kokushibo with his body
refusing to battle something that had
never happened before in his entire life
majira attempts to compose himself
kukushibo asks him what his name was and
matera tells him with kokushiba
responding that the tsuki koni name has
died out puzzled mature asks him who
tsuki gurney is and kokushibo continues
saying that it was inevitable after so
many centuries the upper rank tells
muchero that when he had been human his
name was machikatsu tsukiguni and then
reveals that muchiro is his descendant
mature's eyes widen with shock and he
refuses to believe it at first with his
mind swimming with questions about the
upper rank coming back to earth quickly
mature steals himself and prepares to
attack with kokoshibo praising his
mental strength lording him for
overcoming his panic in such a short
period of time as mature swoops forward
and attacks him with a misbreathing
second form eight-layered mist that the
demon effortlessly dodges in the blink
of an eye appearing behind muchiro
kukushibo praises the boy's breathing
technique seeing that his descendant was
a missed breathing user and then swiftly
dodges a missed breathing fifth form sea
of clouds and haze launched by the mr
shearer accurately deducing mutura's age
as being 14 kokushibo is impressed that
the boy's swordsmanship is so refined at
his young age and his mental fortitude
to quell his fear and battle the demon
taking pride and the strength still
flowing from those of his blood
displeased mature rebuffs the upper rank
saying that if a hundred years have
indeed passed then not a drop of
kokushibo's blood remains in him mature
then activates his demon slayer mark and
performs a misbreathing seventh form
obscuring clouds a technique that
kokushibo had never seen before as
muchero slices at the demon's neck
kukushibo quickly evades the attack
impressed with the beauty and grace of
the technique during his own blade
kokoshibo performs moon breathing first
form dark moon even in palace that
muchero is unable to keep up with and
the hashera sadly loses his left hand as
a result shocked that the upper rank is
able to use breathing techniques as a
demon motura quickly attempts to
restrict the bleeding from the stump on
his arm by tightening the sleeves of his
robe with his teeth he then dashes
forward and attacks kokushibo despite
his injuries and the demon is impressed
at the courage and his skill of his
descendant as the mr shearer performs a
missed breathing fourth form shifting
flow and slash kukushibo catches the
boy's blade between his fingers and
turns it on him pinning him to a pillar
and then he asks mushiro to allow him to
turn the hashera into a demon so that he
could serve muzan kibitsuji kukushibo
stands in front of mochiro after having
pinned him to a pillar with his own
blade and says that his heart is moved
on scene one of his own descendants
something he had never imagined machero
stares at the upper rank in silence as
kukushibo continues and says that the mr
shira's arm would regrow once he became
a demon certain that musa would allow
such a thing given that the other upper
ranks had all been slain transfixed on
his descendant kokoshibo attempts to try
and stem muchuro's bleeding but then
says that if muchero died due to excess
blood loss or if he was rejected by
muzan then it would be fate kokoshibo
tells maturo that this would mean that
he was a man and only meant to go so far
in the background sneakily kenya
shinozugawa attempts to sleep up on the
demon as he shoots at him he is left
utterly shocked as kokushibo instantly
appears behind him and asks if he agrees
with his statement slicing off genya's
gun arms so fast that he wasn't even
able to notice as giny's left arm falls
to the ground the boy looks in shock and
attempts to defend himself as mature is
horrified and yells out to ginya before
his hand is able to fully draw his blade
kokoshibo swiftly slices off his other
arm as well leaving the boy bleeding
profusely he sees that kenya has been
eating demons and slices his torso clean
in half
mature was horrified at the sight and
attempts to pull the blade out of
himself but in vain as he is unable to
make it budge
kukushibo is surprised that genya is
still alive despite having his torso cut
in half and tells him that around 300
years ago there was another swordsman
who ate demons just like he did saying
that he had killed a particular
swordsman by slicing his torso in half
kukushima says that if the same strategy
did not work on genya then perhaps the
boy's weak point was actually his head
kenya tries to crawl towards his arms to
attempt to reattach them as kukushima
says that he has no reason to allow a
fake demon like him to live and begins
to slice at his head suddenly he is
intercepted by sunimi shinozugawa
performing the wind breathing fourth
form rising dust storm as genya is left
shocked kogoshibo immediately retreats
backwards and recognizes sunimi as the
wind hashera as the later says that he
is the wind that will rip off
kokushibo's head genya whispers to his
brother who roughly responds by calling
genya a pathetic little brother telling
him that the reason he went so far as to
kill their own mother was that he wanted
to protect kenya flashing back to a
conversation he had with tanjuro during
his ashira training kenya remembers that
tangier told him he could not smell a
tinge of hatred and tsunami towards
genya and tanjudo had told him that he
did not need to be afraid of his brother
because sanimi had loved him that entire
time sanemi continues and tells genya
that he should have lived a normal life
until he reaped a ripe old age and
attempted to make his wife and children
happy in return for all the happiness
that had been taken from them their
siblings and their mother essenemy tells
him that he would have not let a single
demon get near genya no matter what
genya tears up and apologizes to his
brother meanwhile kukushibo feels
nostalgic upon seeing a pair of demon
slayer brothers enraged though sanemi
curses at kokushibo and lunges forward
to attack as kokoshibo slices at him
ducking and sliding between kokoshibo's
legs sanemi catches the demon's foot and
flips him over launching a
wind-breathing first form dust whirlwind
cutter at the upper rank without paws
sunimi matches blades with kokoshibo who
finally draws his sword out for all to
see a grotesque blade with eyes and
veins running down the side of its
length and sending me notes how
disgusting the sight of it truly is
sunimi and kokushibo go blade to blade
and the upper moon unleashes a moon
breathing fifth floor moon spirit
calamitous eddy that the wind hishera
manages to dodge noting that kokushibo
is able to repeat his slashes without
even moving his blade tsunimi prepares
to counter-attack dashing forward sunimi
performs a wind-breathing third form
clean storm wintry and clashes with
kokoshibo but is unable to damage the
upper rank impressed kokoshibo lords
tsunemi's physical capabilities and
knows that they are at their peak as the
hashera is silently awestruck at the
demon's own prowess analyzing
kokushibo's attacks and seeing that each
slash is accompanied with smaller
crescent-shaped blades that change their
size randomly over time sunimi thinks to
himself that he is not surprised maturo
lost to this demon thinking that if it
was not for his inexperience he would
surely have been able to cut him down by
now tsunemi gets excited at kokushibo's
skill and the fact that he is a demon
using breaths seeing that this makes him
a much tougher opponent sunimi is
thrilled and calls kokoshibo a demon
worth killing launching a wind breathing
second form claws purifying wind sunimi
leaps forward as kokushibo deflects
anemi's attack he looks up and sees the
wind teshira about to slice down at him
and blocks the blow suddenly tsunami
goes straight for kokoshiba's neck with
genius sword maneuvering the blade with
his right foot kenya looks on in shock
at this move as the upper moon narrowly
evades the two continue to battle with
sunimi matching kokushibo blow for blow
much to the demon's delight the intense
combat begins to take its toll on sunimi
however as the windhashera finally slips
up and narrowly messes up the tip of his
swing missing death by a small margin
kenya looks on with his eyes widening in
concern and mature calls out to sunimi
who is frustrated but alright kokoshibo
reminisces over old battles and thinks
back to a fight he had with a previous
windhashera back in this in goku era and
how both of them had improved their
swordsmanship by fighting in a similar
manner suddenly launching a moon
breathing sixth form perpetual night
lonely moon kokoshibo manages to slice
sanemi's chest and even cuts off all of
the surrounding pillars in the room with
his attack genji calls out to his
brother frustrated as the rubble blocks
his view leaving him unable to see his
brother with blood spilling from his
chest tsunemi stands up straight and
finds slashes running alongside his
torso kokoshibo praises the enemy's
skill for having kept up with him for so
long but tells him that if he moves now
his organs would spill out suddenly he
tenses up as his pulse begins to race
and he is puzzled at the sun change
cinema begins to cuckle as he sees that
the effect of his rear blood even began
to work on an upper rank with a smirk he
lashes forward and attacks kokoshibo
taunting the demon for staggering as he
glows that his rare blood made demons go
drunk off the smell of it as he begins
to counter-attack in earnest the
windhashera recounts how he first
learned about the special quality of his
blood and thinks back to the night his
mother became a demon he noted that her
movements had become duller after his
blood had spilled and demised that she
had gotten drunk off the smell of it
afterwards he began to hunt demons all
on his own being unaware of the
demonstrating swords instead he relied
on his own blood to disorientate the
demons enough for him to restrain them
and then quickly burn them in the sun
the nights were difficult for him as he
had become partially blind after killing
his mother afterwards he realized that
this had been a reckless endeavor that
he tried doing and he had been
incredibly lucky to actually have gotten
through it unscathed one day while
hunting for a demon cinema ran into a
demon slayer named masachika kumano who
was also hunting the same demon this is
where sanemi learned the actual
existence of the demon slayer corps and
would join them afterwards they became
friends and even for undefeated lower
rank 1 while working together however
mazuchika was fatally wounded and the
fight against the lower rank and ended
up dying leaving tsunimi the only one to
become a hashera as a result of their
win back in the fight against kokoshibo
tsunemi unleashes a wind-breathing sixth
form black wind mountain mist which the
upper rank narrowly dodges shocked to
see sunimi being capable of fighting
kukushibo guesses that the hashera is
squeezing his muscles to prevent his
organs from spilling out and solidifying
his blood with his breaths to stem his
bleeding impressed at the hashera's
immense skill kakoshibo note that this
is a feat no ordinary human could
achieve and begins trading blows with
sunimi the windhishera keeps pushing
kukushibo back but the demon suddenly
stomps down on his blade preventing him
from moving it and then attempts to
behead sanemi flashing back to when he
first became a hashera still raw from
his sadness over the death of masachika
tsunemi recalls his ashirami teen when
they had first laid eyes on kagaya
ubiyashiki sanemi had boiled with rage
at seeing someone who was smiling while
there were people who were suffering at
the hands of demons hurling verbal abuse
at oyokata and saying he only saw the
demon slayers as pawns sunimi had
immediately earned the ire of his fellow
hashira with his disrespect gyome had
reapproached him but kagai assured the
hashera it was all right before things
could escalate further and then
addressed sanemi directly kagai told him
that he had wished to fight with their
blade himself as well but was never able
to do more than ten swings before his
pulse went wild and he would have to
stop he continued and said that if the
demon slayers were pawns then he was
nothing more than a porn who moved them
around as well kagaya continued his
response to sunimi's words and told the
winter shearer that even if he died
nothing would change as he already had
successes
oyokata said that since this was
tsunemi's first ashira meeting and that
he probably just had a misunderstanding
to treat him however he wished and he
just focused on protecting people's
lives as a hashera kagaya continued and
said that it was his fault for calling
sunimi so soon after masachika had died
as they had been as close as brothers
sanemi was dumbfounded to hear this and
that oyakata knew massachusetts actual
name
after this kane kocho told him that
kagaya had actually memorized all of the
names of every single demon slayer and
the upbringings ever since he had taken
over as the leader having been shocked
to hear so sanemi had looked in ore as
kagaya had gotten up and informed them
of massachusetts
saying that the will of most demon
slayers would be similar kakaya had
handed over komino's will to sunimi and
the boy tearfully read it and it told
him that the demon slayers would always
want their loved ones to live with their
smile and to not die unnatural deaths at
the hands of demons remember in these
moments cenemy pulls out a pistol and
blocks kokoshibo's blade with the
underside of her before firing straight
at the demon's face kukushibo defiantly
blocks the bullets with his blade and
then unleashes a moon breathing third
form lonesome moon chains tsunemi
vanishes from the range of the attack
and kokushibo exasperately says that the
demon slayers just keep on coming as he
sees gyome standing in front of him as
the stoneheshira declares that the demon
slayers have permanent until every last
demon slayer is exterminated from the
world guyama tells anemi to stitch up a
stomach wound and that he would distract
the demon to allow him to do so salemi
agrees to this and apologizes for
getting into such a state to begin with
as the stonehishera steps in to fight
the upper rank the demon notes with
excitement that gyome has refined his
body to its utmost limits saying that he
hadn't seen a warrior with this strength
in 300 years gourmet continues swinging
his flail and inhaling deeply the whole
time while kokoshibo notes that the air
is being drawn towards him finally
attacking kokoshibo with his weapon
jeremy looks on as the upper rank dodges
his attack but he quickly throws his axe
at the demon as well kokoshibo who had
been about to attack gyomay is forced to
abandon this idea and evade the axe as
well he attempts to attack again but
gyome unleashes a stone breathing second
form upper smash as kukushibo evades
this attack gomu catches him in his
chains restrained kukushibo attempts to
break free but isn't capable of damaging
guillermo's chains the stone heshira
attempts to cut off kokoshibo's head
with his axe but the demon dodges only
losing a lock of hair that is severed
kukushibo is enraged and charges at
gyome attempting to slice of his neck
but the heshira jumps out of the way at
the last second filling in his axe at
the upper rank but only managing to tear
off some of his robe continuing his
assault guyme swings his flail at
kokushibo as the demon evades yet again
however german manages to catch
kokoshibo's blade between his chains and
pulls on them shattering the blade and
the two face off with a stone breathing
fourth form volcanic rock rapid conquest
and a moon breathing second form pearl
flowers moon gazing as kokushibo's blade
finally recovers from the blow it
received he taunts gyome by saying that
no matter what damage he receives it
will all recover
in response jeremy utilizes a technique
he had been saving up for the battle
with muzan kibitsuji finally revealing
his demon slayer mark inosuke and kano
run through the infinity castle not
knowing that just around the corner from
them azinitsu and morata back at the
battle against kokoshibo maturo
struggles to dislodge himself from where
he had been pinned by the upper rank
slowly dragging the blade out of his
body with his remaining hand mature
manages to extract his blade and kneels
over in pain wincing he steams his
bleeding and assesses his situation
noting that he would not be of much use
with his current injuries and that he
would take some time to be able to stop
his bleeding as he had not been blessed
with the same physique as someone like
tengen uzui determined to do something
no matter the cost though mature
resolves to do his best to defeat
kokoshibo and aid those who are still
fighting as he grabs his blade and
begins to run over to the fight material
is distracted by genya calling out to
him to get some of the hair that had
been cut off from kokoshibo so that he
could eat it and recover as he wanted to
fight till the end to be able to help
his brother sunimi
meanwhile kukushibo and gyome face off
the demon notices gyome's demon slayer
mark and says it is a pity noting that
jeremy looked to be at least 27 years of
age he then revealed that all those who
had gotten demonstra marx had died
before they had become 25 predicting
that gyomi would die that same night
kukushibo says that everything gyome had
worked for up to this point would all go
to waste and asks kiyome if he does not
find that regrettable silently enraged
at these words jeremy tells kokushibo
that he and the other demon slayers had
been aware of this story about those
with marx or dying before reaching 25
asking what there was to regret about
his life at their points germain
declares that no one could become a
hashera with such a half-hearted
resolution and declares that kokoshibo's
words are insults to him kokoshibo
attempts to explain his views more by
saying that he meant the techniques and
body gym had worked to hone over the
years and wonders why gyome could not
understand this the stoneheshira
responds that there is nothing to
understand and that humans understood
their dignity was best preserved by
living and dying just as human beings he
rebukes kokoshibo further and tells him
to not force his pathetic world view on
others and call it the supreme one
continuing on gyome says that he had
noticed kogoshibo had lied when saying
no one with a demon slayer mark had
lived past 25. kokoshibo attempts to
deny this though but is cut off by
gyomei saying that there must have been
one exception and kokoshibo suddenly
jolts with an understanding and
remembrance satisfied by this reaction
germain deduces that his theory was
correct just as kokoshibo darts forward
towards the stone hishera to slice at
him but gyome is able to block as the
two trade blows sanemi recovers from his
wounds after having been stitched up
having also acquired a demonstra mark he
wastes no time in attacking kokoshibo in
tandem with gyome and the demon thinks
that all the hashera of the current time
are marked with the demonstrator marks
as the two ashira continue attacking in
sync the demon is surprised at their
skilled coordination well the both of
them say that they are grateful for the
fact that they trained together in the
hashera training to allow such
coordination muchura checks up on genya
and feeds him a fistful of hair from
kikushibo which instantly heals his
wounds as he begins to become more aware
of his surroundings ginyu marvels at
this new speed of recovery and remembers
that he still has a fragment of
kokoshibo's blade he can eat to gain
further strength and is comforted by
this knowledge suddenly muzan
kibitsuji's voice echoes through genya's
head as he asks kokushibo how many
pillars he has defeated before ordering
him to not let any of them pass kenya is
further impressed at the concentration
of the blood that kukushibo possesses as
the latter continues to battle with
gyome and tsunimi kokoshibo knows that
the pair of them must be among the
stronger fighters and is especially
impressed by gyomei he sees that guyme's
weapons allow him to overcome his
blindness by swinging the chains it
creates an echo that allows gymae to
judge the distance and his surroundings
by only using sound kokushibo declares
that his best course of action would be
to shatter sanemi's blade by striking it
from the side and attempts to do exactly
that however sunimi is able to react and
rotate his blade he also forces
kokoshiba's blade down onto the ground
before launching an attack right at him
in tandem with gyomei the upper rank is
impressed as sanemi slices off more
locks of his hair and that his reflexes
have actually improved since he was
first wounded by the demon fiome cuts in
close and lops off kokushibo's left ear
with his axe before sanemi performs a
wind-breathing first form dust whirlwind
cutter that the upper rank is able to
dodge working together gyome and sanemi
unleashed stone breathing first form
serpentinite bipolar and wind breathing
seventh form gale sudden gusts
respectively however it is revealed that
they are only able to rip kokoshibo's
kimono and the demon rips it off
entirely before proceeding to attack the
two pillars from afar they left shocked
by this new range and see that his sword
has extended and more blades have
suddenly branched out from it kukushibo
declares that if he is able to defeat
gyomay and sunimi then defeating
everyone else will be quite easy
suddenly shinozugawa is hit by
kokushibo's attack and loses the index
and middle fingers of his right hand
cursing his inability to react to the
demon's strike tsunemi knows that if it
were not for gyomi using his chain to
divert the trajectory of the attack he
would have lost both of his arms he also
sees that the smell of his rear blood
was beginning to lose its effect on
kokushibo realizing that he may quickly
become a burden a crow flies overhead
and kauna ubyashiki asks karai if they
should send over either geyu or tanjido
to assist the demon slayers in defeating
upper rank 1. however karaya is firm in
his beliefs that kyomei and sanemi
muchiro and genya could defeat the demon
and orders for geyu and tanjiro to
continue onwards to muzan back in the
battle kokoshibo unleashes a moon
breathing seventh floor mirror of
misfortune moonlit that sends shock
waves at the demon slayers from afar
kyomi is taken aback at the range of the
attack and kokoshibo continues to hammer
away at the hashera this time with a
moon breathing eighth floor moon dragon
ring tail that catches sunimi's ankle
and causes bleeding sunimi is frustrated
at his inability to get in close to the
demon's head having to use all of his
skill to just simply dodge his attacks
as the demon lines up another attack he
performs a moon breathing ninth form
whining moon swarfs kokoshibo causes yet
more damage to sunimi slashing his back
with the attack guyama yells out to
sunimi but the winter shira says to
forget about him as kokoshibo attempts
to finish him off with a moon breathing
tenth form drilling slashes moon through
bamboo leaves but muchiro saves sanimi
he says that he would not let saneemie
die that he was capable of wielding his
blade with both of his hands meanwhile
kenya looks on from behind a pillar
frozen in fear that he would simply be
effortlessly dispatched by kokushibo
again hasing his weakness but still
determined to keep his brother alive and
help his friends kenya stays rooted to
one spot neither making their move to
attack kokoshibo nor retreating he
suddenly remembers tanjuro's words that
it was the weakest who had the most
potential when he explained how he had
been able to turn the tide against daki
and gutado he told kenya that after a
certain number of combatants people
would always prioritize the strongest
and thus their guard would be thinner
against the perceived weaker opponents
resolving to do his best kenya takes out
a shard of kokushibo's blade ready to
swallow it and do his best to defeat the
upper ranked demon gym attempts to
perform stone breathing fifth form arcs
of justice akokushibo but is interrupted
by the latter's moon breathing 16th four
moonbow half moon the stoneheshira is
frustrated at the upper rank's
never-ending wave of techniques and
senses that the demon is too quick
picking him off exactly as he tries to
fire a technique at him pondering over
what it could be that the demon is
seeing pyoma attempts to focus and
refine his senses saying that demons are
mere transfigurations of the human form
and anything they could do a human could
manage as well saying that his eyes
could see human nature jeremy declares
that he would not be misled kukushibo
unleashes another attack for a split
second giumei to his own shock is able
to see through him and discern his poles
over with muchero though he attempts to
get in close to kukushimbo and slow him
down so that he can create an opening
for gyomay or sunimi to cut off the
demon's head jeremy notices this and
coordinates with sunimi to match
maturo's run and distract kukushibo from
three sides adjusting to mature's plan
on the fly kokoshibo sees this as an
opportunity to defeat all three of them
at once and unleashes a moon breathing
14th form catastrophe 10-man crescent
moon at all the hasheras all three
managed to dodge his attacks however and
kyome flings a juzu bead right into the
back of kokushibo's right hand shocking
the demon just enough to hold his
attacks and allow the hasheras to launch
their counter-offensive tsunemi attacks
kokushibo forcing him back and kyomek
cleaves off the demon's right shoulder
along with his right arm and muchiro
finishes off this trifecta of attacks by
stabbing kokoshibo clean through the
abdomen done kokoshibo wonders how
muchero had been able to dodge all of
his attacks while he was wounded
deducing that this would only be
possible if the child was also capable
of entering the transparent world
kokoshibo acknowledges that gyoma had
also been able to achieve such a state
in the middle of their fight and had
also taken his own eyes into account by
manipulating his blood flow to throw off
kokoshibo's attacks undeterred since the
demon says had been unable to sever his
neck despite their clever maneuver
kokoshibo plans on analyzing their
attacks to develop a counter-attack and
render them demoralised guioma and
tsunami charge at him and kokoshibo
prepares to unleash another 16th form as
genya looking demonic steps out from
behind ashira and aims his transformed
gun at the upper rank he remembers
muchura's advice to not hesitate and
says to himself that as long as he is
able to slow down the demon he is
willing to go down with him kenya fires
his gun but kokoshibo quickly diverts
his attack to block the bullets however
genye's bullets rebound off kokoshibo's
blade but swerved back to attack him on
their own shocked at this kokoshibo
looks up at genya and sees that the boy
and his gun have transformed looking way
more demonic than before
suddenly a large tree goes out of the
bullets out of the back of kokushibo
rooting him to the ground seeing that
these are blood demon art kukushibo
declares that kenya absorbed the locks
of his hair and broken bits of his sword
to acquire demon powers his attention is
diverted quickly as gyome and tsunemi
lunge at him this causes him to get
anxious and fearful and he thinks back
to the last time that he had felt so
threatened that had been almost 400
years ago back when he had faced his
younger brother yeruichi tsugikuni it
had been the night of a blood moon and
kokoshibo had encountered his younger
brother who should have been more than
80 years of age at the time this was
incredibly shocking to kakushibo as he
thought those with the demon slayer
marks did not live beyond the age of 25
yeruichi had begun to cry at the sight
of his brother and told him that it was
heart-wrenching seeing his normally
reserved and quiet brother showing some
emotion had left kokoshibo bewelded
however this lasted for only an instant
as when yoroichi grabbed his blade he
let off such an aura that kukushibo was
left stunned and afraid
as he charged yoruichi was so quick he
left a slice through his brother's neck
before he could even react seeing that
his brother had lost none of his
strength kokoshibo had been enraged and
his old feelings of jealousy and hatred
began to well up inside of him once more
kokoshibo wanted to kill yorichi but
knew that he would die with yoruichi's
next attack as even muzad kibitsuji had
been pushed to the brink when he faced
yodichi's skill however that next attack
never came as yet she died resting on
his blade but still standing on his feet
kokushibo lets out a howl and emits
crescent-shaped shockwaves from his body
they slice it all of the demon slayers
the demon suddenly grows blades from his
body and the demon slayers are all
pushed back with ginya being vertically
sliced in half though mature stubbornly
hangs on to his blade still piercing
kokoshibo's torso kyomei and tsunimi
charge it kokushibo and materio decides
that he needs to do something to kill
kukushibo so that the other pillars
would be able to save as much of this
drink for the fight against muzan
machido's grip on his blade tightens and
it suddenly starts to turn it red much
to both his and kokushibo shark the
demon suddenly stiffens up in agony as
the bright red blade sears his very
cells taking advantage of the demon's
newfound immobility tsunemi slices at
his neck and genya activates a blood
demon art from afar at the flesh bullets
still inside
and makes a tree grow out of his back
kokushibo attempts to swipe at genya but
finds that he is unable to activate his
technique and kyomei swipes at his head
with his flail kokushibo resists having
his neck cleaved off and kyomi swipes at
it from below with his axe the kokushibo
is able to keep it at bay with his blade
somehow no seen that he is unable to
activate his own blood demon art due to
the tree using up so much of his own
blood to grow itself kokoshibo looks at
machu's blade again and is reminded of
eurowichi's blade thinking back to a
conversation he had with his brother in
the past in that conversation kokoshibo
had asked his brother what his plans of
succession was as he believed there was
no one powerful enough to match them and
worried that their perfect breath
techniques would fade from the world one
day but yoruichi had responded to this
by saying that they were not as big of a
deal as he was making them out to be and
that there would come a day where there
were those who would surpass them he
continued and said that they could reach
the end of their days feeling nothing
but ease meanwhile sanemi had jumped and
swung his blade down on gyome's flail to
force it down and chop off kokoshibo's
neck suddenly both the weapons turned
bright red at these spots where they
made contact with each other and they
finally mustered up enough strength to
chop off kokushibo's neck and snap his
blade in two as this happens the demon
could only remember his brother's words
of how their children born after them
would surpass them and reach even
further heights
thinking back to the time he spoke with
yoruichi about his confidence that their
generation would be the golden age of
the demonstrator corp kokoshibo
remembers how he had been disgusted at
his brother's response he wonders what
had been so funny at the future ahead of
them that there would be demon slayers
who could surpass them kokoshibo
acknowledges the strength and the talent
of those who had been fighting him
noting how they had not let go of their
blades despite their severe injuries and
the capabilities of using blood demon
arts despite being only human continuing
on in spite of blood loss and even
managing to turn their blades red though
they were not sun breathing users
asking what had been so funny about
being able to predict such a future as
this kokoshibo says that the mere
thought of losing made him seethe with
anger resolving not to lose he manages
to stem the bleeding from the stump of
his neck much to the shock of yeome who
tells sunimi to keep attacking the demon
to finally end him and not let the
sacrifices of ginya and mochiro to be in
vain
zunimi is fired up at those words and
unleashes the wind-breathing eighth form
primary gale slash at kokushibo as gyome
follows it up with a stone breathing
fifth form arcs of justice the upper
rank manages to dodge guillermo's axe
and slices off muchero's sword hand he
attempts to pull out the boy's blade and
also remove the stump genya summon on
him kokoshibo's head slowly begins to
regenerate as he continues to evade
strikes from both gyome and sunimi much
to this shock he manages to fully regrow
a new head but is far more monstrous
than what he had looked like before
determined the hashera continue their
onslaught to defeat the upper rank and
as sunimi charges atom kakoshibo sees
the reflection of his new face and
tsunami's blade shocked and disgusted at
the ugliness of his new form the demon
remembers the words of his brother from
their childhood where he resolved to
become the strongest samurai in the
country after his own brother reflecting
on these memories kokushibo wonders if
this is the form of a samurai and if it
is truly what he had wanted suddenly the
spot near his stomach where he had been
stabbed by muchero begins to crumble
away on its own in a split second that
follows this kokoshibo is completely and
utterly shocked but guillerme and
tsunimi managed to cleave off his new
head leaving him completely unable to
use his blood demon art still unwilling
to lose though kukushibo attempts to
muster up more strength but suddenly
remembers the words of his brother from
their final fights kukushibo questions
his motives and wonders if all of this
is what he had wanted from his life and
deeds calling himself a disgrace to life
and acknowledges that all he ever wanted
to do was be like his brother yeruichi
kukushiba remembers his past with his
brother and says that those who do not
envy others are merely lucky as they
have not encountered someone who was so
strong and vivid that they scorched
everything as if they were the son he
thinks back to when they were born and
says that during their time they were
considered unlucky as twins caused
succession disputes yoruichi had been
born with a mark on his forehead which
was considered hideous and he thinks his
father had ordered for him to be killed
however upon hearing this news their
mother had been enraged to him so it was
decided that yeruichi would be sent off
to a temple when he became 10 years old
instead the brothers were kept separated
and kohushibo then michikatsu would
often see yoruichi clinging to their
mother's side and he had found his
brother to be pitiful and childish
machikatsu would sneak to yaruchi's room
when their father wasn't looking and
even made him a flute people had
believed yurichi was death as he had
never spoken a word until the age of
seven one day while practicing sword
swings in the garden majikatsu was
chilled to the bone noticing yolichi
staring at him silently from next to a
tree suddenly yeruichi spoke and asked
him if his dream was to become the
strongest samurai in the country
machikatsu was so shocked he dropped his
wooden sword and she burst into a smile
and said that he would become the second
strongest samurai however michikatsu was
merely disgusted at his brother's lack
of awareness saying that a kid who ran
with his mother every time he saw her
could never become a samurai yeruichi
began to hang around michikartsi's sword
practices and asked to be taught their
way as well sumachukatsu's trainer gave
him a small shenai with basic
instructions on how to hold the sword
and a form stance the trainer asked
yoruchi to charge him to shikatsu's
shock
she was able to shatter the trainer's
wooden sword flip him over and knock him
out unconscious and only four swift
strikes the trainer even grew swellings
the size of fists in these spots where
yoruichi had struck him yodichi lost his
desire to become a samurai as he
disliked the feeling of hitting someone
and felt horrible for it machikatsu was
greatly intrigued at his brother's
strength and tried to learn his secret
after much coaxing yerichi said that
their opponent's lungs expanded so they
just had to closely watch their bone
movement muscle contraction and blood
flow machikatsu had difficulty following
this but was able to summarise that his
brother could see through living things
he felt jealous that his brother had
such an immaculate talent to fight with
but absolutely no desire to fight as
yodouichi told him that he would rather
just fly a kite with his brother later
on mochikatsu realised that his position
with the oduichi would become reversed
and he would be the one to live in the
temple instead however that night
yodouichi came to him and told him that
their mother had passed away and that he
would be running away from their home
for good saying that he would always
cherish the flu his brother had made for
him before running off the next day
michikatsu read their mother's diary and
saw written in it that yoruci had
realised that he would become the ear
which is why he had decided to leave the
house earlier than plan he also learned
that yoruichi was aware of their
mother's illness and that she had been
suffering pains in her left side for
several years machikatsu made the
connection between her illness and
yodewichi's constant clinging to her
mother's left side whenever he saw her
and realized that his brother had in
fact been supporting their mother the
entire time crushing the page as he lost
control of his jealousy thinking back to
his past with yoruichi kokoshiba
remembers how he had begged for
yudowichi to die as the justice of the
world went amiss with his very existence
their father had sent invoice to the
temple yoda which he was supposed to be
at in the hopes of making his younger
son his ear but found that he had never
arrived there and so michikatsu had
inherited everything for a decade
afterwards he lived in peace even
getting married and having a child
however one day his military encampment
had been attacked by demons who sorted
all his troops and were about to do him
in as well
until a timely intervention from no one
other than yeruichi the moment he laid
eyes on his brother again michikartsi's
tranquil days came to an end as he saw
how much stronger you which he had
become and his jealousy and anger was
only stoked by the letter's good natured
apology for not being able to save his
subordinates
possessed by his jealousy machikatsu
abandoned his family and joined the
demonstra court he saw that youichi had
begun to teach the demon slayers how to
use sun breathing and sword techniques
none were able to reach his level and
perform them however he had to work
around this limitation instead focusing
on the strengths of each individual and
teaching them a breath style suited for
them more people began to grow marks
like yoroichi had and the power of the
demon slayers increased and even
michikatsu himself greenmark which was
the same as yodawee cheese michikatsu
was also unable to use sun breathing and
had to resort to using a derivative
which he named moon breathing anguished
by the fact that he was unable to catch
up to his brother soon the mark demon
slayers began dying in numbers as they
learned that they might shorten their
life spans in exchange for getting
stronger which signaled that the golden
age of demon slayers would soon come to
an end and that he himself had little
time left remaining actually as well
it was with these thoughts in his head
that michikatu came face to face with
muzan kibatsuji who offered to turn him
into a demon saying that with his nigh
immortality michikatsu would be able to
perfect his techniques as much as he
pleased michikatsu accepted the offer
and felt as if he had been freed from
all of his obligations this was fleeting
however as when he once again faced his
brother kokushibo was utterly outclassed
and he saw with his own eyes that his
brother had transcended the world even
muzan had been unable to lay as much as
a scratch on him and yoruichi had died
undefeated in his old age out of sheer
hate and once again coming up short
against his brother kokoshibo swiped at
yodowichi's standing corpse with his
blade slicing it into several parts
however there was one final surprise in
store for him and he saw that a bag fell
out of yoroichi's robes the one that
contained the flute he had made for him
when they were children
seeing that his brother had still
cherished their memories together
kokoshibo tears up but is also
frustrated at his brother's continued
excellence kokoshibo says that he had
been unable to forget yoroichi's face
throughout his entire life despite
wishing desperately that he would he
said that yoruichi had been like the son
and that people around him yearned for
him and to be like him but their only
option had been to fail and vanish away
recognizing that he hadn't been able to
obtain anything having abandoned
everything he had to emulate his brother
and had even been unable to wipe out his
breath staff despite killing all those
who knew its forms alongside muzan
kukushibo finally disintegrates away as
he wonders why he had even been born
asking yedowichi this question as he
finally faded away kukushibo
disintegrates away but tsunimi
shinozugawa continues to blindly charge
adam ankyomay has to stop the
windhashera telling him that the fight
is over he's shocked to say that sanemi
is in fact unconscious and had been
attacking the upper rank in that actual
state
genya still alive looks on at this scene
and weakly whispers gyome's name and the
stone ishira walks up to check on him
and is shocked that the boy is still
somehow alive he deduces that it must be
due to absorbing a demon and kenya tells
him to focus on treating muchero instead
kyomei lays saneemie next to kenya who
is relieved to see that his brother is
still alive the stonehishera heads over
to mochiro who lies lifeless on the
ground staring straight above the stone
hishera closes his eyes and says that
maturo had been valiant until the very
end and said that they owed their
victory to the efforts of both muchero
and genya yeome closes muchero's eyes
shut and says that they would continue
onwards to defeat muzan matura opens his
eyes in the afterlife and finds his
brother yuchiro tokito standing in front
of him with tears in his eyes angrily
telling him to go back he begins to well
up in materia's eyes as he is hurt that
his brother still does not praise him
for all his efforts and asks why his
brother is still bent on rejecting him
uchero responds by asking why he worked
so hard instead of running away and
mature says that it was because he could
not abandon his friends but yuvchero is
adamant and calls his brother's death a
pointless one asking if even knew why he
was born a mature retorts that his
brother had died when he was 11 and was
more pitiful than himself going on to
say that he was born to be happy mature
tells his brother how he had sad and
painful moments ever since they had been
left alone by the deaths of their family
but despite that he had managed to smile
again this was down to all the friends
he had made and all the times he had
shared with them mature says that he has
no regrets he hadn't run away from
anything and even laid his life down for
his friends and asks his brother not to
call his death a pointless one as coming
from him those words hurt more than they
would otherwise uchira apologizes for
his words and hugs his brother
meanwhile tsunemi comes in and sees
ginya disintegrating before his eyes
horrified he screams out shocking kyomei
as kenya apologizes for being a burden
and thanks him for protecting him sanemi
says that he hadn't protected him at all
as he is dying right now despite all of
his efforts but kenya responds that his
brother had tried his hardest and that
he had done enough kenya says that he
wants sunimi to be happy as he knew his
brother was the sweetest person in the
entire world tsunemi cries as genya
fully disintegrates and kyome walks up
behind him to remind him that it wasn't
fully over until they defeat muzan
kibitsuji
as word spreads of the deaths of muchero
tokito and ginyu shinozugawa tanjiro
begins to cry quickly attempting to
compose himself though he thinks of how
everyone else had to keep their feelings
in check and fought till the very end
thinking back to the letter he received
from sin judo which he'd revealed to him
that there were in fact 13 forms of the
hanukkaami kagura one more than the 12
forms he currently knew resolving to do
his best to defeat muzan regardless
tanjulo continues to run forward with
geyu meanwhile karaya realizes that they
would be unable to make it to where
muzon was in time and tamiya wouldn't be
able to hold off the demon for much
longer as he learns that the first group
of demon sailors have reached muzan's
location with the second troop also
close he immediately issues an order for
the demon slash to stand by and not
approach muzan saying that they should
further wait for the hashera to arrive
as the first troop stands in front of
the capture of flesh muzan is locked in
along with tamiyo they see that they are
unable to reach it as it is suspended
over a steep fall into the depths of the
infinity castle being suspended in a
place by outgrowths of flesh from the
capsule one of the demons says suggests
that they should slice at the
outcroppings of flesh he is interrupted
however by muzan bursting out of the
capsule where they jump the demon kills
the entire first troop in mere seconds
as karai reiterates his orders for the
troop to maintain its distance as they
would only serve as food for muzan to
recover the crow's cries are wasted
however as the entire troop has already
been killed by muzan and he also strikes
at the crow beheading it in one stroke
he says that when one lives for a
thousand years they lose the feeling of
enjoying the taste of their food but now
that he was hungry he found the taste of
his victims to be incredibly delicious
he thanks kagaya ubishiki for
unwittingly preparing this feast for him
and says that he was unaware of which of
his children led the demons they call
now but they were quite superb thinking
that he might turn the new oyukata into
a demon to replace his now dead
subordinates if they bow before him a
mouth on the palm of muzan's hand
finishes 18 and he holds up tamiyo's
severed head
orders the second troop to retreat at
once to prevent muzan from recovering
any more of his strength by eating more
people meanwhile muzan gloats etamio and
says that her medicine to cure demons
and turn them back into humans had
failed as the woman responds that this
would be the day when muzon would
finally go to hell the demon flippantly
responds that hundreds of people had
said those same words to him before but
they had yet to come true tamil tells
him to give back her husband and
children and muzan caldi looks at her
and says that in that case she could go
and join the family that she had killed
as he crushes her head in his hands
elsewhere in the infinity castle yoshido
immediately falls to the ground while
running as this happens tearing up on
the floor and gritting his teeth and
rage at tamiyo's death muzan swiftly
makes short work of the second troop as
well slicing through them all in one
move as karate orders for them to fall
back asking about giz whereabouts muzan
says that not one of them was of use to
him as he killed them and declares that
he will end the demon slayer corpse on
this night as he also smirks with an
evil expression crier ubishiki panics
and regrets the great loss of life to
all the demon slayers who had been slain
by the newly reawoken muzan blaming
himself for the failure he begins to
lose focus of what is around him and
continues to fear that he has wasted
years of effort by his predecessors and
all the demon says who had given their
lives in the fight against muzan kanata
though slaps him out of this much to
their sister kunuwai shock and yells at
him to keep himself together and issue
his next orders as the battle was still
ongoing realising his father and
forefathers had gone through all of the
same pressure coria recomposes himself
and orders for his reinforcements to be
sent to muzan's location and to focus
their power on one point to get rid of
muzan once and for all
canada heads back to her seat and kariya
thanks both his sisters for being there
to support him as they both tearfully
accept his thanks a crow announces to
the other demon slayers that muzan has
been revived and passes on karia's
orders for the other hashera together
immediately matsuri is shocked to hear
the news as obanai curses the fact that
he and mitsuri are being held back by
nike may while the others had already
slay in the upper rank even at the cost
of muchero and genye's lives matsuri is
confused at the order they have received
and wonders if that means that they
should mess up with the other hashera
and leaves nakime alone suddenly she is
whisked away by the hem of her cloak by
someone as niki may play zubiwa again
meanwhile muzan who was standing amidst
the corpses of all the demons he had
killed is suddenly teleported into a
large room with tangido and yiyu joining
him
tangier was shocked to see the demon and
his mind floods with the memories of his
family's murder nezuko is a demon and
all of his fallen comrades enraged he
grips his sword tightly and looks
fiercely at muzan but giu tells him to
calm himself down muzan begins to speak
to them again saying that they are all
persistent and that sickened him to the
bottom of his heart continuing on the
demon says that the demon slayers always
talked about avenging their families or
friends believing that instead they
themselves should just be thankful for
the fact that they had not died and
simply go back to the way that they used
to live their lives tangible was shocked
at these words and asks muzan what he is
saying as the demon compares himself to
a natural disaster saying that no one
saw vengeance on earthquakes or storms
when they killed people concluding that
the dead could not be brought back to
life and that they should all just go
back to earning their daily wages he
says that most humans do that and the
only reason that demon slayers did not
do the same was because they were a
bunch of deviants and he was sick of
dealing with deviance muzan says that he
is the only one who truly wanted the
state of affairs to come to an end as
tanjido comes to a boiling point and
says with a calm seething rage that
muzan was a being that should not be
allowed to exist
as tangelo steers down muzan the young
demon slayer notes to himself how this
is the first time he has ever felt such
sheer rage at any living being knowing
that the demon lord will not be defeated
by simply cutting off his head and that
they will have to drag him out into the
sun to truly be rid of him for good
aiming to stall muzan and buy enough
time for the other demonstrators to join
them tanjulo resolves to get any
information that could prove useful out
of the skirmish to tell the others and
make the task easier for all of them
muzan suddenly swings his tubes at both
tanchiro and giyu but the demon slayers
are able to dodge the attack muzan gazes
at his attack taking in his new form's
prowess and then unleashes even more
ferocious attacks at the demon slayers
geu just barely blocks the attack with a
water-breathing 11th form dead calm and
the water heshira notes the speed of the
attacks and also that the tubes are as
sharp as swords tanchira was entirely
unable to keep up with the attacks and
dodges them on pure instinct but still
attempts to get through the tubes closer
to muzan he manages to do so but before
he is able to attack muzan the demon
slices at him and manages to cut his eye
giu comes in close to scoop tanjiru up
and away from muzan warning the boy not
to get too close saying that muzan is
far stronger than an upper rank and that
it is best to keep their distance as
beheading mozam will have no effect
muzan asks if three hashera are really
enough to accomplish this task the count
takes geu and tanjudo by surprise as
muzan continues on saying that obanai
and mitsuri had already been killed by
his subordinate nakime as he had seen
through her eyes the demon's letters
dodge another wave of attacks from muzan
and tanjiru urges himself to not become
a burden now that he has lost an eye
attempting to use his smell to keep up
tanjuna was shocked as he finds that
muzan's attacks are so fast he's unable
to even smell them finding himself
unable to keep up his breaths tanchodo's
new blind spot gives him a harsh
reminder of the existence as he smacks
into a wall on his right side geu calls
out to the boy as muzan launches attacks
his way suddenly matsuri bursts into the
scene by breaking through the wall
behind muzan and the demon and gilu look
on in shock at the fact that she is
still alive unleashing a love breathing
sixth form cat-legged winds of love
matsuri looks on dumbfounded as muzan
shrugs off the attack with ease and
doesn't even take a scratch from it
while this happens obernai picks up
tanjuro and orders for him to fall back
instead of being a burden in which
tanjido is grateful that obanai and
matsuri are still somehow alive obani
does a double take in shock telling
tanchiro to worry about himself first
looking on muzon wonders how the
tuashira he had seen to be dead could
still be alive he yells in the kimae's
name asking what is going on and yushiro
responds to him saying that he is
controlling her right now the castle
begins to shake violently as yushiro
yells with tears in his eyes that muzan
had committed the gravest sin in the
world by killing tamio and declares that
he will wipe the demon lord from the
face of the world the hashera battle
muzan but the sight of their battle
repeatedly changes within the infinity
castle and matsuri begins to get dizzy
muzan sniles at them and they love a
share of cows and fear wishing for gyome
to arrive and aid them saying that
yoshira's plan to have them pretend to
be dead was now in shambles and that
giyu and tanjudo were in greater danger
than they had realised flashing back to
yushero explaining his plan to her
matsuri recalled how the demon told her
to cooperate with him if she wasn't an
idiot she said to herself that she
wasn't one agreed and you should have
told her to distract nakime so that he
would be able to sneak up behind her and
take control of her mind to show her a
false vision to feed muzan of all of the
hashera being dead so that they would be
able to storm him at once with him being
caught unaware masood is amazed at this
ability of his and tells him so back at
the battle with muzan the landscape
continues to rapidly change as the demon
lord identifies that yushiro is
controlling nikime he attempts to
wrestle back control of nakime's mind
from yushiro and manages to weaken the
young demons hold even beginning to
spread his cells to yeshuro's hands a
demon slayer next to ushero offers to be
eaten by the demon to strengthen him and
give him a better chance against muzan
but yushiro firstly rejects this notion
muzan's attention is suddenly brought
back to the battlefield as giyu and
aguro attack him with water-breathing
fourth form striking tide and serpent
breathing first form winding serpent
slash respectively yushira begins to
fight back while muzan is distracted and
manages to have nakime change the
battlefield again leaving muzan and the
hashera falling as he falls muzan
reaches forward and clenches his fist
destroying nakime's skull sensing that
the castle was soon collapsed yeshua
attempts to transport all of the demon
slayers out of the castle before it is
destroyed the floor reappears beneath
them all again as the demon slayers
continue to fight against muzan and
dodge his attacks tangier gets hit by
one of the attacks and his right
shoulder begins bleeding the castle
begins to creak and open eyes senses
that it will soon be destroyed noting
that if it happens then only muzan would
survive as matsuri notices that they are
all being pushed upwards muzan launches
an attack at her taking her completely
by surprise tajiro rushes forward though
to intervene and swings his blade
flinging a demon slayer's broken sword
straight into muzan's head taking the
demon by surprise and infuriating him
further the castle finally stops moving
as it bursts through the ground to the
outside flinging them all to the surface
tangier regains consciousness and sees
the night sky above him finally back at
the surface after yushiro had worked so
hard to get them all there realizing
that they were in the middle of a city
tangible panics and karaya ubyashiki
sweat while saying that they were flying
much further than he had expected he
asks his sister how long until dawn and
she tells him that there is still an
hour and a half before daybreak karia's
eyes widen at the knowledge that there's
still so much longer left acro tells the
demon slayers how much longer they have
left until dawn and taking note of the
fact tangero looks around to confirm
that his comrades are doing all right
relieved that the hashera who had been
with him are all safe tangido moves out
to find muzan suddenly the demon lord
bursts through a pile of rubble sending
it flying in all directions enraged
muzan taunts the demon slayers and dares
them to keep him there until dawn if
they can even do so he launches a wave
of attacks that the hashera all evade
and then begin to attack muzan obani
with the serpent-breathing third form
coil choke and matsuri with her love
breathing second form love pangs giu
then attacks with the water-breathing
8th form waterfall basin obino manages
to slice through muzan's neck but is
surprised to see that his blade goes
through the demon and is unable to leave
any damage he realizes that he is
regenerating the instant they damage him
at once muzan resumes his attacks on all
the hashera however he is pushed back by
the junior demon slayers who wish to
give their lives to take out muzan all
of them begin attacking him together and
quickly make an opening for those who
are able to fend off muzan giving them a
chance to survive the hashira are
horrified at the chaotic battle scene
and their subordinates being killed one
by one to protect them tanjuro struggles
for ear unable to keep fighting due to
the pain of his words muzon explains
that those who die immediately from his
attacks are fortunate for even a wound
would be fatal those who die from them
will suffer a greater pain he nods
towards tangier as the boy lies on the
ground writhing in pain with a tumor
growing out the entire right half of his
face saying that he mixes his blood into
all of his attacks muzan tells tanjiro
that he won't become a demon since the
concentration of his blood and his
attacks is too high he would be poisoned
instead destroying tangero's cells and
ending him tanjulo continues
tengan uzowi and shinjudo look on in
shock as inezuko somehow begins to run
away uzui yells after her asking where
she's going while his colleague shinjudu
reports to karai ubishiki that the girl
had begun to run away
karaya was afraid that muzan might be
influencing her but he felt his father's
hand on his shoulder the voice reassured
coria that it would be okay and all he
needed to do now was let nezuko make her
own decisions
karate ordered them not to follow her to
their initial consternation as if she
were caught by a demon they would be
able to retrieve her however he tells
them with tears in his eyes that his
father had told him it would be alright
nezuko is faster than sekonji and he
loses her just as she leaps off a cliff
after being pointed in the direction by
her father's ghostly appearance as she
lands safely sekonji is shocked to see
that tamiya's medicine to make her human
again had not worked elsewhere giu
obernai and mitsuti continue to battle
muzan who had manifested his malevolent
presence over tanjido's face the tumor
can be seen growing just above his eye
they're all struck by this but muzan
unleashes another flurry of attacks and
commends them for still being able to
move
however those with demon slayer marks
would not fall so easily
mathuri's wound flares as she is unable
to move yelling their two companions to
protect themselves muzan's outstretched
whip is suddenly cleaved off by gyomei
to matsuri's relief the stoneheshira
apologizes for being late as muzad
recognizes him as the demon who slew
kokushibo he is suddenly taken aback as
he is sliced clean down the middle from
behind by sanemi who also flings a few
bottles of oil towards the demon who
slashes them and gets drenched in the
liquid tsunemi sunemi backflips away and
lights a match midia throwing it towards
muzan setting the demon on fire muzan
cries out that tsunemi played a dirty
trick to which the hashera responded
that it's the perfect fit for the demon
saying he will grind him to smithereens
morata peeks out from the rubble at the
scene and geu notices him yelling at him
to carry tanjido to safety as the boy is
unable to move touched that giu
remembers his name morata carries
tanjido forward as the boy begins to
dream while envisioning the past tanjudo
is back at home with an axe in hand
chopping firewood but he is shocked that
he cannot smell anything tanjuno notices
he is in a home that looks similar to
his own and not actually his own
confused at the fate that has befallen
him he comes across a nearby man who is
bowing respectfully before him he
realizes this must be the swordsman of
the first breath urawichi tsukigoni
meanwhile morata is doing all he can to
resuscitate tanjiro's physical body he
was unable to find a pulse and the heart
had stopped beating back at the home
yeruichi reveals that he came to speak
about what was on his mind and he wanted
someone to listen tanjido wonders if it
involves the 13th form he says it's been
two years since they last met and he's
glad that yeruichi is doing all right
tanjuro was surprised to see this but he
also noted that sumida had grown up
since they last met he realizes that his
actions and words are those of his
ancestor sumi yoshi meaning he cannot
interact with them you know which he
states though that he is happy to see
him happy saying he is happy when he
sees other people happy and believing it
to be a blessing to be born in this
world his mother was a very religious
woman who often prayed for peace in the
world she would pray to the sun god to
shine on his ears back when he was
considered death he worried her when he
couldn't speak as a child something that
only got worse with his age his brother
machikatsu was a kind boy who always
worried for him despite garnering abuse
from his father for it even gifting him
with a handmade flute the day his mother
died yoda which you ran from the house
knowing that he was unwanted and he was
to become a priest of the temple as well
as ensuring mishikatsu would be the
rightful era he ran as far as he could
seeing the beautiful night sky but
despite running for almost an entire day
his feet never became tired soon after
due to which he came across a young girl
around his age standing alone and a
paddy when asked about what she was
doing she sadly states that her entire
family had died of a plague leaving her
the only survivor she wanted to take
some tadpoles home for company but she
remained unmoving for the rest of the
day and as the sun began to sit she
decided to release them unwilling to
separate the tadpoles from their
families hiroshi offered to take her
home with him and as she looked at his
face he saw that her eyes were dark like
obsidian the girl's name was utta and
she began living with yarawichi she was
talkative capable of speaking for almost
an entire day while he was quiet but uta
taught him how different he was to
normal people she stated she had never
met another person who could see inside
a living creature like yoruichi can this
enlightenment lead him to realize why he
always felt like an outsider but uta
cared for yodawichi greatly he
considered himself like a kite with a
cut string she grabbed it and held on
tight ten years later furuichi and yuta
had married and yusu was pregnant
expecting her first child soon yet in
which she went to get her midwife to
prepare for the birth while hoping to
return before sunset while out he
encounters an old man attempting to
cross the mountain despite being in poor
shape the man's son was wounded in
battle and yarawichi took the man to see
him for his final moments
deciding to fetch the midwife the next
day he ran home as quickly as he could
but his son had already said yet which
he found utah had been killed by a demon
along with the child inside her belly as
a shock tangier listens
she comments that even if something is
more precious than your own life others
can easily trample over it he spent 10
days absent-mindedly cradling the
corpses of his family until he demon
slayer chasing the demon had found him
he told him that he believed the two
should receive proper burials all he
ever wanted to do was live with his
family in a small house he wanted to
have the photons close together at a
distance where he could see their faces
or easily reach out and grab their hands
it would have been enough for him but
that dream would never happen he sadly
says demons exist in this beautiful
world yet which he became a demon slayer
shortly after this learning people had
been chasing demons for a long time yet
nobody had used breaths like him so he
taught them how they worked the best
swordsmen were known as the heshira and
now armed with the new breaths of flame
water wind and stone their powers
increased even further they began
killing demons like never before
yeruichi also adding his own brother had
also joined upon the deaths of his
subordinance soon after urduichi came
face to face with the originator of
demons muzan kibatsuji and he finally
understood upon meeting him that he knew
he had been born for only one purpose of
defeating that man
after crossing paths with muzan due to
which he immediately senses his violent
intent comparing it to magma erupting
from a volcano muzan instigates the
confrontation by stating his disinterest
in swordsmen that use breathing
techniques shortly after he unleashes
his attack and attempts to kill him
though yet of which he dodges the attack
he knew that even if a single strike hit
him it would be fatal by seeing through
muzan's transparent body yodewichi was
able to discern that he had a total of
seven hearts and five brains despite his
immense power yudowichi manages to
complete his sword forms and combine
them into a single attack overwhelming
muzan completely
as tanjido through sumiyoshi listens to
the story he
realizes uruichi had created the
thirteenth and final form of sun
breathing despite trying to regenerate
his body muzan becomes stunned and is
forced to hold his head in place to keep
it from falling off yeruichi realizes
that the immense amount of damage was
caused by the bright red blade that he
wielded he questions muzan on what he
believed the value of life to be only
receiving a furious glaring response
believing his words didn't reach him
yodewichi's attention is then drawn to
the young demon girl travelling with
muzan he immediately notices her eyes
staring directly at muzan not with a
look of concern but with a look of hope
as he sat there dismembered holding his
severed head before he began dealing
with her yoda which he approaches muzan
in order to finish him off however as he
walks towards him the sound of teeth
grinding grew louder until muzan's body
burst into many small pieces caught off
guard due to which he was only able to
cut about 1500 of the 1800 total bits of
flesh leaving the remaining portions to
regenerate somewhere else and escape the
girl collapses on the floor and begins
to weep while tearing out her hair and
angrily cursing that muzan should have
died she is then surprised that she
managed to survive despite seeing
muzan's name out loud yodawichi
approaches her and calms her down before
she eagerly informs him about muzan how
he was the originator of demons and
would most likely never appear before
yeruiji again he asked for her
compliance in defeating muzan to what
she agrees and allows her to escape she
introduces herself as tamiya to yoruichi
something that tanjiro is surprised
there after his interactions with the
demons yodewichi is approached by the
demon slayers whom inform him that his
brother michikatsu had become a demon
once they return to the estate he's
angrily confronted by the rest of the
swordsman for failing to kill muzan for
letting tamiya escape and for
michikatsu's transformation into a demon
as a result he was banished from the
dmsa corps and was demanded to commit
sega poo but the newly assigned oyukasa
would not allow it to happen after
telling sumi yoshi the end of his story
yoda which he reveals his thoughts of
being born with a gift to defeat muzan
but his failure to do so and that
because of his mistake many more people
would begin to perish at the hands of
muzan telling him it pains him
distraught by his inability to comfort
his friend for going through so much
sumi yoshi sits beside yarawichi in
silence until summerday slowly walks
towards the swordsman she tugs softly on
his clothes and says hug surprised by
the child's sudden demand sumiyoshi asks
if his guest would mind carrying her to
make her happy without her response
yodawichi picks up the girl and lifts
her up into the air the little girl
squeals with the delight of happiness
causing youichi to emotionally break
down and his eyes fill with tears soon
after suyuko returns from gathering
chestnuts in the forest and discovers
yodawichi weeping as he hugs the little
girl suyaku comes forth to comfort
yoruichi saying she'll treat him to a
warm meal back in reality as tanjudo
sleeps he wishes that yoruichi's heart
would find any form of peace after
hearing everything that the man had to
go through after a series of attacks
from muzan gyomi comments on how he
appears to be getting faster so fast
that matsuri barely manages to dodge his
attacks on pure intuition and luck
performance so they can land an attack
she realizes that she is getting dragged
down by one of muzan's arms another
attack from him manages to slice off
some of the hashera's right cheek and
injure the shoulder of her right arm
overnight jumps to rescue her and with
the help of sunimi geyu and gyome
holding museum back he is able to carry
her to another demon slayer he commands
the slayer to find yushiro to treat her
injuries and the slayer agrees however
matsuri insists on fighting but obanite
doesn't allow her as he leaves her she
pleads for him not to die
as he's running obernai contemplates the
number of people that have had to die or
because of the existence of demons at
first he wishes that he and matsuri had
met under normal circumstances but takes
it back saying that he would rather die
and claims himself of the filthy
bloodline he carries within him his
bandages fall behind him as he's running
to reveal the slits across his cheek in
a flashback it is revealed that his
family stole and lived a luxurious life
from it obani was the first male born
into the clan in over 370 years and was
confined to a cell because of this he
would have died earlier if it wasn't for
his different colored eyes as the demon
living there with the lower body of a
serpent decided that he should grow to a
more satisfying size before she'd eat
him she was also the one who ordered the
other females of the clan to cut the
sides of his mouth to resemble her as
obanai was trying to get away kaburamaru
his snake friend head straight inside
the cell before their escape using a
hairpin urbanized slowly cut away at the
wooden cage and they were able to slip
out soon after because of him the
serpent demon killed everyone else in
the clan and tried to kill open eye but
shinjuro the flame hashira of the time
katu head off saving obanai and his
female cousin by becoming a demon slayer
he felt as though he could become a
better person even though the souls of
the dead family members always dragged
him down
overnight re states that he would like
to die by killing muzan to purify his
blood and hopes to meet matsuri again
and another life one without demons
saying that if he and her are ever
reincarnated into humans he'll confess
his love to her nezuko continues to run
towards the location of the fight as the
group of kokushi attempt to keep the
sight of the battle clear of civilians
and redirect all approaching people to
safety they tell them that there are
rescue teams set by the local policemen
another group of kokushi examine the
rubble of the buildings destroyed by
muzan's attacks and find that no one has
been harmed due to the damage except for
a cat trapped in the rubble after
throwing the cat it ran off to the
battlefield with a bag strapped to its
back this cat was no one other than
tamios over at the fights obernai and
sunimi battled muzan at close courses
and opener chopped off one of muzan's
arms cleverly kicking this away as he
severed it to prevent the demon from
regenerating immediately muzan notes the
strategy as well but is unconcerned
saying that the extra time the demon
slayer has brought is but a blank muzan
attacks obanai with his whip and the
hashira rules all the energy is having
to waste just to avoid the mouth of the
werp he assuredly thinks that he will
only allow himself to faint one second
after dawn as every second is precious
and has been brought with the lives of
all of the members of the demon slayer
core geyu begins to weaken as a result
of the venom he has received from all of
muzan's attacks and disorders whipped
away from him by one of muzan's attacks
obernai and gyome intervened slicing the
creature with sunimi grabbing his sword
and throwing it near the water shera and
yelling at him to focus or else he will
kill him himself geu gratefully grabs
the sword and performs the
water-breathing third form flowing dance
resolving not to back down and keep
fighting until the very end
muzan admits that they are more
resilient than he had expected but is
unconcerned as it is only a matter of
time before his venom kills them all
long before dawn the hashera continue to
struggle against muzan as the poison
continues to weaken them until suddenly
tamiya's cat jumps onto the scene and
injects its cargo vials of antidote to
muzan's poison it manages to file all
the vials at the hashera and they
immediately begin to inject the
antidotes into them as this happens
muzan slices the cat into pieces tsunemi
smiles as he notices his tumors
disappear and guillerme also notices his
frenzy pulse and constant pain vanishes
the heshiera are able to fight with more
ease again which sunimi is thankful for
gourmet notes that it is possibly just a
temporary cure for the symptoms but that
they are fortunate for such an event to
actually happen muzan quickly deduces
what had happened and realizes tamiya
had done it cursing her for being a
thorn in his side even in death with
immense fury he launches a frenzied
attack that creates multiple craters in
the landscape ahead of him the heshira
all barely managed to dodge the attack
with obanai wistfully thinking to
himself how his contribution has been
the lowest wishing he could land more
crucial blows thinking that when one's
life is in danger one is able to exert
explosive strength he reflects back on
how before he had never lifted anything
heavier than a pair of chopsticks and
his biggest task was escaping a prison
cell he couldn't believe it himself when
he had successfully done so and thought
of what machiero did in his final part
against kokushibo by changing the colour
of his sword according to the crows all
he would have been able to do was grip
his sword tightly saying he had been
shocked when he heard about it and at
first believed it had changed colour due
to a rise in temperature however now he
realized that to obtain a bright red
blade he would have to grip his sword
with all his might and grit his teeth he
put all his strength into gripping his
sword and it slowly began to shift from
its usual colour to a bright red obino
reflects on how he saw stars in his
peripheral vision when he saw the bright
red blade and realized he had made a
mistake recognising that he had been too
fixated on tightening his grip on his
sword and gaining the bright red blade
to the point he had almost passed out
due to lack of oxygen he is brought back
to earth with a yell from sunimi who
warns him to watch out as muzan launches
an attack his way noting that even if
one of them falls it will increase the
burden on the others obani tries to
stand up and fight willing himself to
make out for matsuri's absence however
he has lost feeling in all parts of his
body except for his sword hand guillo
attempts to intercept muzan's attacks
but he isn't able to outpace the demon's
blow suddenly he looks up and sees
obanite in the air having somehow
successfully dodged the attack muzan
sees this and attempts to attack him in
media but is shocked to see the servant
hashera dodge easily again further
surprised at his right arm and whoops
being cut off seemingly from nowhere
muzan notices that there is an odd kind
of cut that could not have been made by
the weapons of those that he is fighting
muzan forcibly regrows his severed limbs
with a delay then resumes his attack to
stop gyome and tsunemi from getting in
too close his further surprise is his
left arm is chopped off as a result of a
similarly mysterious cart muzan deduces
that it has to be from a blade with
jagged edges and realizes that someone
else is present who is also aiming to
destroy him quickly assessing the new
threat muzan analyzes his surroundings
saying that even if a spell from
tamiya's demon could make someone
invisible it could not erase their
traces of existence
though he is unable to see any
silhouettes through the dust clouds
muzan is still able to hear the air
passing in some areas deducing that
there are three hidden attackers around
him he slices at their approximate
locations and is able to land a hit on
all three of them enosuke kano and
zunitsu suddenly pop into view as
muzan's attack slice off the seals on
their heads they are taken aback and how
quickly he was able to find them out but
kyomi is pleasantly surprised to see
that they are all still alive inosuke
boasts that he won't die and that he has
plenty of seals to spare muzan
unceremoniously interrupts enosuke's
monologue and swipes at him with a whip
but his attention is drawn back to
himself mid-attack as obanise slices off
both of his arms he is displeased at the
time it takes to regrow from these
attacks by a bright red blade and sunimi
is heartened as he notes this fact to
his companions kano and zunitsu
hurriedly put on new seals and attack
muzam with flower-breathing fourth form
crimson hanago moro and thunder
breathing first form thunderclap and
flash enraged muzan calls them a bunch
of pesky flies saying that they have
nothing but pitiful tricks but he is
interrupted by obanai who attacks him
with serpent breathing third form coil
choke while this happens guyme thinks to
himself that this addition to their
numbers and obinna manifesting a bright
red blade has helped them and it also
allows him to concentrate more the stone
hishera clangs his weapons together and
upon impact both of them change colour
to a bright red he swings at muzan and
knocks off his entire left shoulder
exposing his spine the demon pauses and
sunimi yells giul to prepare himself as
he swings his blade at gehus turning
both of their weapons bright red as well
a crow arrives overhead and announces
that dawn will break in one hour and
three minutes with this sunimi declares
that there is no problem as they will
chop muzan into pieces yushiro injects
tanjuro multiple times with the antidote
to muzan's poison made by tamiyo in an
attempt to rejuvenate him the demon
slayers around him ask if injecting
tangero so many times is safe for him he
quietens them and says that his
condition has been worsening since muzan
struck him the demon slayers try to free
tanjiro's katana from his hands but he
has a very tight grip on it so they fail
yoshiro takes this as a sign that
tanjuro still has the will to fight and
suddenly the demons they are holding
tangero's head yells out saying that he
had felt his pulse return they attempt
to wake him up and when one of them
mentions that muzan might get away they
are all left completely stunned as
tanjiru's katana begins to creak as his
grip on it tightens considerably and he
jolts back awake back at the fight with
muzan akakushi hidden out of sight peers
over to see how things are faring and
gets hoped that they might hold out
until dawn gomez cleaves off the left
half of muzan's torso and sunimi rushes
over to a pile of seals on the ground
and puts one on his forehead as soon as
he put it on he could see kanoa zinetsu
and inosuke as inosuke declared that he
wanted a bright red blade like the
hashera tsunemi launches the
wind-breathing seventh form gale sudden
gusts towards muzan guyama is relieved
at the arrival of the new fighters as it
allows him to concentrate more looking
into the transparent world he sees that
muzan has multiple hearts and brains and
thus will not die if they chop his head
off he also knows that they move around
his entire body making it difficult to
actually strike them an idea suddenly
strikes him believing that if the others
could also see muzan in the transparent
world they will be able to strike the
organs simultaneously and destroy muzan
for good he calls out to the others to
look closely at muzan's body and see if
their vision changes and if they can see
through him for an instant obani is able
to do so and is shocked at the sides he
doesn't have long to ponder this idea
however as muzan launches a devastating
attack in all directions and crushes
everything around him flinging everyone
into their surroundings the kikushi is
shocked at the sound and looks over
again to see what had happened and is
dumbfounded as he sees muzan standing on
his own and the surrounding area having
sustained heavy damage looking right
next to him he is even more baffled as
he sees gyomayn knocked into the
building he is hiding behind and that he
had lost his leg his horror only grows
as he sees sunimi has been flung into
the upper story of a tall building while
obani zenitsu and inosuke are all
unconscious in the rubble and geru's
sword arm has been severed kano's sword
falls to pieces as her seal falls off
and she falls to her knees with muzan
right in front of her she tries to urge
yourself to stand up and attack him but
she can only stare transfixed at him in
fear and shock the kakushi rushes from
his hiding place to attack butanjiro
interrupts muzan's attack with the
hanokami kagura beneficient radiance
cutting off muzan's arm the remaining
stump of flesh sizzles muzan looks at it
in concern as it does not grow back
immediately while tanjiru apologizes to
kanoa for being late handing her off to
the kikushi he turns to face muzan as he
says that the boy looks positively awful
and taunts him by saying that in his
current condition it is difficult to
tell who the demon is between the two of
them as he gazes at the boy muzan is
reminded of yarawichi and says that he
makes his skin crawl and tangero
challenges muzan saying that they should
finish it all tangido thought about how
his understanding drastically changed
after seeing the proper forms of the
hanokamikagera with his own eyes he
noticed wasted movements and the
variation of the angle of his wrists
differences in footwork and the
intervals between breaths he said that
yoruichi was a quiet and simple person
and when suyaku asked him to show her
the different forms he obliged sumiyoshi
made sure to memorize all of them
searing them into his memory left
breathless by the beauty of the
movements when he finished demonstrating
suyako and their children were
overflowing with excitement and yet a
week she bowed his head an embarrassment
sumiyoshi asked yoroichi to come back
someday but when they parted the demons
they gave his hanafuda earrings to
sumiyoshi who realised that this meant
he would never see his friend again this
brought tears to his eyes and he yelled
out to youichi as he left that they were
grateful for him for saving their lives
and they would continue on his legacy
shouting that yodowichi's life was not
without value and that he shouldn't feel
as if he hadn't accomplished anything
sumioshi said he would pass down the sun
breathing and the earrings to his future
generations hearing all of this you know
which he turns around and thanks
sumiyoshi with a beaming smile in the
prison tangero stands in front of muzan
and thanks youichi for his actions
including sparing tamio whose own works
had aided the demon slayers and fighting
the demon and for showing his son
breathing with which tanjido could
assuredly defeat mu's arm he thinks to
himself at how he had pondered over what
their thirteenth form could be and how
he noticed the first and twelfth form
had similar names recalling that his
father had told him that if he learned
to breathe properly then he would be
able to dance forever saying that his
suspicions had been confirmed when he
saw muzan's current state that
performing all 12 forms sequentially
would complete a ring that would result
in the 13th form tangier plans to attack
muzan by connecting all forms together
and continue to strike his brain and
heart until dawn realizing the gravity
of his task tangero understands how
someone such as the flame heshira who
spoke with yodowichi about his fight
with muzan could lose confidence
believing that he doesn't have yoruichi
or even his own father's skill and
unsure on how he would prevent muzan
from escaping as he did against yoruichi
he asks how he can do something even the
great sun breather couldn't do sterling
himself tundra resolves to try his best
rallying himself to keep his heart
burning he charges that muzan who begins
to rapidly attack him as he uses the sun
breathing seeing tajiri's attacks remind
muzan of yoruichi and he cries out that
he is a ghost he slashes around so
violently that the ground around them
cracks into pieces and he lands a hit on
tanchiro who is pushed back
meanwhile tangero notices how muzon had
been able to defeat everyone else he had
nine whips growing out from his back in
addition to his own two arms and he also
had eight even faster whips that grew
out of his thighs realizing that since
the demon could change shape he needs to
stop thinking of muzan as having a fixed
form to avoid being taken by surprise
tanju attempts to combine all the forms
to perform the 13th form by using the
sun breathing dance and raging sun but
is thoughted midway during the firewheel
and pushed back yet again unphased
tangero says that he will connect all
their forms as that's how they were
designed to be and resolves to succeed
muzan notes that living creatures are
able to tap into reserves of strengths
that they are not aware of to escape
death and looks on to see tanjiro doing
the same in an attempt to connect all 12
forms of the sun breathing he sees that
tanjuro has turned his blade bright red
just as the other hashera had but is
unconcerned as he says that the demon
slayer's attacks are nowhere near as
powerful as those of yoroichi's as the
young demon slayer connects the sun
breathing dragon sun halo head dance and
firewheel he successfully manages to
connect six of the forms however muzan's
organs keep moving within his body
preventing him from attacking his torso
beginning to feel fatigued tangelo
heaves and slows down but he keeps
telling himself to focus on one second
at a time while connects the sun
breathing fake rainbow and burning bone
summer muzan notices that tanjiru's
attacks begin to lose their accuracy and
surmises that he will soon lose his red
blade as well saying that he is yet
another swordsman who will never live up
to yarawichi nor reproduce the
terrifying technique that the old
swordsman had used against him launching
another attack towards tanjiro muzan
manages to connect and knock the boy
back tangero coughs up blood and muzan
whips at him yet again barely managing
to evade it swiftly regaining his
footing tangerine resumes his task of
connecting together all forms of the sun
breathing this puzzles muzan as he
wonders why he is struggling so much
against one weak and wounded human being
who has grown weaker by the second
deducing that he himself is also going
slower as a one-on-one fight wouldn't
have lasted so long muzan suspects it is
an after effect of the antidote injected
into him by tamiyo resolving to ask her
himself as he had absorbed herselves
muzan seeks out her remaining presence
and his subconsciousness finding the
remnants of the demon within him as a
severed head moves in holds it in his
palm and asks her what she had done as
he believed the drug had only made
demons human again tamiya's head
reaffirms this but she smiles evilly and
says that she won't tell him what else
it does as that would be something his
multiple brain should figure out enraged
muzan crushes the ruminants of tamiu's
head within his hands and tries an
alternative method to figure out what
had been done to him by reading the
memories lying in her remaining cells
muzan dives through her memories and
finds one of her in a lab with yushiro
and shinobu recognizing shinobu as the
poison user who had fought doma muzan
watches as she suggests that they mix in
two poisons instead of one under the
assumption that he could withstand one
of them with the first poison being the
antidote to turn demons into humans and
the second one being an aging potion
tamiyo had concocted to make its victims
older by 50 years every minute suddenly
realizing that he had been struggling
against the hashera and tanjuro because
his body had been diverting strength to
combat against his aging muzon attempts
to calculate how much he had aged noting
that it had been almost five hours since
tamiya had injected him with the drug
and the aging potion had only begun to
take effect three hours ago muzan is
shocked as he realizes that he is aged
by at least nine thousand years over the
whole battle recognizing that he should
have noticed this earlier when his color
did not return to his hair muzan juix's
head to the side as he hears a crow
announced that there are 59 minutes
until dawn tangero keeps continuing by
using sun breathing solar heat haze
beneficient radiance clear blue sky fire
wheel raging sun and flame dance yelling
at tangible to stop jumping around muzan
attempts to attack the young demon
slayer again with renewed ferocity but
tajiro dodges his attacks with sun
breathing fake rainbow and follows that
up with dance setting sun transformation
burning bones summer sun dragon sun halo
head dance and sunflower thrust with
that he successfully connected all 12
forms of the sun breathing and with a
new renewed hope he determines to keep
doing so until daybreak even with
greater speed and accuracy yushiro and
some of their demon slayers make their
way towards chachumaru's mangled body
and the demon reattaches the cat's head
to its body cradling it in his arms as
it recovers the accompanying demon
slayers are taken aback at this and ask
yushiro if chachumaru is also a demon
and he replies in the affirmative saying
that he and tamiya had turned it into a
demon shortly before the battle yushiro
snaps at the pier to stop dwardling and
tend to the injured they run off with
vials of tamiya's anti-muzan serum and
get to inosuke kano and zinetsu walking
over to gyome yushiro assesses the
damage on the hashera and notes that he
has lost a lot of blood in addition to
his leg tying up the wound to stem the
bleeding yshira begins to worry as he
declares that gyome is in no position to
fight even if he does regain
consciousness in time as the blood loss
and lack of equilibrium will hinder him
too much within over 50 minutes left
till sunrise he thinks of tamion asks
her to help tanjiro in his battle with
muzan saying there is no way the boy can
last this long on his own meanwhile
tanjunu continues to connect the
different forms of the sun breathing to
defeat mozarne as he matches blows with
a demon his left sleeve is ripped off
and he dodges back to avoid the attacks
seeing that it is not enough to merely
connect the forms tanjido realizes he
must accurately target all of muzan's
hearts and brains to effectively use the
13th form however just as he attempts to
see through muzan to be able to do so he
almost blacks out due to lack of oxygen
shocked at this tangiero quickly
attempts to regain his bearings and
sniff muzon out instead but slips and is
almost hit in an attack from the demon
before obanai intervenes and scoops him
out of harm's way quickly dodging all of
muzan's attacks obani successfully
carries tangero out of danger with the
demon left angrily exclaiming at their
constant resistance asking why wouldn't
they just die already tanjuro's vision
clears up and is able to see his rescuer
and he is overjoyed to recognize the
striped hairy of obanai this quickly
transforms into horror though as he sees
that the serpent hashera's face has been
mutilated with slashes across his face
and through his eyes morsified tanjiru
asks obani if he was injured while
saving him but the hashera hastily
explains that it was during muzan's
attack from before which had knocked out
all of the hashera continuing to dodge
attacks from mozan obanai tells tanjiro
to quit worrying about the others as the
boy offers to help out and says the
vision impairment will not affect him
greatly as one of his eyes has always
been weak and that he has a snake friend
kabul ramaru confirming that tangero has
recovered oberner lets go of the boy and
quickly engages in battle with muzan who
would jump towards them with great fury
and tackles him one-on-one to tanjuro's
shock with kabul romaru's aid obernai
dodges all of the demon's attacks as the
surrounding building is destroyed and
tangible rushes to use sun breathing
again to help split muzan's attention
muzan notices that the snake is relaying
information to obanai which is allowing
the hashera to dodge his attacks and is
infuriated that such a simple animal is
able to read through his attacks tangero
and obinna match muzan's attacks in
tandem and the demon is further annoyed
at being unable to kill such seriously
wounded humans realizing that it is due
to the aging potion continuing to evade
muzan's blows tangier sees that the
demon has gradually gotten weaker but is
barely hanging on himself trying his
best to avoid oxygen deprivation
resolving to help obani who has helped
him so much already tangier was shocked
to see muzan's body begin to change
color as old scars appear all over it
realizing that these were the wounds
yoda which he gave muzan so long ago
which the demon was never able to
recover from seeing that the demon had
been burned at the cellular level and
that the wounds were his weak spots
tanjudo says that yoruichi was still
showing them the way muzan kibitsuji
reminisces over when he first saw
yuruichi recalling how he had first
thought the swordsman to be weak as he
exuded no drive or desire to fight muzan
or any hatred towards him he had never
expected yarawichi would be able to cut
off his head and wound him in such a way
that his body right down to the cells
would continue to herd as if being hit
with sunlight continuing muzan says it
was entirely out of the blue and no one
could have expected it and that yoruichi
had been the real monster instead of him
town to do rallies himself to take
advantage of muzan's grown exhaustion
and newfound weak spots noticing that
these scars were all moving across the
demon's body tanjuro concludes that they
all mark his heart and brains and now
even though he cannot see through muzan
anymore due to lack of oxygen he can
still locate his organs and target them
trying to figure out a way to hope obani
overcome his visual impairment tangita
decides to give the hashera one of
yushiro's seals and suddenly a crow
announces that there are 40 minutes left
until dawn upon hearing this muzan
immediately dashes away leaving the
battle in an attempt to secure himself
away from sunlight tangero quickly yells
this out to obanai who remembers that
muzan is not like a human who would act
on emotion and that he would cling to
his life first and foremost muzan begins
to further the distance between himself
and the demon slayers much to tangido's
frustration and suddenly passes through
a crowd of demon slayer corpses
trampling on them in his way this
frustrates tanjuro who reaches the
corpses and begins throwing all their
swords straight at muzan who quickly
slices through all of them with great
concern as passing attacks would be far
worse for him than slashes in his
current state the demon comes to an
abrupt halt as oberney drops from above
and stabs him through the top of his
chest jumping away just before muzan's
whips can swipe at him tangier slices at
the whips with sun breathing to ensure
overnight safety but has to throw away
yushiro's seals while defending from
muzan's ferocious attacks he yells at
overnight to jump to his right to grab
them but is relieved as kaburamaru
snatches them out of the air and obani
takes them from him and wears one being
able to see better than before obernai
begins to more effectively attack muzan
who begins to pant realizing that his
strength will soon give way muzan
becomes truly concerned as far away
nezuko reaches the outskirts of the town
where the battle is going on with one of
her eyes having gone back to the way
they were when she was human nezuko
slowly makes her way panting towards the
town where the battle with muzan is
underway suddenly she flashes back to
her memory of muzan's attacks on the
kamado family after he had attacked all
of the members of the family and seen
that they had all apparently died due to
his attacks the demon notes that even
with a small dose of his blood he had
kept in his attacks none of them had
been able to become demons saying that
it would be difficult for him to make a
demon who could withstand the sun
muzan left the kamado house unaware that
nezuko had survived more memories flood
into niziko's mind as she sees the
visions of the people and events she and
her brother tanjuro had encountered
during their journey including geyu
zakonji yushiro zenitsu and inosuke she
collapses to the ground unable to keep
walking and more memories flash through
her brain of the hashera meeting and
tanemy attempting to lure her in to
attacking him for his blood and finally
her memory of kagaya she remembers the
time at the butterfly mansion and
meeting its residents including shinobu
who during her stay once offered to give
her a closer look at the goldfish next
to her nezuko thinks back to the
adventures with kyogiro tengen and their
time at the swordsman village finding
her footing niziko stands up with her
hand transforming back to her human hand
as she gets up with another memory of
her brother's hand as he told her that
he would save her no matter what nesico
holds her head sweating and grunting
profusely as she turns back into a human
declaring that she is nezuko kamado
whose family was killed by a demon
meanwhile the battle of muzan rages on
as the demon rules the fact that he has
still been unable to finish off tanjudo
sensing that the other hashera are
slowly reviving muzan curses the demon
slayer core saying that they are like
linked beads of roziri which had always
been there trying to end him akron
announces that there are 35 minutes left
until dawn and upon hearing this he
attempts to split himself into several
pieces the way he had done in his fight
with yoruichi tanjiro recognizes this
technique and realizes what muzan is
about to do calling out to obanai
telling him muzan's plan secretly
worried that if the demon successfully
managed to split himself then they would
be unable to stop him however muzan
finds that he is unable to do so and
quickly realizes that this is yet
another side effect of tamio's medicine
he's shocked yet again as he suddenly
coughs up blood and tamiya tells him
that there were four ingredients to the
medicine and that when the first three
had weakened him the fourth would take
effect the fourth being the destruction
of muzan's cells with tamiy hussein and
muzan's head with an eerily menacing
grin that the death he hated so much
throughout his life was now terrifyingly
near the apparition of tamiyu inside
muzan's head tells him that there is no
need for them to be stronger than him to
kill him she says that just as he would
do anything to survive then they who had
suffered at his hands would do anything
to kill him muzan notes that in regular
circumstances he would not be concerned
at the bright red blades of demon
slayers as they were all weaker than the
bright red blade of yarawichi and their
regeneration would not be so exhausting
for him he curses the medicine injected
into him by tamiyo as they now render
him susceptible to such exhaustion and
make the attacks of the demonstrators
far more potent than they normally would
be realizing the poison is different
from the one used on doma muza notes
that it will take some time for him to
analyze the compound and counteracts it
suddenly he freezes and stands still
looking at the sky
for a moment tanjuro believes that the
demon has finally start to get exhausted
and that tamiya's medicine is finally
taking effect he and obanite attempt to
capitalize on this opportunity and
attack muzan but a giant shock wave with
lightning erupts out of the demon's body
and strikes everything in close vicinity
to muzan huge jaws erupt from muzan's
torso and run along it diagonally to his
back as he bears fangs and glares at the
destruction he has caused with oberner
left stunned and unable to move and
tangero also experiencing seizures
meanwhile karaya kanata and kuwana also
receive damage from the attack due to
the kasugai crow being instantly killed
in the blast seeing this tengan and
shinjudu rush to their aid karaya
bleeding from the nose hastily says that
he is fine and asks if tanjudo and obani
are doing all right shinjuru wonders if
muzan somehow sensed the location to be
able to cause damage kunai announces
that there are 25 minutes left until
dawn and korya asks the demon slayers to
hang in there and that a final victory
over muzan is within their grasp tanju
is still unable to get up and wonders if
his lungs were damaged in the attack
seeing muzan walk away in anguish
however the demon stops in his tracks as
inosuke jumps in front of him saying
that muzan had really done it now and
that he wouldn't stand for it any longer
enraged muzan attacks inosuke with
tanjiru calling out for him but he is
only able to weakly flail his whips
about pantene muzan realizes that he has
become too tired after using this shock
wave as inosuke huffing and wheezing
himself says that kyoma had lost his leg
trying to protect them and that giulio
has lost his arm continuing he tells the
demon that he had taken the lives of the
other demon slayers he had shared meals
with and henosuke demands that he give
them all their lives back and carefully
says that if he couldn't then he would
pay for it with a million deaths muzan
launches an attack arinosuke who manages
to jump right out of the way but just as
he lands muzan sends his right arm whips
into the ground to catch inosuke from
below managing to ensnare the demon
slayer tanjudo attempts to get up and
help his friend but is unable to and
says that he will die first suddenly
enosuke is saved by zanetsu who slices
through muzan's arm whip and says that
tanjido is still alive as he can hear
his heartbeat yelling at tantido to
continue fighting and to stay alive
zenichi tries to bolster his spirits and
tell him not to die so that niziko could
become human again and they could go
back to the house they used to live in
muzan smacks zanetsu into the building
benignoscope quickly slices his whip to
prevent any further damage the demon is
infuriated and attacks inosuke as well
with tangero desperate to help his
friends through his fights deducing that
it could be a blood demon art affecting
his nervous system tangero attempts to
undo it by stabbing himself in a
non-vital area with his mature and sword
the blade sizzles as it enters his body
and tangent appraised that it stops the
shaking enough for him to help out in
the fight adeshev muzan looks on as
inetsu and inosuke recover and know that
he is unable to raise its arms anymore
as both giu and kyomay make their way to
the battlefield to resume their fight
with him stopping at nothing to finally
kill muzan once and for all everyone
prays for the success of those fighting
muzan as inosuke and zanetsu continue to
attempt to hold the demon back inosuke
performs his beast breathing fourth fang
slice and dice to chop off some of
muzan's whips ezenitso follows it up
with a thunder breathing first form
thunderclap and flash god speed zinetsu
notes that he is losing his strength and
he would only be able to muster one more
attack with his full strength and
unleashes a thunder breathing seventh
form honokazuchi nokami but it only
produces a shallow cut and muzan seeing
that only a bright red blade could deal
sufficient damage to muzan zenitsu falls
to the ground and muzan slashes adam
inosuke intercepts this attack with his
beast breathing fifth fang crazy cutting
following it up with his third fang
devourer in rapid succession
musan is enraged and unleashes a weaker
shockwave from the mouth on his torso
that flings inosuke back before muzan is
able to do anything else however kanjuru
intervenes and performs the sun
breathing burning bones summer sun and
rapidly performing the raging sun fire
wheel beneficent radiance and dragon sun
halo head dance noting that muza needs
to allow his shock waves to charge
before using them tangier attempts to
use more of his sun breeding technique
but coughs up blood before he can attack
and is bailed out from muzan's
counter-attack by inosuke who uses a
beast-breathing sixth fang palaside bite
which allows tanjuro to unleash the sun
breathing dance clear blue sky and fake
rainbow zenitsu remembers his mentor
jigoro and asks him to give him the kick
he needs performing another thunder
breathing first form thunderclap and
flash sinitu attacks muzan but is
aggravated by the fact that he is too
slow azinosuke and tanjudo continue
their combined onslaught on muzan with
their respective sun breathing dance and
beast breathing fifth fang crazy cutting
in oscar gets a knocked back but
tangible is able to continue attacking
muzan with his sun breathing setting sun
transformation and dragon sun halo head
dance with some help from zinitsu who
takes a blow intended for tanjiro to
allow his friend to continue attacking
tanjuno manages to perform successive
forms of the sun-breathing dragon sun
halo head dance and raging sun to pin
mouse onto a wall with the sun breathing
sunflower thrust he is unable to perform
more techniques as the mouth of muzan's
chest attempts to take his blade
suddenly matsuri grabs muzan's left arm
and rips it clean off his body and anger
sacrificing her own arms in the process
senemie appears and quickly chops off
muzan's right arms as well with the wind
breathing eighth form primary gale slash
undaunted muzon opens wide his mouth
from his torso to the top of his head
and tries to eat tanjuro with it however
urbanized steps in and takes the bite
instead protecting tanjuro as dawn
begins to break the sun begins to rise
as muzan kibitsuji is horrified at the
sight of it he unleashes another shock
wave and blows oberner and sunimi away
however tanjuro holds on but loses his
entire left arm resolving to keep
holding muzan down tanjido attempts to
tighten his grip on his sword and make
it go bright red but is unable to do so
suddenly geyu tomioka appears behind him
and also grabs his blade to help keep
muzan pinned down with both demon
slayers holding on to the blade with
their combined might it turns the blade
red and muzan instantly starts to cough
up blood as the sun rises steadily the
demon quickly attempts to think of a way
to avoid disintegrating muzan attempts
to cover himself in a wall of flesh to
block the sunlight from hitting his skin
and transforms into a giant baby
as the flesh grows outward and begins to
swallow up tanjuro he throws his head
back to headbutt gear you out of the
flesh's growth and he gets slowed into
it alongside his blade as the water
heshira yells out to him muzan attempts
to crawl away from the scene into some
shade and karai ubishiki orders the
remaining members of the demon slayer
corps to do everything they could to
hinder him some lower ranking demon
slayers the right bookcase on top of
muzan's head from my building slowing
him down but he still crawls forward a
pair of kakushi ram into him with some
cars yelling at him to die as karate
orders them to all fall back muzan
crushes the cars and attempts to crawl
forward finding his way blocked by some
tram cars held by more kikushi amazon
attempts to overcome this hurdle as well
as he slowly begins to sizzle as mozan
attempts to crush the kakushi behind the
tram cars with his first cry orders them
to fall back and stay alive sunimi
intervenes and slices off muzon's right
arm with wind breathing ninth form eaten
typhoon however the cut was too shallow
to do any more damage as muzan continues
to try and climb over the cars to avoid
dying kyomei throws his chain around the
demon's neck and with the help of some
kakushi pulling on him the stoneheshira
attempts to pull the demon down onto the
ground with brute force he successfully
does so and cry yells for the demon to
finally burn and disintegrate as kawana
ubishiki prays for their victory
determined not to die muzan continues
his resistance and begins to dig
underground to avoid the sunlight geyu
and sunimi work in tandem to attack the
demon and strike him with water
breathing tenth form constant flux and
wind-breathing fifth form cold mountain
wind they are joined by obanai who
unleashes the serpent breathing fourth
form twin-headed reptile but all three
are only able to inflict minor damage
with everyone at their limits
guillermo's chain shatters and muzan
begins to crawl deeper down with the
others left too exhausted to further
impede him suddenly tanjunu tightens his
grip on his blade and attacks muzan from
the inside causing him to rear up in
agony going straight up into the
sunlight and the demon finally begins to
disintegrate as he cries out the sun
rises on a new day as muzan kibitsuji
finally disintegrates and everyone
heaves a sigh of relief crying as their
battle is finally over kara ubiyashiki
orders for the injuries of the wounded
to be tended to before passing out
himself gyome refuses to accept any help
from the junior demon slayers or kakushi
and asks for the injuries of the younger
fighters to be tended to first as he
knows that his fate is inevitable he
begins to see all of the children he
used to care for at the temple appear
before him and they tell him they had
always wanted to apologize for the day
they had been attacked by the demon
saying that they knew they had hurt him
they explained that they had not
intended to run away but were instead
trying to protect him as he was the
blind one one child says that he was
trying to go outside to get farming
tools as a weapon while another say she
had been trying to go and call for help
gummy hears their explanations and
accepts them as they continue on and
tell him that they also had a reason for
driving out kagaku their nigh which they
would have not told him about had they
lived till the morning was fully wishing
the next they had dawned for the
children as well gyome apologizes to
them for being unable to protect them
the children tell him not to apologize
saying that they love him and that they
had been waiting for him this entire
time thanking them gyome says that they
can all now move on together and passes
away with a smile on his face leaving
the kakushi in tears matsuri comes to
and finds herself in open eyes arms and
asks him if they had won
he tells her that they did and she is
relieved but tells him that she could
not feel anything more and that she
would die soon urbana responds that he
would also be dying soon and that she
wouldn't be alone anguished at this she
tells him not to die apologizing for not
being of much use in the fights
reporting though that that was not true
obinna reminds her of the first time
they met when matsuri had gotten lost in
the mansion and she recalls that obanai
had helped her overnight rebuffs saying
that it was the other way around and
that she had been the one who saved him
he tells her that despite all of the
troubles she had gone through to become
a hashira she had still been so normal
when they admits and that she was still
capable of enjoying the things around
her like a regular human being the said
made obinna feel like a regular boy as
well as he cherished his time with her
saying that he was sure the other
heshira had felt the same way he tells
her that her cheerfulness had saved many
people around her and that she had not
been useless at all but sudhi begins to
cry and says that meals had tasted
better with obanai as he had always
looked at her with great affection she
asks him if she could be his bride if
they are ever reborn and obono replies
that she could definitely be if she
would have him as hers and that he would
make her happy and protect her meanwhile
sanemi sees a vision of genya and his
siblings all playing together happily in
heaven but looks around for his mother
who is nowhere to be seen turning behind
to his right he senses his mother shizu
shinozugawa standing there and pulls her
hand from the darkness telling her to
join her children however she refuses
saying that she didn't deserve to go to
heaven as she had attacked her children
smiling serenely sanemi tells her that
he would go along with her saying that
genya would be saddened to see him so
soon he attempts to go with her but her
hand is wrenched away by his father who
says that he would be the one
accompanying their mother sanemi yells
at his father to let go of his mother
but he simply responds that sanemi isn't
ready to die yet and that he was extra
tough senemy regains consciousness and
the kakushia overjoyed to see this
inosuke regains consciousness as well
and bites a kakushi who attempted to
help him while coughing up blood zenitsu
tells the kakushi tending to him to tell
nezuko that he loved her and was brave
fighting to the very end calling her his
wife as others point out that he's
actually not married giu gets up and
tries to find tajiro but looks forward
to see the boy as kneeling still holding
his blade and having bled heavily after
losing his arm the kakushi tearfully
informed geyu that tantra was no longer
breathing and had no pulse gee was
greatly saddened tearing up and kneeling
down in front of tanjuro he grabs the
boy's remaining hand and apologizes for
having failed to protect him he was
always the one who ended up receiving
protection he apologizes to niziko for
being unable to protect her brother not
knowing that she had arrived at this
scene and was carefully running for her
brother from behind him as death dwells
muzan kivatsuji recounts how death had
always been close to him and that his
heart had stopped many times even while
he had been inside of his mother's womb
he had been stubborn but when he was
about to be cremated he suddenly began
writhing around and crying for the first
time and thus had been spared the demon
feels relieved as he says that he had
finally achieved what he had been
waiting to make happen for so long
admitting that what he could do on his
own was limited he thinks of kakaya
ubishiki and concedes that what the
master had told him was correct saying
that everything that lives must die and
their only feelings were external muzan
says that he did not remember even a
single human being he had killed but
their feelings had passed on and stayed
alive even managing to conquer him being
moved to tears at the fact that the
feelings of all the people had
vanquished him muzana's resigned to his
inevitable fate however he says that his
own feelings are external and undying
just like anyone else's and he extends
his hand towards tangero who was there
with him and still alive as he gives all
of his blood to tajiro muzan says that
if the boy survived this he would become
the strongest demon ever since he was
the brother of niziko kamado the first
demon to develop an immunity to sunlight
and also the one capable of using the
breath style of yoroichitsukiguni
as he slowly disintegrates muzan tells
tanjiro to make his dream come true and
destroy the demon seiko in his place as
giu tomioka kneels in front of tanjuro
and the surrounding kakushi shed tears
one of them subtly gapes in shock as the
tumor from tangier's head disappears and
he opens his eyes to reveal a demonic
gaze to everyone's shock tanjunu
regenerates his left arm and swipes at
the kakushi next to him bugi reacts
quickly and pushes the kikushi out of
harm's way the other kokushi look on
interfere and ask why tanjuro is acting
in such a manner the boy stands drooling
profusely enjoying his newfound fangs
and claws his demon's layer mark mutates
and goes down to move past the bridge of
his nose with another identical mark
growing upwards from the bottom of his
neck almost to meet in the middle
similar to kokoshibo's mark giu rushes
forward and yells at the other kakushi
to get away from tanchiro as the boy
looks to swipe adam suddenly the sun
shines brightly from the sky and tanjuro
double takes to look at her he begins to
burn and writhe on the ground with his
swipe at the kakushi going off target
but still managing to rip off the lower
half of his mask as gee gets in front of
the kakushi he tells him to run away as
he prepares to face this new threat
yelling for everyone who was still
conscious to grab weapons and begin
fighting everyone else looks on from
afar with confusion at the sudden
commotion unaware of tanjiru's fate when
giu suddenly announces to them that
tanjido has become a demon he says that
they need to pin tanjiru down and burn
him in the sun before he could kill
anyone tanjido suddenly attempts to find
shade to stop burning but giulio
intercepts him by stabbing him from the
side and dragging him into the ground
with the boy clutching at his hair
noting to himself that if he had not
been interrupted by the sun tangential
would have surely killed the kikushi he
u wastefully begs in his mind for
tanjiru to stay who he was and die as a
human
suddenly tanju stops burning and gu
looks on in shock as the boy takes
advantage of the heshira's surprise to
swipe at him he narrowly dodges but his
chin is grazed and tajiro follows up
with another swipe that is intercepted
by inosuke who yells at his friend and
asks him what he is doing geru attempts
to stand up but feels dizzy from his
blood loss and cannot do so yanovsky
stands over him and tries to remind
tanjido that geyu is the ally azinetsu
also approaches the saiyan supported by
kakushi tajiru crouches down and a third
demonstrator mark appears from the other
right side of the head and he bears
fangs at inosuke who can only look on
quietly at what has become of his best
friend zenitsu looks on and disbelief at
the scene and says that everyone else is
tired and unable to continue fighting
asking for tanchiro to think of niziko
tanjo leaps forward to attack inosuke
who prepares to fight him inosuke thinks
back to his time together with tanjido
and says that they are all comrades like
brothers who would pull each other back
if one of them started going down the
wrong path stealing himself by thinking
that no matter how difficult it was they
would always walk down the right path
zenetsu yells at tanchiro to stop as
inosuke thinks to himself that he would
strike tanjiru down and stop him himself
suddenly hit by a memory of tantrudo
offering him some fish to eat together
with a smile on his face enosuke stops
mid-swipe at tangero's neck and is
unable to complete his attack tearing up
insane that it was no use and that he
could not attack tanjiro geyu inosuke
and zunitsu look on in shock as neziko
runs forward and hugs the now demonified
tanjido as he sinks his claws and fangs
into his sister she begins to bleed out
but tanturo does not proceed to drink
her blood crying niziko hugs tanjo and
apologizes to him for all the hardships
he had to endure to make her human again
she encourages him to resist becoming a
demon and says that going through all of
the suffering was quite difficult but to
never give up as nezuko tells him to
come with her tangero starts sinking his
claws in deeper and lets out a wild howl
inosuke anzanitsu rush forward to help
naziko to try and bring their friend
back zenitsu grabs tanjuro from behind
and begs him to stop hurting mizuko and
that she had become human again as he
tells him that she might die if he
continued further tanjiru lets out
another howl but this time is
interrupted by nosuke repeatedly hitting
him on the head saying that tanjore was
not the kind of person who would hurt
his sister enosuke tells his friend to
snap out of it and to go back to being
his kind usual self angered tangero lets
out another feral howl and sends a shock
wave that flings enosukes sinitsu and
gee you back as nizikou desperately
clings on to her brother she falls to
the ground as tanjo gets on all fours
and releases bone whips similar to those
of muzan's from his back she begs him to
keep fighting his newfound demonic
tendencies however he still swings a
whip towards the netsu geyu intercepts
the attack by performing the
water-breathing fourth form striking
tide saving zinetsu and the kakushi
propping him up thinking to himself
their things have progressed too far
with tantru having bitten into niziko
and learning the taste of blood kieru
aims to kill tanjudo however the water
hishera acknowledges that neither bright
red blades nor the sun will work on
tanjuro anymore leaving him virtually
indestructible suddenly tangero charges
a ball of pure energy from his mouth
nezuko sees this and desperately tries
to stop his brother from committing any
murders telling him that he has to stop
niziko puts her hand in front of
tantra's mouth to block the attack and
it goes off course hitting the ground
instead gee was able to dodge as zenitsu
calls out to niziko in concern her
entire left hand and forearm begin to
bleed profusely as a result of blocking
the attack and she yells at her brother
to stop as he gets on all fours
attempting to stop him from using his
whips nisiko puts her hand on her
brother's back and tangero is only able
to strike the ground again looking on in
shock understanding begins to dawn on
giulio as he sees that somewhere inside
tangerine was fighting his demonic urges
as he was avoiding doing any lethal
damage to nizuko geru decides to try and
bring tanchiro back to his senses though
he is unsure he would be able to perform
such a miraculous feed meanwhile from
behind the shade of a nearby building
yoshido looks on at the scene cursing
muzan for continuing to torment people
even after his death seeing that his
blood demon art would disintegrate with
sunlight yushiro feels powerless to stop
the carnage suddenly he sees kano
lumping forward to the scene of the
battle looking on at the sights of the
two siblings kano tears up and feels
sorry for them she reaches for the vial
of medicine in her front pocket and is
relieved to find it undamaged thinking
back to when she received it from
shinobu kano remembers the former insect
ashira telling her that she made an
extra vial of tamiya's medicine and the
fear that there might not be enough left
for nizoko once things had settled she
tells shinobu that this must be the
reason why she has still got one eye
quickly analyzing tangido kano assesses
that since he had only just become a
demon she would be able to dodge his
attacks even with just one eye kano
activates the flower breathing final
form equinential vermilion eye and
charges towards tanchito with guillotine
a double take and recognising the move
as kane's tanjulo swipes at kano but she
evades it by backflipping over the boy
and injects the medicine into him just
as he redirects his arm and then slashes
at her torso as she begins to bleed kano
tells tangido that it is enough and it
is time for him to come back to them
saying that he must not make mizuko cry
kano falls to the ground will they thud
as something begins to stir inside
tangento's consciousness upon hearing
niziko's name and the medicine begins to
take effect niziko tearfully calls out
to her brother to return so that they
may finally return home tangero stirs in
his subconscious and responds that he is
very tired and wishes to go home as well
tanjiru prays to the god to return home
saying he only wants to go home with his
little sister but as he raises his arm
to reach forward eyes grow on the flesh
growths that cover his body and begin to
speak the voice of muzan attempts to
dissuade tanchiro from returning to his
loved ones asking what would happen
after he returned to them muzan tells
him that his entire family is dead and
that there is no point in returning home
batantri responds that he still has
memories of the happy days there he
tells the demon lord that their memories
will never disappear as long as he and
niziko are still alive and that is why
he has to go back tantrido continues to
slowly reach forward as muzan tries
harder to dissuade tanchito he lies to
him and says that the boy has killed
nisiko unpersuaded tangita calls muzan's
bluff and says that niziko is alive
telling him he lies his deceased friends
then all give him a push to the back to
raise him up muzan tells them not to
interfere and continues to try and
mislead tangido saying that they all now
hate him and don't want him to return
for what he has done after becoming a
demon muzan continues to try and
discourage the young demon slayer but
tangier responds that he wants to
apologize to everyone for hurting them
and muzanra taught saying that they
would not forgive him then telling the
demon slayer that it was not for him to
decide batajira perseveres and continues
to move forward saying that he could
smell all of his friends being concerned
for him growing more frustrated muzan
tells tanchodo to be silent and says
that he is the inheritor of his will so
he should not look forward or try to
find any hope but instead should embrace
life as a demon telling the boy that he
would die in a few short years because
he had manifested their demon say a mark
muzan urges him to think only of himself
and live forever however the boy refuses
and says that he never wanted to live
forever and that he only wanted to
return to his friends and live as a
human admittedly refusing to give up on
trying to mislead tanchito muzan tries
to manipulate him further and asks if
the boy really wishes to return to her
life after everyone else has died
grabbing the head of tangido in his
hands he asks tanjido if he wants to
live on without losing anything more
hands push tanchiro forward and he
smells the scent of wisteria flowers at
first believing it is shinobu kocho he
tears up as he sees nezuko's arms
reaching out for him reaching forward
himself to meet her tantra grabs
nezuko's hand and she attempts to pull
him forward but muzan grabs his arm and
tries to force him away saying that they
had finally conquered the sun and that
tanjuro would go with him saying that he
was a rare being muzan tells him to hear
the cries of the dead and that they all
resented him for being the only one who
could move on and keep his life
rebuffing this tundra says that they
were not such people and that instead
they had been willing to sacrifice their
lives for others saying that while they
were sad and suffered they did not wish
their fathers as tanjunu begins to be
taken away muzan grabs at his torso and
tries to pull him back but in vain as
the hands of geyu zenitsu andy nosuke
join nezuko to pull him up as even more
hands reach out to pull tanjaro up muzan
finally loses his grip and tanjura
regains consciousness to find nezuko
looking down at him with tears in her
eyes with his friends and the kokushi
surrounding him nezuko calls out
tanjuro's name and he apologizes to
everyone for having brought them harm
everyone begins to cheer upon hearing
his voice and inosuke tells tanjido that
he hadn't caused him any significant
harm at all sinitsu begins sobbing and
says that he would make tanjudo pay for
his entire life for what he had done to
him and calls nezuko his wife much to
her shock and consternation
geru heaves a sigh of relief and a
kakushi holds him to keep him stable as
nezuko hugs her brother they both smile
through the tears and the kakushi wakes
kano up to tell her the good news kanye
regains consciousness and smiles as she
looks on at tanjuro with tanjuru
thinking to himself that he was glad
that she was still alive enosuke grabs
tanjo's head and begins to sob as
yushira pulls out tamiya's hairpin and
begins to weep saying that it was all
finally over
three months after the battle against
muzan the world is now free of evil
demons and the survivors of the battle
continue living despite all they lost
tanjuri recovers at the butterfly
mansion and sees the cherry blossoms in
bloom alongside niziko inosuke and
zinitsu sleep peacefully at the other
end of tanjor's beard as niziko says
that their flowers look very pretty
examining tanjido's left hand now
horribly shriveled neziko asks her
brother how it feels and he responds
that he cannot feel anything on his left
arm beneath his elbow so he cannot use
the hand anymore then he points to his
right eye and says that while it looks
okay he cannot see anything out of it
tangier asks niziko how she is doing and
she responds with a beaming smile that
she feels perfectly fine still feeling
guilty though over how being attacked
her when he was a demon tanjito
apologizes to niziko for attacking her
niziko pouts and says that no one cares
if he turned into a demon and attacked
everyone saying that she was just glad
he was human again she tells him that if
he apologizes for it again she would
flick him on his forehead he tells her
that giu told him he feared all was lost
when tanju had bit nezuko and she laughs
saying she had felt the same way then he
tells her that you shiro had told him
that it was quite lucky actually because
they had shinobu kochi's medicine with
them and because nezuko had already been
a demon before she had also developed an
immunity to muzan's cells
these words fly over nezuko's head as
tanjura reiterates what yushiro had told
him the demon had told tanjudo that had
they not shinobu's medicine or had
nezuko not been the one that he had
bitten then he may have never become
human again yoshiro had been impressed
that tanjo hadn't completely lost
himself since he had been more powerful
than either muzan or neziko even
conquering his son in an instant he told
tanjido that he admired him for having
fought valiantly and the boy had
stammered over his words at the
compliments modestly saying that he had
received a lot of help yushiro had told
him that it was a joke and not to take
it seriously before picking up
chachumaru and leaving
tanjuro had called out to him before he
left though asking him to stay alive and
to not die as he was the only one who
could keep tamiya's memory alive tangero
had not heard from the demons since then
and was getting slightly worried about
him suddenly remembering giyu he asks
nezuko where he is and she responds that
he is all right and was with karaya ubia
shiki meanwhile korya began the final
hashera meeting with the two remaining
hashera guiyu tomioka and tsunemi
shinozugawa both in attendance quraya
announces that the demon slayer corps
was disbanding from that moment on the
ubishikis expressed their gratitude to
the hashera and the demon slayers for
their centuries of service and bow
before them with both hashera protesting
this telling the ubishikis that they
were the one that kept the core together
and that they did not want any thanks
the hashera instead expressed their
gratitude towards the ubeashikis giu
tells coria that he was excellent at his
job and that his father and ancestors
would be proud and the ubyashiki tears
up at these words as kariah thanks
guilty for his compliment the two
hashira look on at each other and smile
as their long journey had finally ended
meanwhile tenkan uzue and his three
wives visit tanjiro being glared to meet
them again suma rushes forward to greet
nezuko and starts loudly doting over the
girl so much that makio hits her for
being too loud much to her frustration
she asks tenkan if he saw makio hit her
but he responds that he missed it tengen
tells tanjiro to visit them when he got
better giving them their address and
hinatsuru handed him a snack shinjuru
speaks with tanjido and thanks him for
using kyogioro's handguard on his blade
during the final battle saying it would
have made his son quite happy tanjuru
humbly replies that kyoujido's words had
been quite inspiring for him and that
they had helped him throughout his
journey cenaxin suddenly wakes up and
finds that these swordsmiths are waiting
outside of tanjuro's room saying that
they come every day and creep him out
his shock only grows as a group of
kokushi also arrive and they all enter
the room filling it to the brim they
need to hold on to tangido oh my god man
zunitsu holds on to tangido scared at
the turn of the event as tanjiru smiles
at the sight of more of his comrades
meanwhile inosuke sneaks away into the
kitchen and grabs his snack as aoi is
busy cooking he swipes some of the food
and she catches him saying he was
stealing again and then offered him a
plate of prepared food telling him to
stop stealing food inosuke is quite
impressed at how quickly she caught him
and wonders if she's strong and then
smiles serenely as he begins to dig into
the food presented to him kano stands in
the garden in front of a cherry blossom
tree and tanjiru comes to meet her
saying it was a beautiful tree she tells
him that it was called victory and had
been planted by the first user of their
flower breathing and she had come to
tell it that they had finally defeated
muzan tangero asks her how she is doing
and she responds that she still has some
vision left in her eyes and that her
wound was better saying that even sunimi
had given her urbanized pet snake kiba
romaro to take care of as the serpent
slithers out of her collar sanemi meets
nezuko and she greets him asking him how
his injuries were to which he responds
that they are fine sanemi apologizes to
niziko for having passed out after
muzan's defeat
leaving them to deal with tangido on
their own but she cheerfully responded
that it was no trouble and that she had
once passed out for two whole years
saying that it was nothing compared to
that she then says that she loved
sleeping which makes anemi think of
genya shinozugawa when he was a child
and when he had told tsunemi that he
loved sleeping because he didn't get
hungry
sanemi smiles and pats in izuko's head
telling her to take care as inetsu
jealously looked on from around the
corner of the hallway and raged at
tsunemi's actions tanjiro and nizikou
find guil and sekonji and greet them
glad to finally be reunited later on
they go and pay their respects at the
graves of olivier fallen before they
depart the butterfly mansion for the
kamado residents sinetri complains that
it will take all day but refuses to let
inosuke do it with his faster method
saying he will not pay proper respect
once they were finished and on their way
to the kamado household enosuke asks
zinitsu what he was carrying on his back
as zenitsu responded that it was his
gramps's remains puzzled and oscar asked
what remains are and if they are edible
to zunitsu's disgust on their way back
they meet saburo one of the people who
had lived near the kamado family and he
greets them tearfully when they had
arrived back at the kamado household
they found flowers are growing outside
the house and they pay their respects to
the other kamados by kneeling in front
of the flowers and praying they begin
their new life at the kamado household
and time leaps forward to a large modern
city
we see a large modern city three
generations in the future kanata kamado
who resembles kano in appearance is the
great great grandson of tanjido and kano
and the eldest son of the kamado family
as he tries to wake his younger brother
sumihiko up who almost looks exactly
like a young tanjido he tells him that
he will be late for school however
sumihiko sleepily responds that he is
already up but kanata sees that he is
barely awake and leaves for school on
his own leaving sumahiko to deal with
waking up himself over at the future
agatsuma household yoshiteru reads the
legend of zenitsu a supposed
autobiography of his great-grandfather
zenetsu agatsuma and cries when he
reaches the part where they defeated
muzan kibitsuji suddenly his sister toko
who resembles their great-grandmother
nezuko kicks yoshitero in their back and
tells them to stop reading their great
grandfather's novel of lies and to focus
on his study as his grades had been
unruly low he objects to being sent to
go study but toko twists his ear and
tells him that the demon's lair studied
too which he uses in a way to trick him
into following suit with the two also
only being great-grandchildren this
proves the fact that both zinitsu and
nezuko lived long lives together
azinitsu himself never achieved the
demon slayer mark and thus would have
not died before the age of 25 as the two
of them make their way to school
together yoshiteru thinks to himself how
the other woman and his family were all
quiet and polite batoco was nothing like
them with an annoyed expression he asked
toko if she believed in reincarnation
and she merely snapped at him asking
what he was making such an expression
for yoshitiro then said while something
like that was hard to prove conclusively
it was his belief that everyone who had
died while fighting the demons for a
peaceful world had found some kind of
path to happiness toku ignores him and
looks at the news alert on her phone
with admiration which declares that an
athlete called tenma uzui had won a gold
medal in gymnastics for japan at only 20
years of age taking his ancestor tink
and uzui's appearance into style and
physique yoshitiru says that tenma was a
rude and nasty person but toku defends
him and says that it was truly possible
to get away with anything if one was as
good looking and of course as flashy as
he is another news story catches
yoshiteru's eye and he snatches toko's
phone from her much to her irritation he
opens the story about a beautiful
looking botanist called ayoba hashibera
who had discovered a real flower called
the blue spider lily ayoba is the
great-grandson of inosuke hashibera and
aoi kanzaki who also would have lived
long fulfilling lives together just like
zenitsu and niziko it also reveals the
true reasoning behind why museum would
have never been able to achieve his goal
of finding the blue spot early as it was
an extremely rare plant that only
bloomed during the day on occasion every
few years and for two or three days
every year making it near impossible for
muzan to achieve his actual goal
obviously though we never know and this
could have possibly changed if he had
formed some kind of relationship with a
human who could have searched for it
during the day which thankfully never
happened though sadly though in the
future ayoba had come under intense
criticism following a mistake in their
handling of the lilies which caused them
all to wither and he was forced to
apologize at a press conference
yoshitiro denounces this attitude
towards such a stunning and beautiful
woman but toku corrects him and tells
him that aoba is in fact a man much to
his shock and disgust as the two
continued onward they encountered a
woman pushing two strollers with twin
children in them they were wrapped in
nice miss padded blankets and had black
hair reminiscent of the toquito twins
muchiro and yuchiro yushitiro taking on
the personality of zenitsu asked if they
were girls or not and toko said he was
creepy to which he cried out and
declared that he was not creepy at all
the two then pass a pair of female
students and yoshiteru immediately
recognizes that they are from the nearby
sakura women's academy with the two
students having an exact likeness to
that of kane kocho and shinobu toku
looks at her brother with extreme
disappointment but is quickly distracted
when she spots kanata she eagerly runs
over to tell him he looked cute with
kanata returning the compliment to her
delight joshuiteru mutters that he had
been learning how to cast curses and
says that they should watch out but toku
angrily tells him to repeat himself and
what she quickly apologizes as his voice
begins to tremble they then cross next
to the kindergarten and yoshiteru stares
at the teacher who happens to look
exactly like gyome but also notes that
he looked funny in his pink apron toko
asks kanata if he wants to go with her
to a certain diner on their way home
kanata asks if she meant the one with
the snake decor and the giant serving
sizes to which toko confirms and canada
responds that he is unsure if he could
ever show his face there again he shares
the story of when he was last at their
store with yoshiteru the boy had been
completely transfixed with the woman's
chest who had worked there obviously
this woman just happened to resemble the
volumptuous matsuri her husband who also
worked in the store got mad and had
thrown a knife at him and of course he
looked like no one other than obanai
also finally fulfilling the wish that
the two had made on their deathbeards
toko turns around to yoshiteru in
disgust and rage as the boy stammers
claiming that this was a false
accusation and that he was not looking
at her chest back at the kamado
household sumihiko finally wakes up and
notices that he was running late
wondering why no one had come in and
woken him up he then gets ready for
school and dives out of his window to
the bottom of their apartment and
sprints for his school on his way he
passes a house with two elderly men
playing shogi they bear a resemblance
and wear robes similar to that of
sekonji and jigoros they yell out at
sumahiko asking him why he did this
every morning meanwhile on the old men's
television a news report began about an
ubiyashiki who had set the record for
the eldest living japanese person this
ubishiki is actually karaya meaning that
over a century after muzan's defeat
karaya is still alive and the oldest
living person in japan being at least
108 years old the fact that he lives so
long is amazing proof that the illness
which previously cursed their family is
now long gone with muzan when quran
first learnt about the curse being
broken he didn't believe it but as he
grew past the age of 20 and then 30 it
cemented to him that the curse was truly
gone this made him cry for hours
alongside his wife children and sisters
sumahiko continues racing and while
running he runs past the store called
haganezuka maintenance and three girls
who recognize him as the running man
these girls all closely resemble sumi
kio and naho as sumihiko arrives at a
traffic light that had just gone green
he attempts to jump over the hood of a
police car to avoid having to stop which
startles the policemen inside who both
look like the brothers tsunemi and genya
the policeman resembling genya is
actually his descendant and is incensed
and believes that sumahiko must be the
one they have had seven reports of they
attempt to chase after him but sumahiko
dashes off even faster he crosses a
group of three children bearing a
resemblance to our boy tomioka and his
best friends sabito and makomo the boy
resembling tomioka is named geichi and
is a confirmed descendant of gius
probably a great great grandson just
like sumihiko is of tanjuro the boys
have some rare toys which are shaped
like the masks once made by sakonji for
his pupils the girl says she has spent
all her allowance luckily though they
give her one of theirs so that she can
have one as well at the school yoshitaro
watches as a boy named goto looks at his
phone at an image of a beautiful woman
who looks just like tamiyo yoshiteru
interrupts the boy and his friend says
that he recognizes that as one of the
paintings of yushiro yamamoto which is
obviously the only remaining demon alive
yushiro who has followed through with
tanjuro's last wishes to him and kept
the memory of tamiya alive through the
paintings of her in the future yoshiro
had begun to receive acclaim throughout
the world for his paintings of tamiyo
which was said to be like photographs
yoshitiro notes that yushiro would
attempt to shoot at any reporters who
came to ask him questions but mentions
that his first love was number 812 tamio
with dark blue flowers he then walks off
leaving the two boys bewildered at him
and his personality sumihiko continues
to run and is joined by tojiro one of
the descendants from rengoku's bloodline
tojiro even resembles kyogiro
specifically with his fiery hair
greeting the boy sumahiko says that it's
unusual for him to be late and togiro
explains that he woke up at 4 am but got
absorbed into his training throughout
the morning he says that he couldn't
hear anything until his father whacked
him suddenly the police car from before
draws nearer to the boys pestering
sumihiko for him to stop tojiro tells
sumihiko that he should get into a sport
but he responds that it will just cut
into his sleeping time tajiro is adamant
though that he would be great at
whatever sport he picked they keep
running even as police keep up their
chase with them in their car the police
are screaming at them to stop as they
arrive at their high school we're a
teacher who looks just like the demon
slayer corps member morata asks for the
gate to be closed as soon as he sees
sumehiko the person at the gate says
that there are still three minutes
before it should close but the teacher
insists that sumihiko is a habitual
offender as the gate begins to shut
sumehiko says that he believes they will
make it in time and togiro agrees both
of them glide over the gate and land
inside of the school running for their
classes the police car comes to a
screeching halt and the officer looking
like sanemi walks over to the gate and
tells the teacher that they need to talk
ayoba sits on a bench in the park and
notes how it is a quiet day saying he
wishes he could live a quiet life alone
in the mountains back at the kamado
residence sumahiko's mother receives a
phone call and is told of her son's
doing being highly surprised and
apologizing for the trouble her son had
caused next to her on the wall we see a
katana that is actually tangible's black
mature and blade with kyogiro's flame
helped still attached just above the
blade hang some photographs and an old
yellowing picture of all of those who
would survive the battle against muzan
smiling happily together and the two
hanafuda earrings of yarowichitsugiguni
hanging right next to them as this
series finally comes to its end
you